THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME. WE
HAVE 29 MEASURES ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AND WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR MEMBERS TO GET OVER HERE
FROM CAUCUS, PRIMARILY FROM
CAUCUS, WE WILL TRY TO GET
STARTED. WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
FOR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES EACH
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. EACH
WITNESS WILL INDIVIDUALLY HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND ANY ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL ASK
YOU TO LIMIT YOURSELVES TO NAME
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. ALSO, I WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT ITEM FOUR, AB 1958
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA BY
THE AUTHOR. AND LASTLY, SENATOR
PORTANTINO, WHO IS REGULARLY A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE, WILL
NOT BE HERE TODAY. HE'S BEING
REPLACED BY SENATOR LAIRD. WE
HAVE 12 MEASURES PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. I'M GOING TO GO OVER
THESE NOW. WE'LL GO OVER THEM
AGAIN LATER WHEN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THEM UP ON A
CONSENT CALENDAR. BUT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE FOLLOWING ITEM THREE, AB
2401 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING,
ITEM SEVEN AB 1978 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANCHEZ. ITEM EIGHT AB
2082 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. ITEM 11 AB 2130 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. ITEM
12 AB 2186 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALLACE. ITEM 17 AB 2645 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. ALSO
ITEM 1820 AB 2879 ALSO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. ITEM 21
AB 2817 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DIXON. ITEM 23 AB 2900 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SARRIA. ITEM 25
AB 3102 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
HOOVER. ITEM 28 AB 3278 BY
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND ITEM 29 SCR 159 BY
SENATOR HURTADO AND THEN WHEN
THERE ARE SUFFICIENT NUMBERS, OF
COURSE, WE'LL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, AND AT SOME POINT WE'LL
TAKE UP A MOTION ON THOSE
CONSENT ITEMS. IN ONE MOTION. I
DON'T KNOW WHERE. NUMBERS ON
THAT PAGE. ALL RIGHT. WE
UNDERSTAND AND VERY CLEARLY WE
HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS ON THEIR
WAY ALL AT THE SAME TIME, SO
THIS SHOULD FILL UP QUICKLY, THE
FIRST AUTHOR, THIS IS ON AB 637
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON. YOU
MAY COME FORWARD AND BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION WHEN READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AND I'LL HAVE MY WITNESS.
COME ON UP, SPONSOR. HERE WE GO.
COME ON UP. ALL RIGHT. I AM
PLEASED TO BE BEFORE YOU TODAY,
PRESENTING AB 637, WHICH IS A
COMMONSENSE BILL SEEKING TO
ENCOURAGE FLEETS SUBJECT TO THE
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET REGULATION
TO RENT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
TRUCKS OVER DIESEL TRUCKS. AB
637 INTENDS TO ADDRESS A GAP IN
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT FOR
THOSE WHO MAY NOT USE FLEETS
REGULARLY, THESE TRUCKS
REGULARLY OR NOT HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL WHEREWITHAL TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE THEM OUTRIGHT.
THIS IS A PRACTICAL OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKING SURE THAT NO MATTER
HOW THE VEHICLES ARE ACQUIRED,
THAT THEY ARE CERTAINLY USED,
AND WITH ME TODAY IS MANDY LEE
REPRESENTING THE BILL'S SPONSOR
AND SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
637. I WELCOME YOU'LL HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES. YOU MAY
PROCEED. GREAT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MANDY ISAACS LEE OMNI
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HERE ON
BEHALF OF ENTERPRISE MOBILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 637, I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR AN
EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT ANALYSIS ON
THIS BILL. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE,
WHICH IS IN FURTHERANCE OF
CARB'S ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET RULE
AND WOULD ENABLE REGULATED
FLEETS TO RENT ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS AND HAVE THAT RENTAL
COUNT TOWARDS THEIR COMPLIANCE
OF THE ACF. AS ADOPTED, THE ACF
ALLOWS FOR FLEETS TO LEASE A
ZERO EMISSION TRUCK FOR A YEAR
OR MORE AND HAVE THAT COUNTED
TOWARDS THEIR COMPLIANCE.
HOWEVER, THE ACF DOES NOT
CONTEMPLATE SHORTER TERM RENTALS
OF LESS THAN A YEAR. THIS BILL
CLOSES THAT GAP AND ALLOWS
FLEETS TO RENT A ZERO EMISSION
TRUCK AND ALSO RECEIVE
COMPLIANCE CREDIT. IMPORTANTLY,
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS, AB
637 WILL INCENTIVIZE A FLEET TO
RENT A ZERO EMISSION TRUCK OVER
A DIESEL ONE. A SHARED GOAL OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THIS IS A MODEST
BUT IMPORTANT PROPOSAL THAT
REALLY HAS DUAL BENEFITS TO THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY. NUMBER ONE,
IT ENABLES FLEETS COMPLIANCE,
FLEXIBILITY, AND TWO, TO DRIVE
CRITICAL DEMAND TO THE RENTAL
INDUSTRY SO THAT THE ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO PROCURE DON'T SIT IDLE
ON OUR LOTS. WE'RE CONSIDERED A
HIGH PRIORITY FLEET UNDER THE
ACF, AND THEREFORE WE WILL HAVE
TO PROCURE ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
PURSUANT TO THE MILESTONES SET
FORTH IN THE RULE. BUT IF WE
DON'T CLOSE THIS RULE, THIS HOLE
IN THIS RULE, THERE WON'T LIKELY
BE DEMAND FOR OUR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS, ESPECIALLY IN THE NEAR
TERM. GIVEN THE LACK OF
SUFFICIENT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WHEN ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS SIT IDLE ON OUR
LOTS, THEY DO NOT CONTRIBUTE TO
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF ACF, WE SURVEYED OUR
CUSTOMERS AND HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR, PARTICULARLY FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CLIENTS WHO FACE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE CHALLENGES
PURCHASING NEW ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS THAT THEY WANT. THIS
OPTION TO RENT FROM US. THIS
BILL WILL HELP INCENTIVIZE
FLEETS TO RENT ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS, RATHER THAN RENT ICE
VEHICLES. IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH THE ACF, THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES THUS FAR,
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
COME FORWARD WITH A SUPPORT
POSITION? YOU MAY DO SO NOW.
THIS IS NAME, AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT ONLY, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. CHRIS
SHIMODA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
KAI COOPER ON BEHALF OF EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT AND
CALSTART IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WALID HAJJAJ, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AFTERNOON. MARK
NEUBERGER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU TO OPPOSITION. NOW I SEE WE
HAVE SOME OPPOSITION ON THE
BILLS IN OPPOSITION TO WITNESS
HERE. IF SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD
. YES. PLEASE COME FORWARD. YES.
AND YOU'LL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH. YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. VICTORIA, ROME WITH
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL OR NRDC, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. AND WE I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE IN JUST A
MOMENT FOR MORE SPECIFICS. BUT I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT, OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS, WE HAVE
HAD PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND,
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARD THE SAME GOALS, WHICH IS
CLEAN AIR AND LOWER EMISSIONS
FOR THE STATE. BUT WE DO AS AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. WE DO OPPOSE
THE BILL, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
CORTEZ AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GUILLERMO ORTIZ, AND I'M
THE POLICY LEAD ON MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. RESPECTFULLY, I EXPRESS
OUR OPPOSITION TO AB 637. WHILE
WE FULLY SUPPORT REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
PROMOTING THE DEVELOPMENT, THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES, AB 637 AS DRAFTED
COULD UNDERMINE THESE GOALS BY
ALLOWING FLEET OWNERS TO COUNT
RENTALS OF 260 CUMULATIVE DAYS
PER YEAR AS OWNERSHIP. THE BILL
MAY ENCOURAGE SHORT TERM RENTALS
OVER THE PURCHASE AND
INTEGRATION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. THIS SHIFT WOULD
WEAKEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL,
ECONOMIC, AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS INTENDED BY THE
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEETS RULE.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 637 WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD OR CARB TO
REVISE EXISTING FLEET RULES,
POTENTIALLY CAUSING CONFUSION
AND INSTABILITY. CARB WOULD NEED
TO UPDATE ITS DATA REPORTING AND
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS TO COMPLY
WITH THE NEW REQUIREMENTS,
COMPLICATING COMPLIANCE FOR
RENTAL COMPANIES AND FLEET
OWNERS. FURTHERMORE, EXEMPTING
THESE CHANGES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
RAISES CONCERNS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. THE APA ENSURES
REGULATORY CHANGES, UNDERGO
PUBLIC INPUT, AND RIGOROUS
REVIEW, MAINTAINING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
. SKIPPING THIS PROCESS
UNDERMINES THE ENGAGEMENT OF
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
SPENT YEARS ADVOCATING FOR THE
ACF RULE AND BEAR THE BRUNT OF
POLLUTION CAUSED BY MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. IF THE BILL
REMAINS AS DRAFTED, WE REMAIN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS AN
OPPOSED POSITION? IF SO, YOU MAY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME, YES.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU HAD
MENTIONED ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. ARE YOU ALSO INCLUDING
HYDROGEN IN THAT ZERO EMISSIONS?
BECAUSE HYDROGEN VEHICLES ARE
OUT THERE FOR RENTAL PURPOSES AS
WELL? THROUGH THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION, SENATOR
ARCHULETA, HYDROGEN TRUCKS ARE
ALSO INCLUDED. VERY GOOD. I'LL
MOVE THE BILL AT APPROPRIATE
TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, I APPRECIATE THAT. I'M
SEEING NO OTHER REQUESTS TO BE
RECOGNIZED ON THE DAIS. YOU MAY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
SÐNG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR, JUST, THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WHERE I FINALLY HAVE
A BILL THAT AT LEAST MOST PEOPLE
AGREE WITH IT. AND SO I'LL TAKE
WHAT I CAN GET, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I DIDN'T QUITE
SOUND LIKE A DECLARATION OF
VICTORY, BUT. WE ENCOURAGE
THOSE, THOUGH, IN THIS
COMMITTEE, TO ENCOURAGE THAT,
THANK YOU. AND OBVIOUSLY, AS YOU
KNOW, AS YOU'VE BEEN HERE SINCE
THE COMMITTEE CONVENED, WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET, BUT WE
WILL, ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY. AND WE THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU.
NEXT AUTHOR ON ITEM TWO, AB
1777, ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING,
WELCOME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
ALSO, THANK YOU AND YOUR TEAM
AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ALL THE ALL THE WORK THEY
PUT INTO THIS BILL. WE HAPPILY
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
DISCUSSED AND AGREED TO. I ALSO
WANT TO JUST THANK ALL THE ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS, IN PARTICULAR,
THE NUMBER OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN MY CITY, LAW ENFORCEMENT, OUR
FIRE DEPARTMENT, OUR
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY, PLUS ALL
THE COMPANIES AND ALL THE FOLKS
AND LABOR REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT. AB 1777 IS A BILL TO HELP,
MAKE SURE THAT AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ARE TREATED LIKE US IN
VEHICLES, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CURRENTLY. RIGHT NOW, IF AN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE IS TO BREAK
THE LAW, THERE'S NO LEGAL
AUTHORITY THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
COULD CITE THAT VEHICLE. FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THEY WERE SPEEDING
OR THEY RAN A STOP SIGN, THE LAW
IS WRITTEN TODAY WOULD NOT ALLOW
A POLICE OFFICER TO ACTUALLY
CITE THAT VEHICLE. THERE'S NO
AUTHORITY IN STATE LAW TO DO
THAT, ALSO IN MY CITY, WE'VE HAD
A NUMBER OF CONCERNING INCIDENTS
WHERE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
ACTUALLY ENTERED INTO LIVE FIRE
SITUATIONS, WHICH OUR CHIEF CAN
DISCUSS AS WELL AS, LIVE POLICE
ENCOUNTERS. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ONE THAT IF THERE IS
A, YOU KNOW, MANUAL OPERATION,
THAT WITH MANUAL OPERATION THAT
THERE IS A WAY TO HAVE A MANUAL
OVERRIDE FOR THOSE CARS, ALSO,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
OPTIONS IN THERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S COMMUNICATION.
THERE'S TWO WAY COMMUNICATION IN
THE FUTURE WHERE, A FIRE, A
FIREFIGHTER COULD ACTUALLY SPEAK
TO THE CAR, IMMOBILIZE THE CAR,
GET THE CAR TO MOVE, AS WELL AS
A HOTLINE. SOMEBODY COULD CALL
DISPATCH, COULD CALL THAT
HOTLINE TO DO THAT. ALSO, WE'RE
HAVING OUR BIG PRIDE PARADE, ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST CELEBRATIONS IN
SAN FRANCISCO. IF THE CITY WAS
ABLE TO GET TO THE COMPANIES
THAT THE PARADE IS COMING, THESE
ARE THE HOURS THE STREETS WILL
BE CLOSED. THEY COULD PROVIDE A
GEOFENCE FOR THOSE VEHICLES TO
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T ENTER INTO
THAT AREA. SO THESE ARE A NUMBER
OF IMPROVEMENTS TO ME. IT'S VERY
MUCH MAKING SURE THAT AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ARE TREATED SIMILAR TO
DRIVER VEHICLES, WHERE THEY
WOULD NOT BE WHERE THEY SHOULD.
THEY ENTER IN LIVE FIRE AREA,
LIVE AREA WHERE THERE IS A
POLICE THAT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
BE TOLD TO MOVE, TOLD TO STOP
THE CAR, TOLD TO MOVE, MOVE OUT
OF THE WAY AND MAKE SURE THAT
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES HAVE THAT
SAME ABILITIES SUCH AS WE WOULD
EXPECT ANYBODY WHO'S A DRIVER TO
DO AS WELL. SO WITH THAT, I HAVE
A DEPUTY CHIEF. LATROP, FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO FIRE DEPARTMENT
HERE TO TESTIFY. DEPUTY CHIEF,
YOU MAY PROCEED. I HAVE A COUPLE
OF MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
CORTESE COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS
DARIUS LATHROP. I'M THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF OPERATIONS FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE DEPARTMENT, WHERE
I'VE SERVED FOR OVER 26 YEARS.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION
TO SPEAK, THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO HAS AN OFFICIAL
SUPPORT POSITION FOR AB 1777, WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND HIS STAFF FOR REACHING OUT
TO SAN FRANCISCO FIRST RESPONDER
AGENCIES AND WORKING WITH US AND
INDUSTRY AND STATE AGENCIES, TO
DRAFT LEGISLATION THAT ADDRESSED
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
EXPERIENCED WITH DRIVERLESS
OPERATION IN SAN FRANCISCO. AS
YOU KNOW NOW, THERE'S NO CLEAR
MECHANISM TO ISSUE A MOVING
VIOLATION OR CITATION. AND
DRIVERLESS AVS WHEN THERE'S NO
DRIVER BEHIND THE WHEEL. THIS
CLEARLY IS AN IMPORTANT
REGULATORY GAP. AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT. AB 1707 1777
ADDRESSES THIS BY ALLOWING
POLICE OFFICERS TO ISSUE MOVE
VIOLATION CITATIONS BY MAIL.
THIS FIX IS NEEDED WHEN THERE'S
NO HUMAN DRIVER BEHIND THE WHEEL
. NOW TO DESCRIBE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT'S CONCERNS, THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDES SOME OF THE BUSIEST
FIRE STATIONS IN THE NATION. AND
IN 2023, WHEN DRIVERLESS AV
STARTED OPERATING WITHOUT A
SAFETY DRIVER, SAN FRANCISCO
MEMBERS FILED ALMOST 100 WRITTEN
REPORTS OF DRIVERLESS AVS
INTERFERING WITH EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS. OUR EXPERIENCE KIND
OF ILLUSTRATED TWO CRITICAL
CHALLENGES. THE FIRST WAS
UNCERTAINTY EMERGENCY RESPONSE
RESPONDERS NEAR DRIVERLESS
VEHICLE CAN'T TELL WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO MOVE OR REMAIN
STATIONARY, OR UNDERSTANDS ANY
DIRECTION IT HAS BEEN GIVEN.
THIS SLOWS US DOWN, MAKES OUR
WORK HARDER AND MORE DANGEROUS,
AND UNCERTAINTY CAN REQUIRE
FIREFIGHTERS TO LEAVE THE
VEHICLES ON THE WAY TO AN
EMERGENCY SCENE TO DIRECT OR
MANEUVER AROUND A DRIVERLESS AV.
IT CAN REQUIRE TRAFFIC CONTROL,
POLICE, FIREFIGHTERS TO REMAIN
DIRECTLY IN FRONT OF THE VEHICLE
TO PREVENT IT FROM MOVING,
RATHER THAN DOING THEIR
NECESSARY DUTIES, THE SECOND
CHALLENGE WAS THE SLOW PACE OF
COMMUNICATION, BOTH EMERGENCY
DISPATCHERS ON SCENE RESPONDERS
HAVE FOUND THAT CONNECTING TO A
REMOTE HUMAN ADVISOR WHO HAS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS, A
DRIVERLESS AVS ON THE STREET
MOVES FAR TOO SLOWLY. OUR 911
DISPATCHERS HAVE HAD CALLS TO
THE COMPANY, FIRST RESPONDER
LINES PICKED UP BY A VOICEMAIL
SYSTEM. SOMETIMES THERE'S A
RESPONSE, SOMETIMES THERE'S NO
CALL BACK. AND AS THE ON SCENE
RESPONSE, OUR FIREFIGHTERS DO
NOT CARRY AND ARE NOT GIVEN CELL
PHONES BY THE DEPARTMENT,
OBVIOUSLY WE'D PREFER THEY'RE
USING A HOSE OR A STRETCHER OR
SOME OTHER PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
THAN A CELL PHONE TO COMMUNICATE
, SOMETIMES RESPONDERS ON SCENE
CAN'T HEAR OR REMOTE ADVISOR
UNLESS THEY PUT THEIR BODY IN
THROUGH A WINDOW OR INTO THE
VEHICLE, WHICH WE CONSIDER AN
UNSAFE POSITION. SO COMPARING
THAT TO THE NEARLY INSTANTANEOUS
COMMUNICATION WITH A HUMAN
DRIVER BY GESTURE, EYE CONTACT
OR VOICE, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
HUMANS DON'T ALWAYS DO WHAT WE
ASK, BUT MOST DO AND DO SO VERY
QUICKLY. SO WE'VE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH INDUSTRY TO SHARE OUR
KNOWLEDGE AROUND EMERGENCIES AND
REAL LIFE EXAMPLES, SO THAT
PARTNERS UNDERSTAND OUR NEEDS
WHILE WORKING TOWARDS SOLUTIONS
THAT SUPPORT INTERESTS OF ALL
INVOLVED PARTIES. SO AS AN
EXAMPLE, WE NOW ISSUE ABOUT 20
AVOID THE AREA MESSAGES TO THE
COMPANIES EVERY DAY. WHEN WE
RECEIVE CALLS THAT CREATE THE
GREATEST CONCERN ABOUT POTENTIAL
DRIVERLESS AV INTERFERENCE, THAT
AMOUNTS TO ABOUT 5% OF OUR CALLS
FOR INCIDENTS LIKE STRUCTURE
FIRES, MAJOR MOTOR VEHICLE
CRASHES OR MULTI CASUALTY
INCIDENTS WHERE MULTIPLE
RESPONDERS WILL BE WORKING IN
TRAFFIC LANES. AB 1777 OFFERS
FOUR SOLUTIONS TO HELP IMPROVE
DRIVERLESS AV OPERATIONS AROUND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE, SO FIRST,
WHERE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AGENCIES ISSUE GEOFENCING
MESSAGES TO KEEP DRIVERLESS AVS
AWAY FROM EMERGENCY AREA, IT
REQUIRES A MANUFACTURER TO
PROMPTLY DIRECT THEIR VEHICLES
AWAY FROM THAT AREA. IT THIS.
THIS WILL ALLOW OTHER FIRST
RESPONDER AGENCIES TO BENEFIT
FROM A SYSTEM WE'VE LAUNCHED IN
SAN FRANCISCO, AND IT'S
CURRENTLY BEING USED IN ARIZONA
AND TEXAS CITIES. SECOND, IT
REQUIRES A MANUFACTURER TO
PROVIDE A DEDICATED TELEPHONE
LINE WHERE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
OFFICIALS, INCLUDING OUR 911
DISPATCHERS, CAN EXPECT TO REACH
A HUMAN, WHO HAS. THERE WE GO.
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS OF A
DRIVERLESS VEHICLE WITHIN 30S.
SO EMERGENCY RESPONDERS CAN
COMMUNICATE CLEARLY TO SOLVE
WHATEVER PROBLEMS THEY NEED TO
SOLVE. AND THIRD, IT REQUIRES A
MANUFACTURER TO ENABLE DIRECT
VOICE TO VOICE COMMUNICATION
FROM THE EXTERIOR OF A VEHICLE
ON A PUBLIC STREET. SO NO MORE
CELL PHONE. FOURTH, IT REQUIRES
A MANUFACTURER TO HAVE A STATUS
INDICATOR THAT TELLS FIRST
RESPONDERS WHETHER THE AVS
DISENGAGED AND WILL STAY WHERE
IT IS, OR WHETHER IT'S CAPABLE
OF MOVING. THAT REMOVES THAT
UNCERTAINTY. THERE IS TIME TO
COMPLY. WE KNOW THE AV COMPANIES
ARE WORKING ON THESE SOLUTIONS,
AND SOME HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
ALREADY, WHILE OTHERS ARE STILL
DEVELOPING THE CAPACITY THE BILL
GIVES MANUFACTURERS UNTIL JULY
1ST, 2026 TO IMPLEMENT THE 30S
RESPONSE TIME. THE VOICE TO
VOICE COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE
EXTERIOR AND THE STATUS
INDICATOR SOLUTION. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AND WITH THE MANUFACTURERS
AND OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES. AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION? IF SO, PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE AT THIS TIME. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, SYLVIA SALAS
SHAW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY, AS WELL
AS THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHERS? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES MAY COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME. WELCOME IF
YOU HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
CORTESE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RENE
GIBSON. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE WELCOMED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND HIS
STAFF ON THIS BILL, AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE TO DATE, BECAUSE
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A FEW
CONCERNS WITH THE DESIGN
MANDATES IMPOSED BY THE BILL. WE
ARE TAKING AN OPPOSING, LESS
AMENDED POSITION TODAY. IN
PARTICULAR, AB 1777 WOULD
REQUIRE THAT AV MANUFACTURERS
ALTER THE DESIGN OF THEIR
VEHICLES BY MANDATING THAT
VEHICLES HAVE BOTH AN ON SITE,
TWO WAY COMMUNICATION DEVICE AND
A COMMUNICATION DEVICE THAT
CONVEYS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
VEHICLE AT A DISTANCE. NO LESS
THAN 50FT IN FRONT OF OR BEHIND
THE VEHICLE. THESE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD INCREASE BURDENS ON BOTH
THE DMV AND AV MANUFACTURERS
WITHOUT MEANINGFULLY ENHANCING
PUBLIC SAFETY. MANDATED DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS ARE INAPPROPRIATE
FOR STATE REGULATION. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REGULATES
VEHICLE SAFETY AND DESIGN AND IS
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS SPECIFIC TO
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. STATE LEVEL
MANDATED DESIGN STANDARDS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
CHALLENGES FOR AV COMPANIES THAT
ARE SEEKING TO OPERATE
NATIONALLY. VEHICLE DESIGN IS A
LENGTHY PROCESS. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT AV COMPANIES MAY
BE UNABLE TO IMPLEMENT DESIGN
MANDATES ON THE SHORT TIME
FRAME. THAT IS PROVIDED BY THE
BILL. FINALLY, AS NOTED IN OUR
POSITION LETTER, WE BELIEVE THE
PROPOSED VEHICLE DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS PREVENT SAFETY AND
SECURITY CONCERNS. I'LL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT WHILE WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
WRITTEN, WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING'S
OFFICE ON ALTERNATIVE LANGUAGE
AND WE HAVE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THE SIGNIFICANT
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE OTHERS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISH TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSED POSITION? IF
SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME. GOOD AFTERNOON, LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF TESLA
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
MEMBERS, TIMOTHY BURR, ON BEHALF
OF PADDOCK AND AURORA
INNOVATION, REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR
THE WORK ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AUSTIN HAYWORTH, ON
BEHALF OF WABI INNOVATION AND
KODIAK ROBOTICS. ALSO REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. AND
ONCE WE SEE THEM IN PRINT, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
CHRIS SHIMODA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH OUR MEMBERS.
WE'LL ALSO BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION UPON THE AMENDMENTS
GOING INTO PRINT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, PETER THE ROMAN
YOST OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
COME FORWARD, WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. AT THIS TIME,
ANYONE WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED,
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES, THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I SEE THE
OPPOSITION IS JUST SLOWLY,
SLOWLY DRIFTED AWAY. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY, YOU'VE GOT
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT BACK ON YOUR
SIDE. AND I THANK THEM FOR
LOOKING INTO THIS MATTER VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US. I
WOULD IMAGINE THEY'RE SITTING
THERE AND HERE COMES A VEHICLE
WITH NO, NO DRIVER. OUR CONCERN
WITH THE SAFETY, OF COURSE, BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE WORKED THAT
OUT. MY CONCERN WOULD BE THE
VIOLATION THAT, THAT VEHICLE
COMMITS AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE SIGHTING WILL BE SENT TO THE
COMPANY. WELL, MY CONCERN IS,
DOES THAT COMPANY GET THREE
STRIKES? FOUR STRIKES? HOW MANY
TIMES WILL THAT HAPPEN THAT THE
VEHICLE OR THE COMPANY WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO PUT VEHICLES
ON THE ON THE ROAD? OR THAT
PARTICULAR VEHICLE THAT MAY HAVE
SOME MECHANICAL PROBLEM THAT'S
CAUSING THAT? HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT? I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT WAS A JUST CONFIRMING
WITH MY STAFF ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
. SO AT THIS POINT, WE DID NOT
ENTER INTO THAT STRIKE SYSTEM.
AT THIS POINT, I THINK WE'RE
STILL, ENGAGING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST PATH FORWARD AS WELL AS,
TALKING TO DMV ABOUT IT. BUT
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP, YOU
KNOW, AS PART OF MY CLOSE. BUT I
CAN SAY THIS NOW. I MEAN, THIS
IS GOING TO BE THE FIRST OF MANY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE BILLS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE SEEING.
IT DEFINITELY WILL NOT BE THE
LAST. THIS IS TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW,
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP. MY CITY IS
JUST THE FIRST CITY TO
EXPERIENCE ALL THESE THINGS. SO
WE'RE JUST TAKING OUR EXPERIENCE
AND TRY TO ADD SOME GOOD POLICY
TO IT SO THAT I THINK THAT
STRIKE SYSTEM IS DEFINITELY ONE
THING THAT WE CONTINUE TO
GRAPPLE WITH, BECAUSE EVEN, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, THE WAY THE TECHNOLOGY IS
DEPLOYED, IT'S NOT LIKE, OH, YOU
HAVE A QUOTE UNQUOTE BAD DRIVER,
YOU HAVE A COMPANY, THE
TECHNOLOGY IS A CERTAIN WAY. AND
SO IN ORDER FOR THEM TO CORRECT
IT, THEY'D HAVE TO CORRECT IT
ACROSS THEIR ENTIRE FLEET.
RIGHT? SO IT'S NOT SO MUCH, YOU
KNOW, IF THERE'S AN ERROR MORE
THAN ONE CAR IS GOING TO BE
DOING IT AT ONE PARTICULAR TIME.
SO YOU COULD HAVE LITERALLY
THREE STRIKES ON THE, YOU KNOW,
ON THE PARTICULAR DAY OR THREE
POINTS ON THAT PARTICULAR DAY.
AND SO I THINK WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE, WE'RE HAVING, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE CITING. BUT THEN
WE'RE ALSO GIVING THAT TIME TO
HAVE THAT CORRECTIVE BEHAVIOR AS
WELL. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING THE BILL IN THE FUTURE
THAT YOU MIGHT BRING BACK TO US
ON HOW YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT, THAT AN ADJUSTMENT WILL BE
MADE WITHIN A PERIOD OF TIME,
THE COMPANY WILL BE FINED OR THE
VEHICLES WILL BE ELIMINATED FROM
A ROUTE OR THE CITY ALTOGETHER.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP,
WE'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT, BILL. AND HOPEFULLY YOU'LL
HAVE THAT AROUND IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, IT IT WON'T BE ME. IT'LL
BE SOMEBODY ELSE. BUT MAYBE OUR
MAYBE OUR CHAIR, MAYBE ONE OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE EXAMPLE OF ONE
COMPANY IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT,
YOU KNOW, HAD CARS ON THE ROAD
THAT LOOKED LIKE THEY WERE
CREATING SOME DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR
, DMV ACTED IMMEDIATELY, PULLED
THEIR LICENSE. THEY WERE NO
LONGER ALLOWED TO OPERATE. SO IF
DMV SEES THIS AS A PATTERN, THEY
CAN PULL THE LICENSE TOMORROW
FOR THEM TO OPERATE. AND I'LL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. WOULD
LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED AT THIS
TIME. LET ME JUST, THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US, AS
AS YOU NOTED, A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH AND I THINK A LOT OF
COMMUNICATIONS ON YOUR PART WITH
FOLKS, IN A PRETTY LARGE
COMMITTEE HERE AS WELL. AND I
WANT TO I DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS
. WANT TO SINGLE OUT, SENATOR
NEWMAN HAPPENED TO BE PRESENT,
ON TIME TODAY, AS USUAL, FOR,
YOU KNOW, SOME WORK HE DID TO
HELP US TRY TO, CLARIFY SOME
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AS WE GOT
DOWN TO THE WIRE HERE. WITH
THAT, I DO WANT I, I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION THAT IS JUST FOR REALLY
FOR FUTURE REFERENCE BECAUSE
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE, AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED, IS, YOU KNOW,
DONE WITH ITS WORK. AND WE'LL
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO CLOSE IN
JUST A SECOND, AND THIS IS TO
THE OPPOSITION WITNESS. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS A HARD QUESTION,
BUT YOU TALKED ABOUT TWO THINGS
HAVING TO DO WITH DESIGN AND ONE
IS MANDATED DESIGN REQUIREMENTS.
AND I, I AT LEAST HEARD YOUR
POSITION. I THOUGHT I HEARD YOUR
POSITION AS BEING ONE THAT YOU
KNOW, IN EFFECT, WE SHOULDN'T BE
LEGISLATING DESIGN REQUIREMENTS,
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
DONE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AND,
THAT STRUCK ME BECAUSE, JUST
THIS YEAR ALONE, WE'VE, WE
PASSED THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE A
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT THAT DO
EXACTLY THAT. NOT AROUND AVS,
BUT MANDATING VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS. AND I THINK THAT
THE STATE HAS A PRETTY PROUD
HISTORY, WHETHER IT'S, EV
TECHNOLOGY OR ANYTHING ELSE OF
MANDATING REQUIREMENTS, IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT,
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE YOUR YOUR
CONCERN IS, IS BETTER PLACED
AROUND THE TIMING OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE DESIGN
STANDARDS FOR ONE WHO WOULD NOT
WANT TO INTERRUPT THE STREAM OF
COMMERCE UNNECESSARILY, THEY
THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT. BUT THIS
COMMITTEE AS FAR AS I KNOW, WE
DID NOT RECEIVE ANY ANY SUCH
LANGUAGE OR PROPOSED, AMENDMENTS
OR, YOU KNOW, ANYTHING ALONG
THOSE LINES THAT WOULD JUST DEAL
WITH THE TIMING OF THE DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS. I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE, IF THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU KNOW, OR SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE WORKED ON, YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD. NOW BEFORE, YOU KNOW, WE
CLOSE THE HEARING ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I THINK
JUST AS AN INDUSTRY IN GENERAL,
WE HAVE THE POSITION THAT DESIGN
REQUIREMENTS ON VEHICLES SHOULD
BE DONE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. I
THINK WE'RE IN ACTIVE
CONVERSATIONS. JUST TO BE
CANDID, WE HAD A CONFERENCE CALL
EARLIER TODAY. WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE TOMORROW, WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
LANGUAGE, WE'RE JUST KIND OF IN
THIS POSITION. HERE WE ARE TODAY
. AND MY STATEMENT STANDS AS IT
IS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU
ANOTHER ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY
TO CLARIFY THERE, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING, YOU MAY CLOSE AS YOU
REALIZE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED YET, BUT GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. AND AGAIN,
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AS SOON
AS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND AGAIN, JUST
THANKS. THANKS FOR YOU AND THE
HARD WORK. REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
SINGLING OUT SENATOR NEWMAN, WHO
I THINK WAS ESPECIALLY HELPFUL.
SO REALLY APPRECIATE HIS AND HIS
TEAM'S PARTICIPATION. AND JUST
TO REITERATE, THIS, BILL, IF THE
FEDS WERE WERE TO COME UP WITH
DESIGN SPECIFICATIONS, IT WOULD
PREEMPT THIS BILL. SO AGAIN, WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING WHERE THE
FEDS, IF THEY WANT TO DO A
NATIONAL STANDARD, IF THEY HAVE
A BETTER APPROACH THAN WHAT WE
ARE CREATING, WE YOU KNOW, I
THINK WE ARE TOTALLY FINE. I
THINK RIGHT NOW WHAT WE DO IS WE
SEE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S ON OUR
STREETS TODAY, AND WE NEED TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION BECAUSE I
AM PERSONALLY WORRIED ABOUT MY
FIREFIGHTERS, MY POLICE FORCE,
AS I'M SURE ALL OF YOU ARE, AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED WHILE THEY'RE
DOING THEIR JOB AND THEY'RE NOT
PUT IN HARM'S WAY. SO THAT'S THE
PRIORITY FOR THIS BILL. REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK AND
RESPECT FOR IPHONE. ALL RIGHT.
WELL THANK YOU. AND I'LL GO
ALONG WITH YOUR NOTION THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT MORE
TO COME IN THE FUTURE. I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES BEING
HERE AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO
STEPPED FORWARD TO EXPRESS AN
OPINION ON THE BILL, WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN, I KNOW HE'S BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY. AND HIS FIRST BILL,
FIRST OF TWO IS AB 2127. THAT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM FIVE. AND
YOU'RE WELCOME TO BEGIN. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS.
CALIFORNIA'S NEW MOTOR VOTER LAW
HAS BEEN A SUCCESS, WITH NEARLY
6 MILLION NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATIONS SINCE IT LAUNCHED
IN 2018. NOTWITHSTANDING THE
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT,
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES
MODERNIZING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS AT THE DMV,
WHICH RESULTED IN LITIGATION AND
SETTLEMENT, CREATED OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS. I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION IN 2021 TO CODIFY
MANY OF THE BEST PRACTICES FROM
THE LEGAL SETTLEMENT, AS WELL AS
ESTABLISH THE NEW MOTOR VOTER
TASK FORCE TO CONTINUE
MONITORING THE LAW'S ROLLOUT AND
ADVISE THE SECRETARY OF STATE
AND DMV ON ITS EFFECTIVENESS.
IMPLEMENTATION. WHILE OUR MOTOR
VOTER LAW HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL, THERE ARE SEVERAL
UPDATES AND CHANGES FORTHCOMING,
AS WELL AS TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
DELAYS. THEREFORE, AB 2127 WOULD
EXTEND THE OPERATION OF THE TASK
FORCE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
FULL EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR NEW
MOTOR VOTER LAW. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I'M
JOINED TODAY BY BRITTANY
STONESIFER STONESIFER STONESIFER
, WHO IS AN ATTORNEY FOR THE
ACLU AND A MEMBER OF THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER TASK FORCE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. OR GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS BRITTANY
STONESIFER. ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2127, WE WORK
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOCRACY IS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
VOTERS, INCLUDING HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS, WITH
OUR PARTNERS, WE'VE SPENT MANY
YEARS ADVOCATING TO INCREASE THE
FAIRNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF THE
VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM AT THE
DMV. THE CURRENT NEW MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM IS A BYPRODUCT OF THAT
ONGOING COLLABORATION. SINCE ITS
ROLLOUT IN 2018, THE NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL TOOLS OUR
STATE HAS FOR MAINTAINING
ACCURATE VOTER ROLLS AND
REGISTERING NEW VOTERS IN ONLY
SIX YEARS. THE PROGRAM HAS
RESULTED IN OVER 26 MILLION NEW
OR UPDATED REGISTRATION
TRANSACTIONS. THE DMV IS NOW THE
TOP METHOD OF REGISTRATION FOR
YOUTH AND VOTERS OF COLOR. THIS
PROGRAM'S SUCCESS RELIES ON
ACTIVE MONITORING AND GUIDANCE
FROM STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS WHY
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE
NEW MOTOR VOTER TASK FORCE IN
2021. FORMALLY CONVENING
STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE DMV AND
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. SINCE
THEN, THE TASK FORCE HAS
PROVIDED VISIBILITY INTO ISSUES
AT THE DMV AND DEVELOPED
GUIDANCE FOR STREAMLINING
REGISTRATION FORMS. THE TASK
FORCE ALSO PUBLISHES ANNUAL
REPORTS THAT ARE INVALUABLE
RESOURCES TO THE PUBLIC,
LAWMAKERS, AND ADVOCATES. THE
2023 REPORT WAS RELEASED JUST
LAST MONTH. DESPITE ITS
SUCCESSES, THE TASK FORCE WILL
SUNSET AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
UNLESS EXTENDED. THE DMV IS
CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN A MAJOR
OVERHAUL OF ITS SOFTWARE SYSTEM,
DELAYING MANDATED IMPROVEMENTS
AND CRITICAL UPDATES THAT WILL
HELP MAXIMIZE THE PROGRAM'S
ABILITY TO REACH POTENTIAL
VOTERS. IF THE TASK FORCE
EXPIRES AS SCHEDULED, WE WILL
LOSE A NECESSARY TOOL FOR
EFFICIENTLY AND TRANSPARENTLY
IMPLEMENTING THESE CHANGES. AB
2127 WILL EXTEND PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT AND TECHNICAL GUIDANCE
DURING THIS PERIOD OF COMPLEX
TRANSITION. FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S QUESTIONS
LATER ON AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. OTHERS HERE WHO WISH
TO EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION ON
AB 2127, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. DORA ROSE WITH
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA CO-SPONSORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT THEIR LOBBYIST IS HERE. SO
I DO HAVE THE PROXY OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS. CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT AND ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE.
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT UP, JULIE
MALINOWSKI, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IN SUPPORT. OH
HI. YOU GET A TWO FOR OKAY,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE COME FORWARD,
DO WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS
ON THIS BILL? SO YOU MAY COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME? SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO COME FORWARD AND EXPRESS AN
OPPOSED POSITION? SEEING NONE.
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ON AB 2127. SENATOR ARCHULETA,
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? MY
QUESTION IS THE VETTING PROCESS
WHEN SOMEONE REGISTERS WITH THE
DMV FOR THE VOTING PURPOSES AND
HOW DO WE WHAT IS THE PROCESS TO
VERIFY ELIGIBILITY? OBVIOUSLY
IT'S WORKED, BUT JUST FOR OUR
GENERAL INFORMATION, WHAT IS THE
VETTING PROCESS? SO THE WAY THAT
THE PROCESS CURRENTLY WORKS IS
THAT MOST PEOPLE FILL OUT A
DIGITAL FORM, THE EDL 44. AND
WHEN IT GETS TO THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PORTION, THERE'S A
WARNING SCREEN THAT SAYS OR
INFORMATION SCREEN THAT SAYS THE
NEXT PAGES ARE GOING TO BE ABOUT
VOTER REGISTRATION. AND THEN THE
FIRST QUESTION IS, ARE YOU A
CITIZEN? YES. NO. DECLINED TO
STATE. IF YOU SAY DECLINED TO
STATE OR NO, THAT'S THE END OF
THE VOTER REGISTRATION
TRANSACTION. AND IT SUBMITS YOUR
LICENSE OR ID TRANSACTION
APPLICATION. IF YOU SAY YES, THE
NEXT SCREEN, IT LISTS ALL OF THE
VOTER ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA,
INCLUDING CITIZENSHIP AGAIN, AND
YES, NO, DECLINED TO STATE AND
ONLY IF YOU CLICK YES FOR THE
SECOND TIME. THEN IT PROGRESSED
TO THE NEXT SCREEN, AND THEN YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO OPT OUT
OF. IF YOU HAVE INDICATED
ELIGIBILITY BUT DON'T WANT TO
REGISTER OR UPDATE. VERY GOOD.
WE'LL MOVE IT. APPROPRIATE TIME.
WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU LATER
FOR THAT. SENATOR ARCHULETA, I'M
SEEING NO OTHER REQUESTS TO BE
RECOGNIZED HERE ON THE DAIS,
SAMIR BURMAN, YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE.
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GET TO THAT AS SOON AS
WE HAVE A QUORUM. AND MAYBE IF
WE'RE REALLY LUCKY, THAT'LL BE
BY THE TIME WE FINISH YOUR NEXT
BILL HERE. WHICH I THOUGHT YOU
WERE PAYING THIS MORNING IN MY
OWN COMMITTEE, TRYING TO GET A
QUORUM. I KNOW IT CAN BE TOUGH.
AB 2583. ITEM SIX IS UP NEXT,
AND YOU CAN BEGIN WHENEVER YOU
WILL. THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS. I WILL
BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS, THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY. I'VE
HEARD FROM FAR TOO MANY PARENTS,
AND I KNOW WE ALL HAVE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CLOSE CALLS IN
FRONT OF SCHOOLS OR EVEN WORSE,
AND TRAGICALLY, KIDS BEING HIT
BY CARS AND SERIOUSLY INJURED OR
EVEN KILLED, IN FACT, AN EIGHT
YEAR OLD BOY WAS HIT AND KILLED
BY A DRIVER WHILE WALKING IN A
SCHOOL ZONE CROSSWALK TO HIS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT
IN SAN JOSE. I THINK OUR
DISTRICT, IN SAN JOSE ON THE
CAMPBELL BORDER IN 2022. AND
JACOB WAS ONE OF FAR TOO MANY
STUDENTS KILLED OR INJURED, JUST
TRYING TO GET TO SCHOOL. I'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE ENDURING
GRIEF, AND I'VE SEEN THIS,
ACTUALLY, WHEN I WAS A CHILD,
THE ENDURING GRIEF THAT AN
ACCIDENT LIKE THIS LEAVES WITH A
COMMUNITY. AND SO I WAS SHOCKED
TO LEARN THAT TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS
ARE THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
FOR SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. SCHOOL ZONES SHOULD
BE SAFE HAVENS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO UPDATE OUR POLICIES TO
ADVANCE SCHOOL ZONE SAFETY.
PUTTING KIDS WELL-BEING FIRST
SCHOOL ZONE SIGNS IN CALIFORNIA
LOWER THE SPEED LIMIT, QUOTE.
WHEN CHILDREN ARE PRESENT, WHICH
IS A STANDARD THAT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO KNOW
HOW TO COMPLY WITH AND DIFFICULT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE.
THAT'S WHY ONLY SIX OTHER STATES
IN THE COUNTRY MANDATE THE
EXCLUSIVE USE OF THE QUOTE. WHEN
CHILDREN ARE PRESENT. LANGUAGE
AB 2583 ALIGNS CALIFORNIA WITH
THE MAJORITY OF OTHER STATES IN
GRANTING CITIES THE FLEXIBILITY
TO USE UTILIZE OTHER METRICS
SUCH AS TIME FRAMES OR FLASHING
BEACONS THAT BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR UNIQUE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND THESE NEW TOOLS
WILL ALLOW CITIES TO BOOST
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW, WHICH
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENT SAFETY. AB 2583 THE
SAFER SCHOOL ZONES ACT WILL ALSO
LOWER SCHOOL ZONE SPEED LIMITS
TO 20MPH OR LESS OF THE 39
STATES IN AMERICA THAT SET A
MAXIMUM SCHOOL ZONE SPEED SPEED
BY STATUTE, CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
JUST NINE STATES IN THE COUNTRY
WITH A SCHOOL ZONE SPEED LIMIT
GREATER THAN 20MPH. SO THIS
BRINGS US IN LINE WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OTHER STATES. THE
RESEARCH IS AS INTUITIVE AS IT
IS TRUE. THE FASTER YOU DRIVE,
THE MORE DANGEROUS YOU BECOME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, AND I'M JOINED TODAY BY
MARK VUKOVICH. DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY AT STREETS FOR ALL. AND
MICHAEL GANDARA, A GROUNDSKEEPER
WITH THE WASHINGTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN WEST
SACRAMENTO. A GREAT WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU. AND YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES EACH. YOU CAN
START IN WHICHEVER ORDER YOU
WISH. GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
KIRSTEN BLOT, AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY FOR STREETS FOR ALL.
MARK. NOT MARK. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB 2583. I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
OF ONE SIMPLE BUT DEVASTATING
FACT. TRAFFIC VIOLENCE IS THE
NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN
EVERY AGE FROM 5 TO 17. IT'S NOT
DISEASE, IT'S NOT GUNS, IT'S NOT
DROWNING. IT'S GETTING HIT BY A
CAR WHILE THEY'RE IN A CAR OR
GETTING HIT BY A CAR OUTSIDE OF
A CAR. AND THE PROBLEM IS
GETTING WORSE. PEDESTRIAN DEATHS
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE SHOT UP 77%
SINCE 2010, A HORRIFYING TREND
THAT IS UNIQUE TO AMERICA AND
EVEN WORSE IN CALIFORNIA THAN
THE NATION AS A WHOLE. AND WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE DEATHS
ARE OCCURRING IN OUR SCHOOL
ZONES, LIKE TWO YEAR OLD MAX
SALAMANSA, WHO WAS STRUCK AND
KILLED BY A CAR IN FRONT OF A
NAPA ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, OR SEVEN
YEAR OLD JACE BORDE, WHO WAS
STRUCK AND KILLED BY A TRUCK
WHILE CROSSING THE STREET IN
FRONT OF A SCHOOL IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY, JUST MOMENTS
AFTER BEING DROPPED OFF BY HIS
MOTHER. AND IN BOTH OF THESE
CASES, THE DRIVER WAS TRAVELING
AT ROUGHLY THE CURRENT SCHOOL
ZONE SPEED LIMIT OF 25MPH, AND
THAT SPEED KILLED THEM. AB 2583
WILL LOWER THE SCHOOL ZONE SPEED
LIMIT TO 20MPH, PUTTING
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH THE
PREVAILING STANDARDS OF A
MAJORITY OF U.S. STATES,
INCLUDING ALL THREE OF OUR
BORDER STATES. THE RECENT
RECOMMENDATION OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
EMPIRICAL DATA UNDERSCORING THE
NEXUS BETWEEN SPEED LIMITS AND
CRASH OUTCOMES. A PERSON HIT AT
25MPH IS TWICE AS LIKELY TO DIE
AS A PERSON HIT AT 20MPH AND AT
20MPH. DRIVERS HAVE MORE TIME TO
REACT TO UNEXPECTED EVENTS, LIKE
A CHILD DARTING INTO THE STREET.
AND WHILE AB TWO FIVE, EIGHT,
THREE WILL NOT SOLVE THE
PERVASIVE PROBLEM OF DISTRACTED
DRIVING, IT WILL DECREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A FATALITY. IN THE
EVENT OF A DISTRACTED DRIVER
HITTING SOMEONE. A DISTRACTED
DRIVER GOING 20MPH IS STILL
SAFER THAN A DISTRACTED DRIVER.
GOING 25MPH. AB 2583 WILL ALSO
GIVE OUR CITIES AND SCHOOLS MORE
LOCAL CONTROL OVER WHAT SCHOOL
ZONE STANDARD WORKS BEST FOR
THEM, YOU KNOW, WE WE'VE REALLY
LEARNED THAT FROM TALKING TO
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS, CROSSING
GUARDS, CITY OFFICIALS ALL OVER
THE STATE THAT WHAT MIGHT WORK
FOR A SCHOOL IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO DOESN'T NECESSARILY
WORK FOR SCHOOLS IN SUBURBAN
ORANGE COUNTY. SO STREETSBORO IS
COMMITTED TO FIGHTING FOR SAFER
SCHOOL ZONES WHERE CHILDREN
DON'T HAVE TO RISK THEIR LIVES
JUST TO GET TO SCHOOL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
GANDARA AND I'M A GROUNDSKEEPER
WITH THE WASHINGTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN WEST
SACRAMENTO. I HAVE BEEN A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE FOR NINE AND
A HALF YEARS, ALONG WITH MY
FELLOW CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. WE ARE THE SUPPORT
STAFF WHO KEEPS OUR SCHOOLS
RUNNING AND KEEP OUR STUDENTS
SAFE. OUR DESIRE TO KEEP
STUDENTS SAFE IS A CONSTANT. IT
BEGINS BEFORE THE STUDENT STEPS
FOOT ON CAMPUS. AS THE
GROUNDSKEEPER, I WORK A LOT ON
THE PERIMETER OF THE SCHOOL. I
HAVE WITNESSED MANY TIMES CARS
SPEEDING BY ABOVE THE SPEED
LIMIT. THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT OR TO ONE SCHOOL OR ONE
AREA. I CURRENTLY WORK AT THREE
DIFFERENT SITES AND HAVE
WITNESSED SIMILAR INCIDENTS
WHERE DRIVERS ARE JUST DRIVING
WAY TOO FAST AROUND A SCHOOL,
EVEN AT DROP OFF, AND PICK UP
TIME WHEN TRAFFIC CAN GET REALLY
CONGESTED. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS,
COMPROMISES WERE MADE AND A LOT
OF DISCRETION IS NOW LEFT TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. ON HOW MUCH
TO REDUCE THE SPEED LIMIT AROUND
SCHOOLS. THE TIME FRAME OF WHEN
THAT SPEED LIMIT APPLIES, AND
SIGNAGE. MY HOPE IS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, GOVERNMENTS DO NOT
WAIT UNTIL A TRAGEDY HAPPENS
BEFORE THEY ACT TO MAKE THE
STREETS AROUND SCHOOLS SAFER FOR
STUDENTS, PARENTS AND STAFF LIKE
MYSELF, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
I VOTE ON AB 2583. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
TO THIS BILL ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE? IF SO, PLEASE COME ON UP.
JEANNIE WARD WALLER,
REPRESENTING CAL BIKE AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, BRIAN
RIX WITH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LETICIA REYES WITH CRUZ
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE IN SUPPORT. MITCH
STEIGER WITH CFT, A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ETHAN NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF REDWOOD CITY. RANCHO
PALOS VERDES IN SANTA ROSA IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT NOW TO
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS BILL
AS SEEN? NO ONE COME FORWARD, NO
ONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AN OPPOSED
POSITION ON THE BILL? YOU CAN
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE IF
THAT'S THE CASE. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
YES. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO SERVE ON THE
MONTEBELLO POLICE DEPARTMENT,
AND BEING ON THE ROAD THERE,
OFTENTIMES EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID. PEOPLE JUST DON'T SLOW
DOWN WHEN THEY GET TO THE
SCHOOLS AND REACTION TIME. YOU
TALKED ABOUT THAT. WE TALKED
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME. AS A
MAYOR OF THE CITY, LA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WOULD
PATROL OUR CITY'S SCHOOLS AND SO
ON. WE IMPLEMENTED STREET SIDE,
STOP SIGNS THAT FLASHED AND RUN
ON SOLAR. AND THAT HELPED A LOT.
BUT GENERALLY, PEOPLE ARE IN A
HURRY TO GET TO WORK, AND THEY
FORGET THAT IT'S NOT JUST THE
CHILD IN THEIR CAR, BUT IT'S THE
CHILD THAT'S BEEN DROPPED OFF.
SO I SUPPORT THE BILL 150, AND I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD, AND HOPEFULLY EVERY
CITY AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD ADHERE TO THIS. AND EVERY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WOULD GO
AHEAD AND TAKE OUT THAT TRAFFIC
BOOK AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE SAFETY OF OUR
CHILDREN IS SO PRECIOUS, AND
WE'VE GOT TO PROTECT IT. SO
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN, AND I'LL
MOVE THE BILL AT APPROPRIATE
TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ARCHULETA, THAT
CONCLUDES COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE AUTHOR AT THIS TIME. I'LL
TAKE SENATOR ARCHULETA'S
COMMENTS AS MY CLOSE, VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU. AND AS SOON AS WE'LL
TAKE HIS MOTION, AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND MAYBE WE CAN
GET THE WORD OUT. I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT MORE MEMBERS IN THIS
BUILDING THAT COULD BE DOWN HERE
ON THE DAIS RIGHT NOW. BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE A QUORUM SO WE
CAN ENTERTAIN MOTIONS ON THESE
BILLS AND BEGIN THE VOTING
PROCESS. WE'RE STARTING TO GET
BEHIND ON THAT ALREADY, WITH
THAT SAID, WE APPRECIATE, YOUR
AUTHORSHIP AND BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY, AND WE'LL GET TO IT
AS SOON AS WE CAN. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. I THINK THE NEXT
AUTHOR AND FILE ORDER WOULD BE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. YOU MAY
COME UP ON FILE ITEM 13 AB 2678.
DID. WELCOME AND BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I HAVE BEFORE
YOU TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL 2678,
WHICH EXTENDS CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT PROGRAM ALLOWING HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANE ACCESS
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FOR
15 MONTHS THROUGH THE END OF
2026. THIS EXTENSION IS
CONTINGENT ON A FEDERAL
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE PROGRAM,
WHICH IS SET TO EXPIRE IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2025, ALLOWING ZEVS
AND HOV LANES HAS PROVEN TO BE
AN INCENTIVE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
MAKE THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES, WHILE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE COUNTRY IN
ZEV ADOPTION, RECENT REPORTS
HAVE INDICATED A SLOWER GROWTH
RATE FOR SALES, MAKING IT
PRUDENT TO LEAVE THE PROGRAM IN
PLACE FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR
CONTINUED EVALUATION, AND TO
AVOID A MAJOR DISRUPTION OF
ADOPTION RATES. THIS BILL LEAVES
IN PLACE PROGRAM GUARDRAILS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ZEVS DO NOT
DEGRADE HOV LANES BY
CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR
CONGESTION. THIS EXTENSION WILL
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BALANCE ZEV ADOPTION WITH LANE
DEGRADATION. IF ACCESS TO HOV
LANES IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT INCENTIVES FOR ZEV
ADOPTION, WE SHOULDN'T RISK AN
ABRUPT END TO THIS PROGRAM. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY REPRESENTING
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL, THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION, KURT AUGUSTINE.
OKAY, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS IS A
VERY SIMPLE BUT VERY IMPORTANT
BILL THAT ALLOWS THE NUMBER ONE
CONSUMER MOTIVATOR FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN THEIR
PURCHASING. AND NOT ONLY IS IT
FOR NEW VEHICLES, BUT WHAT IS
OFTEN OVERLOOKED, IT'S ALSO LOW
INCOME USED CAR OWNERS CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM. AND
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
THAT WILL AGAIN PROVIDE THOSE
INCENTIVES RIGHT. AT THE TIME
THAT THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
MANDATE FOR MANUFACTURING IS
GOING TO RAMP UP IN THE STATE IN
STARTING IN 2026, UNTIL LOSING
OUT ON THIS OPPORTUNITY IS ALSO
NOT ONLY A DISADVANTAGE FOR
CONSUMERS, BUT ALSO FOR THE
STATE'S GOALS OF ACHIEVING THE
MOST NUMBER OF VEHICLES WE CAN
GET ON THE ROAD AS POSSIBLE, AND
WE'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. Þ THE CHAIR CAST A FATE
COMPLETELY TO THE WIND AND LEFT
ME IN CHARGE. I JUST GOT HERE. I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING A LITTLE
SLOW ON THE UPTAKE, DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER PRINCIPAL WITNESS? I DO
NOT, AND OTHERS IN FAVOR OF THIS
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
YEAH. JULIE MALINOWSKI BALL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. MATT
KLOPFENSTEIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
AND SUPPORT. KAI COOPER, ON
BEHALF OF CALSTART IN SUPPORT.
JARED MOSLEM, YOU HAVE A BMW
SUPPORT. I KNOW THEM. DO WE DO
WE HAVE ANY, WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION? ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
FOR ME TO TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING A NONE COME
FORWARD. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. YES, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. OKAY. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. MY QUESTION IS,
HYDROGEN VEHICLES, ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, NOT JUST BRAND NEW
ONES, BUT ALSO, OLDER MODELS
THAT ARE STILL ON THE ROAD.
THEY'RE AUTHORIZED TO MAINTAIN
THAT LANE. CORRECT, FIRST OFF,
REGARDING, HYDROGEN, ALL
VEHICLES THAT ARE DEFINED AS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES,
INCLUDING HYDROGEN, ARE IN THE
BILL. AND THE USED VEHICLE,
STICKER ACCESS IS FOR JUST LOW
INCOME. OKAY, FOLKS. SO THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL IN ITS,
INITIAL FORM WAS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO BE A MOTIVATOR FOR PEOPLE TO
BUY NEW CARS. BUT IT WAS ALSO
UNDERSTOOD BY THEN SENATOR LARA
THAT WE HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, TO
GET FULL ADOPTION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS WHO COULDN'T AFFORD
TO BUY A BRAND NEW CAR COULD
HAVE THE BENEFIT AND THE ACCESS
OF THIS, AND THAT'S WHY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED HIS BILL TO
ALLOW LOW INCOME FOLKS TO GET
THE STICKER ON A USED CAR
PURCHASE. VERY GOOD. AND I WILL
GO AHEAD AND MAKE THE MOTION AT
APPROPRIATE TIME. OKAY. AND
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS, JUST, ONE THING I
FIND THIS FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO GIVE MY USUAL RANT
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT ON THE
STREETS, WHICH IS HORRIBLY
LACKING. AND HAS RESULTED IN A
LOT OF RECKLESS DRIVING. AND
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT A LOT.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THE PRIVILEGE
THAT WE ALLOW FOR CARS TO DRIVE
IN THE HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLE
LANES IN PRACTICE REALLY DOESN'T
PROVIDE ANY PARTICULAR
DISTINCTION. IF ONE IS TO AT
LEAST HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA WHEN THE TRAFFIC IS HEAVY
AND I'M OBEYING THE I'M BY
MYSELF AND OBEYING THE RULE, AND
I'M CREEPING ALONG AND I'M
SEEING CARS WHIZ PAST ME. ABOUT
HALF OF THEM, THEY DON'T HAVE
STICKERS. THEY DON'T HAVE
PASSENGERS. SO THEY'RE USING THE
HOV LANE, OBVIOUSLY IN
VIOLATION. BUT THERE'S NO
CONSEQUENCE. AND SO BY AND
LARGE, WE NEED A LOT MORE
ENFORCEMENT ON OUR ROADS TO MAKE
A LOT OF THINGS WORK THAT AREN'T
WORKING. THIS IS ONE THE
OBVIOUSLY DRIVING HABITS ARE
OTHERS, BUT THAT'S JUST ME, SO,
THE, WE WILL, DO WE DID WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM? NO. HAVE NOT
. OKAY, WELL, THE CHAIR HAS
WISELY COME BACK. THANK YOU. WE
OPPOSE THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
YOU MAY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE AT THIS TIME. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. AND I VOTE WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE HOPE THE TIME
WILL BE APPROPRIATE SOON. AS
SOON AS WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE IT. NEXT IS FILE ITEM
TEN AB 2086 SUMMER SHOVEL. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND SENATORS,
HAPPY TO PRESENT AB 2086 TODAY,
WHICH BRINGS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS. AB
2086 REQUIRES CALTRANS TO UPDATE
AN EXISTING PUBLIC ONLINE
DASHBOARD DISPLAYING HOW ANNUAL
PROJECT INVESTMENTS ARE
ADVANCING THE VISION AND GOALS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. THE CURRENT
REPORTING IN THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IS NOT
DIRECTLY TIED TO THE ROUGHLY $30
BILLION IN TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS THAT THE STATE MAKES
PER YEAR, OR PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE GOALS LAID OUT IN THE PLAN.
AB 2086 WILL STREAMLINE EXISTING
PIECEMEAL TRANSPORTATION
REPORTING EFFORTS INTO A UNIFORM
AND CONSISTENT MANNER IN AN
ACCESSIBLE ONLINE LOCATION. THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC,
LAWMAKERS AND TOP TRANSPORTATION
DECISION MAKERS CAN EASILY
ACCESS AND UNDERSTAND HOW THE
FULL SET OF CALTRANS
PROGRAMMATIC INVESTMENTS ARE
IMPACTING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
UPHOLDING THE STATE'S GOALS. AB
2086 ALSO UPDATES THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN TO INCLUDE A
FINANCIAL ELEMENT THAT
SUMMARIZES THE FULL COST OF THE
PLAN'S IMPLEMENTATION. A SUMMARY
OF AVAILABLE REVENUES THROUGH
THE PLANNING PERIOD, AND AN
ANALYSIS OF WHAT IS FEASIBLE
WITHIN THE PLAN. IF CONSTRAINED
BY REALISTIC PROJECTIONS OF
AVAILABLE REVENUES. BEFORE I
CLOSE, I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMENTS EXPRESSED IN THE
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHAT THE
PROGRAM, WHAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
TO BE REPORTED, AND WHETHER
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE REPORTABLE
DATA. MY STAFF AND CO-SPONSORS
HAVE BEEN WORKING OPENLY WITH
CALTRANS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHICH PROGRAMS HAVE REPORTABLE
DATA AND CAN BE USED ON AN
EXISTING DASHBOARD. HOWEVER THIS
INFORMATION HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN FROM
CALTRANS, EVEN THOUGH I BELIEVE
IT'S A VERY REASONABLE REQUEST.
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE DILIGENCE OF
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF TO
FACILITATE THESE CONVERSATIONS,
AND I HAVE COMMITTED TO FINDING
A COMPROMISE THAT DOES NOT
UNRAVEL PREVIOUS NEGOTIATIONS OR
INCREASED COSTS TO THE STATE,
WHILE PRODUCING IMPORTANT DATA
FOR THE PUBLIC. AB 2086 IS A
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL
OVERSIGHT MEASURE, PARTICULARLY
IN A TIGHT BUDGET YEAR.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE
MAXIMIZING THE RETURN ON EVERY
TRANSPORTATION DOLLAR SPENT AND
DEMONSTRATING RESULTS TO VOTERS.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
HANNAH KRIEGER WITH THE
GREENLINING INSTITUTE AND
SABRINA BRADBURY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND YOU'LL HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES EACH. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. WHEN YOU GET
THE MICROPHONE ON. RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. IT MIGHT NOT BE ON.
IT IS ON. ALL RIGHT, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
HANNAH KRIEGER WITH THE
GREENLINING INSTITUTE AND
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2086.
GREENLINING WORKS TO BUILD A
FUTURE WHERE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR CAN BUILD WEALTH, LIVE IN
HEALTHY PLACES FILLED WITH
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY, AND ARE
READY TO MEET THE CHALLENGES
POSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS
BILL IS KEY TO ENSURING THAT
LAWMAKERS HAVE THE CRITICAL
INFORMATION NEEDED TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS. DESPITE
CALIFORNIA HAVING A WIDE RANGE
OF STATED TRANSPORTATION GOALS,
THE EVIDENCE SHOWS WE ARE NOT
MEETING THEM. FOR EXAMPLE,
TRAFFIC DEATHS. VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED, TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS ARE ALL ON THE RISE,
BUT DESPITE KNOWING THIS, THE
STATE IS NOT COLLECTING DATA ON
HOW INDIVIDUAL TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THESE TYPES OF SAFETY. CLIMATE
EQUITY, OR ECONOMIC OUTCOMES.
FURTHERMORE, EVEN IF THIS DATA
WAS COLLECTED, THE STATE DOES
NOT HAVE A SUFFICIENT WAY TO
SHARE THIS CRITICAL DATA IN A
CLEAR, COMPREHENSIVE AND
CONSISTENT WAY. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
EXISTING REBUILDING CALIFORNIA
DASHBOARD WEBSITE SHOWCASES HOW
THE STATE'S BILLIONS IN GAS TAX
AND FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT. HOWEVER
WHEN YOU NAVIGATE AROUND ON THE
SITE TO YOUR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICTS AND CLICK ON ANY OF
THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS, YOU
WILL SEE THAT THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IS VERY SCARCE. IT
SHOWS A POINT ON A MAP, THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT, AND A VERY SHORT
DESCRIPTION. THERE IS NO
INFORMATION ON IF THE PROJECT
DELIVERED ON CLIMATE SAFETY
OUTCOMES, HOW MANY JOBS IT
CREATED, IF IT SPURRED LOCAL
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY, AND
FURTHERMORE, THE PROJECT DOESN'T
EVEN DESCRIBE WHICH COMMUNITIES
BENEFIT. YOU CAN'T FILTER
PROJECTS BASED ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES, FOR EXAMPLE,
WITHOUT THIS BASELINE DATA, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO TRACK PROGRESS ON
MEETING OUR STATE'S MANY GOALS.
AND I WANT TO STRESS THE
REBUILDING CALIFORNIA WEBSITE IS
A GREAT START, BUT IT'S JUST NOT
LIVING UP TO ITS POTENTIAL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM, AB 2086
ADDRESSES THIS GAP FIRST BY
HELPING THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES THEMSELVES MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS, AND SECOND,
BY HELPING LEGISLATORS LIKE
YOURSELVES TELL THE STORY TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AROUND HOW
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ARE
IMPACTING THEIR LIVES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SABRINA BRADBURY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS. AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE
LANGUAGE IN SECTION TWO, WHICH
DAYLIGHT'S THE IMPORTANT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE RULES
THAT GOVERN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLANS. IN SHORT,
THE REGIONAL PLANS HAVE TO HAVE
BE FISCALLY CONSTRAINED, WHICH
MEANS THAT BEFORE A PROJECT OR
PROGRAM CAN BE INCLUDED, IT MUST
HAVE A REASONABLE FISCAL BASIS
TO BE INCLUDED. THE STATE CTP IS
AN ASPIRATIONAL DOCUMENT, SO IT
CAN ENVISION AN OUTCOME THAT IS
NOT NECESSARILY GROUNDED IN THE
CURRENT FUNDING ASSUMPTIONS. A
SIMPLE EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE STATE RAIL
PLAN IS FULLY BUILT OUT. THIS IS
AN ASPIRATIONAL GOAL BECAUSE THE
FUNDING FOR THAT FULL BUILD OUT
IS NOT DEFINED. NEVERTHELESS,
IT'S A GREAT OUTCOME AND WORTHY
OF BEING INCLUDED IN THE CTP.
BUT SINCE REGIONAL PLANS ARE
FISCALLY CONSTRAINED, THEY COULD
NOT INCLUDE THE FULL BUILD OUT
IN THEIR PLANNING ASSUMPTIONS.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
CLAIM A MUCH GREATER REDUCTION
IN GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAN
WHAT THEY CURRENTLY CAN IN THE
REGIONAL PLANS. SO IT'S NOT A
CRITICISM OF THE CTP. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN
ASPIRATIONAL PLAN, AND THE STATE
SHOULD ADDRESS THE GAP BETWEEN
WHAT'S ASPIRATIONAL AND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY REALISTIC, BUT WE
THINK THE LANGUAGE IN SECTION
TWO WILL MAKE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WHAT HOW THE STATE CAN ACHIEVE
THOSE OBJECTIVES MORE GROUNDED
IN WHAT IS ACTUALLY REALISTIC TO
ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS. AND WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CALTRANS. WE
WOULD DEFER TO OUR CALTRANS
PARTNERS ON ON THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STEP UP? AND,
EXPRESS SUPPORT? MARK VUKOVICH
ON BEHALF OF STREETS FOR ALL IN
SUPPORT, JEANNIE WARD WELLER
REPRESENTING CAL BIKE IN
SUPPORT. ZACH GROSZ WITH
TRANSFORM AND SUPPORT. JAMIE
PUGH WITH THE NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS,
SEEING NONE, IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
YOU MAY COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
YES THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I
THINK THE EXCITING BECAUSE OF
THE FACT ALL THE CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT, ARE EXPERIENCING
GROWTH. THEY'RE EXPERIENCING A
LOT OF CALTRANS WORK AND A LOT
OF WORK IN COMBINED WITH THE
CITY AND OF COURSE, OUR MAJOR,
FREEWAYS IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, 57 TO 60. A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES. SO CONSEQUENTLY,
HAVING THE WEBSITE UPDATED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE, MY QUESTION
IS, WHEN WOULD THAT HAPPEN? AS
AS THIS BILL GOES THROUGH AND
DISSEMINATING SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION QUICKLY TO THE
DISTRICTS. SO ANYONE CAN JUST
PULL IT UP RIGHT AWAY AND GET
THE ANSWERS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE? I DON'T
THINK WE'VE DISCUSSED TIMELINE
UNLESS I'M INCORRECT. I BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE IN 2027. SO GIVING
CALTRANS QUITE A GENEROUS
RUNWAY. OKAY, FOR ORIGINAL
IMPLEMENTATION, RIGHT. BUT THEN
LIKE THE TIMELINE OF ONGOING
REPORTING, RIGHT. YEAH. AND THAT
PIECE IS WHERE LIKE STILL
DEFINITELY OPEN TO WORKING THAT
OUT WITH CALTRANS. MAKE SURE
IT'S NOT ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE I THINK SO
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY FOR SAFETY
BUT FOR THE COMMUNITIES CAN KNOW
WHAT'S TAKING PLACE AND THAT WE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE ANSWERING
THE REQUESTS TO OPEN UP OUR
ROADS AND LET'S GET THE
CALIFORNIA ON THE MOVE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE IT WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, AND JUST FOR
THE RECORD, THE BILL CALLS FOR
JANUARY 1ST, 2027, FOR
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE ENHANCED
DASHBOARD. AND THEN I THINK PART
OF THE ANSWER WAS ON ONGOING
UPDATES AFTER THAT, WHICH IT
SOUNDS LIKE ARE STILL BEING
WORKED ON. YEAH. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER REQUESTS TO BE.
OH THERE. YES. SENATOR NEIL,
THANK YOU. SENATOR ARCHULETA
ENTERED ENDED HIS COMMENTS WITH
GET THE ROADS FREE FLOWING AND,
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE
RESULTS. CERTAINLY OF THE, GOALS
OF THE CLIMATE, ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ACT OF TRANSPORTATION
AND THE LIKE, WHICH IS PART OF
THE TRANSPORTATION PLAN. BUT, IT
WILL BE VERY GOOD TO SEE THE
IMPACT OF THE SPENDING ON THOSE
THINGS RELATIVE TO THE FREE
FLOWING OF ROADS. ONE OF THE
TROUBLING ASPECTS TO ME IS THAT,
PROJECTS ARE BIASED AGAINST ANY
INCREASE IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED, AND OTHERS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THAT IN
AREAS THAT ARE CONGESTED. AND
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
AN INCREASE IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED COULD ACTUALLY REDUCE
POLLUTION. IF THE ALTERNATIVE IS
THAT ROADS ARE CLOGGED, HEAVY
TRAFFIC MOVING SLOWLY, STOP AND
GO IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
POLLUTING THAN TRAFFIC THAT IS
FREE FLOWING. EVEN WITH MORE
CARS AND THE VISION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. I THINK,
LOSES SIGHT OF THAT A LITTLE BIT
. SO TO ASSESS THE SUCCESS OF
ALL OF THESE THINGS, INCLUDING
THE FREE FLOWING OF TRAFFIC AND
WHAT THE COSTS ARE OF THE OF THE
OTHER GOALS, CLIMATE AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND THE LIKE, AS
WELL AS ACCOMMODATING THE
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD. BECAUSE,
REMEMBER, THEY ARE BECOMING LESS
AND LESS POLLUTING. ALSO EVEN
FOSSIL FUEL VEHICLES ARE THE
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS ARE SINGLE
DIGIT FRACTIONS OF WHAT THEY
WERE JUST TEN YEARS AGO. AND
THEN OF COURSE, ALL THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. SO, BE VERY
GOOD TO SEE THE RESULTS OF ALL
OF THIS STUFF. AND PERHAPS,
MAYBE WE MIGHT EVEN REASSESS
SOME OF THE TENETS AND
PRINCIPLES OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED? SEEING NONE,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS. I THINK, IT'S I
MEAN, ALL OF OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
MORE INFORMATION, RIGHT? WE'RE
HERE MAKING DECISIONS ALL THE
TIME ABOUT TRANSPORTATION, ABOUT
HOW IT'S IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES, IMPACTING PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES, AND IT'S REALLY
HARD TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE NEED. AND SO
REALLY, THIS BILL IS GETTING TO
THAT. AND MAKING SURE WE DO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION. THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD KNOW THAT
THEY'RE PART OF THE PLAN THAT
SHOULD BE REPORTED OUT. AND WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN A NON
BURDENSOME WAY. SO WE'RE WORKING
ON FIGURING OUT HOW QUICKLY AND
WHEN. BUT BUT YOU KNOW WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC AND TO US AS
LEGISLATORS AS WELL. SO
APPRECIATE AND I VOTE WHEN YOU
ARE ABLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
AND AGAIN, WE HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ABLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM, BUT
WE'LL GET TO MOTIONS AND, TAKING
UP THE BILL, FOR VOTING PURPOSES
AS SOON AS WE CAN. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. WE APPRECIATE THE
WITNESSES BEING HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM 16 AB
2525, WHICH IS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BURR. YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. I'M PROUD
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2525
ALONGSIDE OUR SPONSOR, LOS
ANGELES. THE MAYOR, KAREN BASS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES IN THE
CITY IMPLEMENT HOUSING
STRATEGIES FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
ARE RESIDING IN RECREATIONAL
VEHICLES. IT WILL DO THIS BY
STREAMLINING THE CITY'S ABILITY
TO LEASE PROPERTY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AT A REDUCED RATE
TO STORE RVS, WHILE THE FORMER
INHABITANTS RECEIVE SERVICES TO
TRANSITION INTO TEMPORARY AND
PERMANENT HOUSING. DATA SHOWS
THAT NEARLY 6500 PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ARE LIVING
IN ABOUT 4000 RVS. THAT NUMBER,
WHICH HAS GROWN BY 40% SINCE
2018, REPRESENTS A WHOPPING 22%
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TOTAL
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS POPULATION.
SHORTLY AFTER ASSUMING OFFICE,
MAYOR BASS KAREN BASS LAUNCHED
HER SIGNATURE PROGRAM CALLED
INSIDE SAFE, TAKING IMMEDIATELY,
IMMEDIATE CITYWIDE ACTION TO
VOLUNTARILY BRING PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS INSIDE
FROM TENTS AND OTHER
ENCAMPMENTS. TO DATE, THE
PROGRAM HAS ADDRESSED MORE THAN
50 ENCAMPMENTS AND HAS BROUGHT
MORE THAN 2700 ANGELENOS INSIDE,
WHERE THEY BENEFIT FROM CASE
MANAGEMENT. GET CONNECTED WITH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND RECEIVE
HOUSING, NAVIGATION SERVICES.
JUST ONE EXAMPLE IN DECEMBER
2023, A SUCCESSFUL INSIDE SAFE
OPERATION IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOCUSED ON A MASSIVE
ENCAMPMENT OF MORE THAN 50 RVS
ALONG FOREST LAWN DRIVE, ROUGHLY
31 PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ACCEPTED HOUSING
AND TURNED 20 RVS INTO THE CITY
THROUGH THE INSIDE SAFE PROGRAM.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS
OF THE PROGRAM, THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IS IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
LOCATIONS TO STORE THE
RECREATIONAL VEHICLES THAT ARE
SURRENDERED OFF THE STREETS. AS
ANGELENOS ARE MOVED INTO INTERIM
HOUSING, AB 2525 WILL HELP
STREAMLINE THE PROVISION OF
HOMELESSNESS RELIEF SERVICES AND
PROMOTE LONG TERM HOUSING
STABILITY AND SAFETY FOR PEOPLE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS FREDDIE
QUINTANA, SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STATE AFFAIRS REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES MAYOR KAREN BASS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
FREDDIE QUINTANA. I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF STATE AFFAIRS FOR
LOS ANGELES MAYOR KAREN BASS, AS
THE AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR, THE MAYOR TOOK THIS
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS IN LOS
ANGELES VERY SERIOUSLY FROM HER
FIRST DAY IN OFFICE, TO DATE,
THE WE HAVE WORKED THROUGH OUR
INSIDE SAFE PROGRAM, WHICH IS A
SIGNATURE PROGRAM OF THE MAYOR
TO, ADDRESS MORE THAN 50
ENCAMPMENTS ACROSS THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND BRING IN MORE
THAN 2700 ANGELENOS INSIDE
DIRECT DIRECTLY THROUGH THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM, SINCE
DECEMBER 2023, WE HAVE LED THREE
RV FOCUSED OPERATIONS, WHICH
HAVE BROUGHT MORE THAN 100
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN RVS IN INTO INTERIM SHELTER.
AND THEN GOING ON TO PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS, THE OTHER REASON WHY
WE NEED THIS BILL IS ON TOP OF
IT IS THAT OUR RV STORAGE
CAPACITY IS CURRENTLY AT ABOUT
95% FULL, AND WE CONTINUE TO
PROCESS THE RVS THAT WE TAKE IN
AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS LEGISLATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OTHERS IN THE ROOM
WHO WISH TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT
POSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME, I'D SEEN NONE. DO WE
HAVE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS ON
THIS BILL? SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD? ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME? SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SENATOR NEAL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. A QUESTION. CAL, CALTRANS
CAN DO THIS, CORRECT, THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO
STREAMLINE IT. THERE'S ALREADY A
PROCEDURE THAT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES USES FOR OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS TO ASSIST THEIR HOMELESS
PROGRAM, BUT IT DOESN'T QUALIFY
FOR THIS RV STORAGE. BUT WHAT
CALTRANS COULD, IF THEY CHOSE TO
UPON REQUEST OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES, DO WHAT YOUR BILL IS
SEEKING TO DO. CALTRANS HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO. YEAH, BUT IT WOULD
BE A THIS IS A STREAMLINED
PROGRAM WHERE WE WOULD ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO HAVE IT IN PLACE.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY ADD THESE
ITEMS INTO THE CURRENT CONTRACTS
THAT THE CITY HAS WITH CALTRANS,
AND IT WOULD IT WOULD CUT THE
RED TAPE RELATED TO THAT. THEY
COULD DO IT TOMORROW COULDN'T
THEY? NO, NOT NØ DO YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT, FREDDY? YEAH, JUST
TO ASSIST THE THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO GO A
NON-MARKET RATE TO THE $1 A
MONTH. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ASKING THE PERMISSION FOR FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
. YOU ARE POSITIVE THAT CALTRANS
DOES NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DO THAT? FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH CALTRANS SO FAR, AND I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR THEM, IT
HAS LED US TO NEED TO PURSUE
THIS BILL IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT
FOR THESE PURPOSE OF STORAGE,
WHERE THE PERSON WOULD BE NOT
INHABITING THE RV WHEN IT'S PUT
ON THE SITE. I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT'S ACCURATE, BUT NONETHELESS
, I'LL TAKE THE ANSWER. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. ANY OTHER SENATORS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED, SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE, VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GET TO IT. STILL WORKING
ON THE QUORUM, AS YOU KNOW. I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR A
WHILE TODAY. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESS AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO, FILE
ITEM. ONE 2323 IS NOT THE RIGHT
ITEM. WE WANT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HANEY TO COME UP. I'LL GET THE
FILE ITEM IN A MINUTE. LET HIM
DO ANY BILL. LET'S SEE WHAT HE
CAN DO WITH SOMEBODY ELSE'S
BILL. OH 2420 WHATEVER BILL YOU
NEED. 24 FILE ITEM 24 ORDER,
ORDER IN THE COURT, PLEASE FILE
ITEM 24 AB 3061, AGAIN, SOUNDS
RIGHT. HANEY. WELCOME. THANK YOU
, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. AB
3061 IS THE SELF-DRIVING CAR
SAFETY ACT. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN SELF-DRIVING CAR
TECHNOLOGY, SERVING AS A PRIME
LOCATION FOR REAL WORLD TESTING
OF THIS ADVANCING TECHNOLOGY.
HOWEVER, RECENT INCIDENTS
INVOLVING SELF-DRIVING VEHICLES
SUCH AS COLLISIONS, TRAFFIC
ISSUES WITH SUDDEN UNPLANNED
STOPS AND PEDESTRIAN INJURIES
HAVE CAUSED ALARMING CONCERNS
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY. AB 3061
WILL PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE TESTING
AND DEPLOYMENT OF SELF-DRIVING
CARS OR AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES BY
MAKING INCIDENT RELATED DATA
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC.
THE BILL ENACTS STATUTORY
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR DATA
COLLECTION REGARDING THE TESTING
AND DEPLOYMENT OF AVS. THE
LEGISLATION IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPLEMENT CURRENT REGULATION
AND PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY IN AV
OPERATIONS. ONE GLARING PROBLEM
THAT CURRENTLY IS THAT CURRENTLY
THE DMV'S METHODS OF COLLECTING
DATA DO NOT ALIGN CONSISTENTLY
WITH FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
REGULATIONS HAVE REMAINED
UNCHANGED SINCE 2018. THERE IS
STRONG PUBLIC INTEREST IN AV
DATA TRANSPARENCY AND SAFETY,
EMPHASIZING THE NEED FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION AND THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT'S NEEDED,
NOT ONLY WILL IT ALIGN WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS, BUT IT
WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT WE RECEIVE
THIS DATA DURING BOTH THE
TESTING AND DEPLOYMENT PHASES
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3073 3061, IS MATT
BROAD FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS AND KEVIN TAKHAR WITH
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. OKAY, YOU MAY START.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. MATT BROAD, HERE, ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS, I'LL
MAKE MY COMMENTS QUICK, I THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID A VERY
GOOD JOB OF SORT OF OUTLINING
THE ISSUES. WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
REGULATORY REGULATIONS ON AV
DATA UPDATED SINCE 2018. AND SO
WE REALLY HAVE THIS DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN, COLLECTING DATA ON
TRIPS THAT ARE TESTED VERSUS
DEPLOYED. OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE
OPERATING IN A BRAVE NEW WORLD
WHERE THESE ARE DEPLOYED. AND SO
THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO CLOSE THAT GAP AND GET US
CLOSER IN TERMS OF WHERE WE
SHOULD BE ON, WHAT THEY COLLECT
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL, FINALLY, I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD WITH
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO GET THEM TO
A PLACE OF NEUTRALITY. WE'RE
REALLY DOWN TO JUST TWO MORE
ISSUES. CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION. AND THEN THE
DEFINITION OF UNPLANNED STOPS. I
REALLY FEEL STRONGLY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE IN THE NEXT
WEEK OR SO. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR. I THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA, PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. I'LL BE BRIEF AS
WELL. I THINK WE COVERED A LOT
ON THIS BILL, BUT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR ON HOW MANY CITIES, AVS
ARE CURRENTLY DEPLOYED IN.
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE BAY AREA,
SACRAMENTO, SAN DIEGO, SAN MATEO
COUNTY, SANTA CLARA COUNTY, SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY, AND THROUGHOUT
L.A. SO ALL OF THOSE DEPLOYED
AVS ARE NOT BEING SUBJECT TO
DATA COLLECTION RIGHT NOW UNDER
THE DMV. SO THAT'S ANOTHER KEY
REASON FOR THIS BILL, THERE'S
ALSO NEWS STORIES THAT COME OUT
EVERY WEEK, EVERY MONTH ON AVS.
THE MOST RECENT NEWS STORY IS
THAT WAYMO IS DOING A VOLUNTARY
RECALL OF 700 OF THEIR VEHICLES,
THERE'S THAT NOTORIOUS INCIDENT
FROM LAST YEAR WHERE A CRUISE
ROBOTAXI DRUG A WOMAN. SO WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT HEARING ABOUT IT IN
THE NEWS. WE'RE HEARING ABOUT IT
IN AN EMPIRICAL WAY WITH THE DMV
THAT STATED NEED FOR THIS BILL.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. BOTH. OTHERS
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT POSITIONS, YOU MAY ALL
COME FORWARD NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS, ROBERT HARRELL WITH THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE THE THIRD
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE. AND
APROPOS OF THIS CONVERSATION WAS
CUT OFF LAST NIGHT ON THE WAY
BACK FROM A GIANTS GAME BY A
DRIVERLESS WAYMO VEHICLE. SO
THANK YOU. BUT WE WON THE GAME
THOUGH, FINALLY, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LOUIS COSTA WITH SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION, STATE
LEGISLATIVE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEGAN ADAMS
PRESIDENT OF SMART LOCAL 1741,
REPRESENTING SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. JONATHAN
ESPOSITO, LOCAL 1732 SMART TÊ IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, YVONNE
FERNANDEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE PAQUETTE, LOCAL CHAIRMAN,
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION,
STOCKTON RICHMOND SUPPORT. SCOTT
BRANT, SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION, LOCAL 1201 OUT OF
STOCKTON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND IN SUPPORT. RYAN SNOW, STATE
CHAIRMAN FOR THE BROTHERHOOD OF
LOCOMOTIVE ENGINEERS AND
TRAINMEN IN SUPPORT. THAT
CONCLUDES SUPPORT. WE GO TO
OPPOSITION NOW. IS THERE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS READY TO COME
FORWARD? WELCOME AGAIN.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AGAIN, MY NAME IS
RENE GIBSON, AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE
GREATLY APPRECIATED THE NUMEROUS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE'VE HAD TO
MEET WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS,
HANEY'S STAFF AND THE BILL
SPONSORS ON THIS TOPIC. WE ARE
VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE PROGRESS
WE MADE SO FAR, AND I WANT TO
FOCUS ON JUST A FEW ITEMS TODAY.
SAFETY AND TRANSPARENCY ARE OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO THE AV
INDUSTRY. A THOUGHTFUL, HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO DATA REPORTING CAN
HELP PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION FOR REGULATORS AND
CAN ENHANCE PUBLIC TRUST IN AV
OPERATIONS. OF COURSE, ANY NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS COME WITH
COSTS, AND THIS BILL WOULD ADD
SIGNIFICANT NEW COMPLIANCE
OBLIGATIONS ON AN INDUSTRY THAT
IS ALREADY SUBJECT TO A
PATCHWORK OF FEDERAL AND STATE
REPORTING REGIMES, IN ADDITION
TO DUPLICATING INCIDENT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, THE BILL WILL REQUIRE ALL
AV COMPANIES OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA TO REPORT TRAFFIC
CITATIONS, UNPLANNED STOPS AND
Ã, AND SUMMARY REPORTS OF ALL
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IN
CALIFORNIA ON A QUARTERLY BASIS,
COMPLYING WITH MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT FRAMEWORKS THAT HAVE
VARYING REPORTING TRIGGERS AND
TIMELINES IS NO SMALL FEAT,
WHICH IS WHY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY AND
THE BILL SPONSORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
DESIGNED IN A MANNER THAT IS
FEASIBLE FOR BOTH THE INDUSTRY
AND FOR THE DMV, WHICH WILL BE
CHARGED WITH REVIEWING THE
SUBSTANTIAL NEW TRANSCRIPT DATA
COLLECTED PURSUANT TO THE BILL.
WHILE WORK REMAINS ON THE BILL,
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE SPONSORS
HAVE ADDRESSED A NUMBER OF OUR
CONCERNS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON
REMAINING ISSUES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. OTHERS IN THE
ROOM WHO WISH TO EXPRESS AN
OPPOSED POSITION MAY COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME. KURT
AUGUSTINE, WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION. WE ARE
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED, AND DO
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS CONCERNS,
AND WE'RE WORKING TO RESOLVE OUR
ISSUES AS WELL. THANK YOU. PETER
LAUREN MUNOZ WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. TEGAN SMITH
WITH CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SEEING NONE BILL AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. SENATOR
ARCHULETA IS OFFERING A MOTION,
WE'LL TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM. AND IN THE MEANTIME, YOU
MAY CAUSE SOME OF MOHINI. THANK
YOU. KNOW, I WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL FOR WORKING
WITH US COLLABORATIVELY. WE'VE
MADE A NUMBER OF CHANGES TO THE
BILL TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS,
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK. I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD FOR A
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY,
WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL IF WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
VEHICLES ARE SAFE FOR THE
PUBLIC. AND WITH THAT, THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WOULD LOVE TO
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WE WILL GIVE IT EVERY
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. WE
APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE BEING OUR
COMMITTEE IS BEING OUTNUMBERED
BY WITNESSES AND AUTHORS HERE
TODAY. SO WE'RE GOING TO OBEY
ALL DAY. YES. ALL AFTERNOON AT
LEAST WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ITEM
20 AT THIS TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU UP
RIGHT NOW UNLESS YOU WANT TO LET
US KNOW. MEMBER LOW GO FIRST.
HE'S BEEN WAITING FOR SEVERAL
HOURS. IF YOUR WITNESSES ARE NOT
HERE, WE COULD DO THAT. SO I
NEED TO GET MY. WE'LL LET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWELL GO. AND
YOU GO AHEAD AND GET YOUR
WITNESSES READY. SO, MEMBER
LOWELL, ITEM 22 AB 2892. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE KIND
ACCOMMODATIONS, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2892,
WHICH ALLOW A TRANSPORTATION
COMPANY TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF WHAT IS TO
BE CONSIDERED SELF-INSURANCE.
AND WITH ME TODAY, HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
. THANK YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER READY. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES EACH, MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. MY NAME IS MIKE
O'ROURKE, AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
FOR NV TRANSPORTATION. NV WAS
FOUNDED IN 1975, IN SAN
FRANCISCO BY A HUSBAND AND WIFE
WHO'S DISABLED NEIGHBORS HAD A
NEED FOR TRANSPORTATION TO
DOCTORS AND OTHER VITAL
APPOINTMENTS. RESPONDING TO AN
UNMET NEED, THEY DECIDED TO
START A ONE VEHICLE PARATRANSIT
SERVICE IN THEIR INTERVENING 49
YEARS, NV TRANSPORTATION HAS
GROWN TREMENDOUSLY AND EMERGED
AS A TRUE AMERICAN SUCCESS
STORY. NV IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
MINORITY OWNED PRIVATE COMPANIES
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND THE
LARGEST AMERICAN OWNED PROVIDER
OF PARA AND PUBLIC TRANSIT
SERVICES IN NORTH AMERICA. WE
MANAGE 64 PUBLIC AGENCY
CONTRACTS AT 47 LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WE
PROUDLY EMPLOY MORE THAN 4400
PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
APPROXIMATELY 84% OF OUR
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA IS
RACIALLY DIVERSE AND 88%
UNIONIZED, PRIMARILY THROUGH THE
ATU AND THE TEAMSTERS. IN
ADDITION, NV OPERATES THE
LARGEST ALL ELECTRIC BUS FLEET
IN THE NATION IN ANTELOPE VALLEY
WITH 90 BUSSES. AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH MANY OF OUR PUBLIC
AGENCY PARTNERS TO HELP THEM
MAKE THE TRANSITION TO ZEVS. AB
2892 WOULD HELP STABILIZE COSTS
FOR OUR PUBLIC AGENCY PARTNERS,
ENSURING THAT THEIR RESOURCES
ARE BEING USED TO PROVIDE VITAL
SERVICES TO THE PARATRANSIT
COMMUNITY. EVERY DOLLAR OF
INSURANCE COSTS THAT WE CAN
REDUCE IS A DOLLAR SAVED FOR A
PUBLIC PARTNER. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ANDREW. GOVERNOR, ON
BEHALF OF MV TRANSPORTATION. AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW SAID, WE'VE
HAD NO OPPOSITION. WE'VE HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS AND WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO SATISFY THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE CREDIT UNIONS, AND VÆ
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY OPERATING
CALIFORNIA, GETTING
SELF-INSURANCE FOR 47 YEARS. OUT
OF THE 49 YEARS THEY'VE BEEN IN
OPERATION, MV DOES NOT CURRENTLY
SATISFY THE NET WORTH
REQUIREMENT. THE DMV, FOR
COMPANIES THAT OPERATE MORE THAN
25 VEHICLES, AB 2892 WOULD PUT
US IN LINE WITH OPERATORS THAT
OPERATE UNDER 25 VEHICLES BY
ALLOWING US TO PLACE A BOND OR A
CASH OR SURETY BOND IN LIEU OF
SELF-INSURANCE, WE ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT POSITION? IF SO, PLEASE
STEP FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE, WE'VE HAD NO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TODAY? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NONE. ANY
OPPOSITION METERS. SEEING NONE.
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? WE DO FROM SENATOR
ARCHULETA? YES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONS THAT 25 VEHICLES, AND
THEY'RE ABOUT 2.2 MILLION SHOULD
BE IN RESERVE TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT. AND I SAY THAT IN RESERVE.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT MONEY SHOULD
BE, ACTUALLY SET ASIDE? SO GOD
FORBID THERE IS AN ACCIDENT?
IT'S THERE AND IT'S NOT UP IN
THE GOD KNOWS WHERE. THAT WOULD
TAKE, THE RECIPIENT OF AN
ACCIDENT, WHATEVER, TO BE ABLE
TO FILE A CLAIM AND HAS TO WAIT
UNTIL SOMEONE SELLS ASSETS AND
SO ON. THAT'S ONE PART OF THE
QUESTION. AND SOMEONE WHO HAS,
SAY, 15 VEHICLES, AND YOU
MENTIONED A BOND. THE SURETY
BOND. AND WHAT WOULD THAT AMOUNT
BE? SO THOSE ARE THE TWO PART
QUESTIONS. SURE. MAYBE TO
RESPOND AND THEN ALSO, ASK IT.
ANY OF OUR WITNESSES WOULD LIKE
TO ADD ON AS WELL TO THE FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION, MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE READILY AVAILABLE.
OF COURSE, IT IS THE INTENT TO
HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS ACCESS
IN THE TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT MAY
OCCUR. THAT'S, OF COURSE, THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT, AS, OUTLINED
IN THE BILL AS WELL TOO. AND
THEN THE CHAIR, IF I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER, SENATOR ARCHER,
SECOND QUESTION. YEAH, ACTUALLY,
ANDREW. GOVERNOR. THANK YOU.
CHAIR, ACTUALLY, THE 2.2 IS
SIMPLY A NET WORTH TEST THAT DMV
HAS TO ISSUE THEIR
SELF-INSURANCE CERTIFICATE. 2892
ACTUALLY WILL ENACT A CASH OR
SURETY BOND. SO TO YOUR POINT,
FOR THE FIRST TIME, WE'LL
ACTUALLY PUT SKIN IN THE GAME.
FOR COMPANIES THAT OPERATE MORE
THAN 25 VEHICLES, BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S SIMPLY HAVING A NET
WORTH VALUATION THAT MAKES YOU
ELIGIBLE FOR A SELF-INSURANCE
CERTIFICATE. SO UNDER 2892, NOW
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PUT CASH OR
SURETY IN LIEU OF THAT, WHICH
ACTUALLY MEANS THERE'LL BE SKIN
IN THE GAME FOR UNDER 24. I
BELIEVE IT MIGHT BE 35,000, BUT
I'M NOT CLEAR BECAUSE I REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN OUR OUR BOND AND
CASH WILL BE COMMENSURATE WITH
THE 2.2 MILLION. NOT FOR THE
OVER 25 VEHICLES, NOT THE UNDER
24. SO THEY'RE BOTH ASPECTS
WOULD BE THERE TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMER. GOD FORBID IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS. AND MY
CONCERN IS IT'S READILY
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE BOND.
CORRECT. THERE ISN'T A LONG
PROCESS THAT THE INJURED PARTY
WOULD HAVE TO WAIT. CORRECT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. AND I'LL MOVE
THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE TIME.
WE WILL MAKE NOTE OF THAT,
SENATOR. AND INNOCENT MEMBER. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, YOU MAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS IN HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING ANY OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES, FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AS WELL. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WELL,
WE'RE STILL ABOUT TEN SHORT OF A
QUORUM, BUT WE WILL, TAKE UP
SENATOR ARCHULETA'S MOTION WHEN
WE GET A CHANCE. AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE, PHÐ ORDER
SAYS THAT WE GO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. PLEASE COME ON UP.
THANK YOU. FOLLOWED IN 15 AB
2503. WELCOME THANK YOU. CHAIR
AND SENATORS. FIRST, I WANT TO
SAY THAT I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCED ON PAGE
SIX OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. AB 20 503 WILL
STREAMLINE THE DELIVERY OF TRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECTS. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FACES
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS IN MEETING
ITS CLIMATE GOALS. ACCORDING TO
THE ARB'S 2022 SCOPING PLAN, VMT
REDUCTIONS WILL PLAY AN
INDISPENSABLE ROLE IN REDUCING
OVERALL TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
DEMANDS AND ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S CLIMATE, AIR QUALITY AND
EQUITY GOALS. THE REPORT ALSO
EMPHASIZES A KEY STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVE VMT REDUCTIONS WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE TO INVEST IN
MAKING PUBLIC TRANSIT A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING BY
INCREASING AFFORDABILITY,
RELIABILITY, COVERAGE, SERVICE
FREQUENCY AND CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE. THE ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION OF LOCOMOTIVES
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
LARGER STRATEGY TO REDUCE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS, AND
EXIST AT THE NEXUS OF AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS, AT A
TIME WHEN THE NEED TO ELECTRIFY
OUR RAIL LINES HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE CLEAR. SUBSTANTIAL BARRIERS
REMAIN TO DELIVER PROJECTS IN A
TIMELY AND COST EFFECTIVE
FASHION. AB 20 503 WILL ALLOW
THE STATE TO SCALE UP
DECARBONIZATION OF ITS
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND REDUCE
THE COST OF ELECTRIFYING OUR
RAIL NETWORK AS AN EXAMPLE,
CALTRANS LONG AWAITED RAIL
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT WAS
DELAYED FOR YEARS, IN PART JUST
DUE TO LITIGATION AND WITH THAT,
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TODAY
I HAVE MARK VUCEKOVICH FROM
STREETS FOR ALL AND STEVE
ROBERTS FROM RAILPAC, WHO WILL
BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF OUR
BILL. YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS STEVE ROBERTS AND I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE RAIL, ALL
VOLUNTEER RAIL PASSENGER
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA, AB 2503 CEQA EXEMPTION
FOR OVERHEAD CANTON AREA RAIL
ELECTRIFICATION WILL STREAMLINE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF FASTER, MORE
FREQUENT AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE RAIL SERVICE. THE
EXEMPTION HELPS MITIGATE THE
COST AND DELAY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS THAT IS
DERAILED OVERHEAD
ELECTRIFICATION INITIATIVES
ACROSS THE STATE. OVERHEAD
CATENARY ELECTRIC RAIL IS THE
CLEANEST AND MOST EFFICIENT
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE. THIS
CHANGE ALSO FACILITATES RAIL
OPERATORS IN THEIR SWITCH AWAY
FROM POLLUTING DIESEL
LOCOMOTIVES, WHICH IS A BENEFIT
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT SINCE
POLLUTION IS PARTICULARLY
CONCENTRATED IN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES OVER AN
ELECTRIFIED CANTON. CANTON AREA
ELECTRIFICATION IS MATURE,
READILY AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY. IN
THE WORLDWIDE CHOICE FOR ZERO
EMISSION RAIL SERVICE
INSTALLATION COULD BEGIN NEAR
TERM OFF THE SHELF OVER AT
CANTON AREA, ELECTRIFICATION IS
THE BEST WAY TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE
GOALS. AB 2503 CARVES OUT THE
CLEANEST, MOST EFFICIENT RAIL
ELECTRIFICATION OPTION WHILE
STILL MAINTAINING THE CRITICAL,
CRITICAL ASPECTS OF CEQA FOR ANY
NEW, OFF PROPERTY BUILDS.
RAILPAC ASKS FOR YOUR VOTE ON
THIS. AB 2503 OKAY. NEXT
WITNESS, PLEASE, GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE. MARK
VUKOVICH FROM STREETS FOR ALL.
OUR GOAL IS REALLY SIMPLE.
EXEMPTING RAIL CORRIDORS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY SERVED BY DIRTY
DIESEL LOCOMOTIVES FROM
ELECTRIFYING FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SEQUA. THIS
EXEMPTION WOULD PROHIBIT
LENGTHY, LENGTHY, AND OFTEN
PROHIBITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BAD FAITH
LITIGATION, DIESEL TRAINS HAVE
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR OUR STATE,
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO CONFRONT THE
REALITIES OF THE LOCALIZED
HEALTH IMPACTS WITH, COMMUNITIES
ARE EXPOSED TO HIGHER LEVELS OF
AIR POLLUTANTS, WHICH ARE LINKED
TO RESPIRATORY DISEASES,
CARDIOVASCULAR ISSUES, OTHER
ISSUES. ELECTRIFYING THESE
CORRIDORS IS A DIRECT ACTION
TOWARDS MITIGATING THESE HEALTH
RISKS. ELECTRIFICATION ISN'T
NOVEL OR UNTESTED. ELECTRIFIED
TRAINS HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
ABOUT 100 YEARS. THERE USED TO
BE A GREAT EXAMPLE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, ACTUALLY ITSELF.
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
GOING TO BE USING
ELECTRIFICATION TECHNOLOGY, BUT
MOREOVER, THIS POLICY SHIFT WILL
HAVE FAR REACHING BENEFITS
BEYOND ITS ENVIRONMENT, ITS
IMMEDIATE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT,
POTENTIALLY CAL CALTRANS,
CALIFORNIA'S AMTRAK, METROLINK
COASTER SERVICES, THE LUZON RAIL
CORRIDOR, THE CAPITAL CORRIDOR
TRACKS, STAND TO SUBSTANTIALLY
GAIN FROM THE RELIABILITY,
EFFICIENCY AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS THAT ELECTRIFICATION
BRINGS. AND SO IT WOULD BE A
CRITICAL ENHANCEMENT TO OUR
STATE'S RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE, THE
SAGA OF CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
HAS KIND OF EXEMPLIFIED HOW
PROTRACTED AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS AND THE SUBSEQUENT
LITIGATION CAN DRAMATICALLY
INFLATE COSTS AND DELAY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT
THESE PROJECTS ARE DESIGNED TO
DELIVER, AND SO THESE THESE
LEGAL BATTLES HAVE ADDED
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES TO THE
STATE AND PROPOSED AND POSTPONE
THE VITAL TRANSITION THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN NEEDS TO HAPPEN. IN
LIGHT OF THESE CONSIDERATIONS,
THIS EXEMPTION, WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IN THIS BILL, I THINK
IS GOOD POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA.
IT'S GOOD FOR MEGA, MEGA
INFRASTRUCTURE DELIVERY, AND
IT'S GOOD FOR OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION?
PLEASE COME UP NOW. MR. CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, LOUIS
BROWN, ON BEHALF OF ASK IN
SUPPORT. ALCHEMY. GRAHAM, ON
BEHALF OF CALTRAIN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
. MICHAEL PIMENTEL, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION. WE
REPRESENT, AMONG OTHER AGENCIES,
THE STATE INTERCITY PASSENGER
RAIL AGENCIES AND COMMUTER RAIL
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE AN OPPOSED
WITNESS ON FILE ITEM 15? SEEING
NO ONE COME FORWARD, DOES ANYONE
WISH TO EXPRESS AN OPPOSED
POSITION AT THE MICROPHONE? IF
SO, PLEASE COME ON UP. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, SENATOR ARCHULETA, I'M
SO GLAD, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THAT
YOU'RE COMBINING HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL ALONG WITH BATTERY AND
EVERYTHING YOU CAN. IT'S A BIG
PROJECT. OVER THE YEARS TO COME.
IS THERE AN ESTIMATE, OR A GOAL
TO GO AHEAD AND EXCEED THAT 50%
ON PASSENGER TRAINS? I DON'T
THINK I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
WHAT 50% OF WHAT? WELL, WHAT I'M
WHAT I'M SAYING IS, RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR THE FUTURE
AND CLEAN AIR AND SO ON. AND
OUR, OUR PASSENGER RAIL SYSTEM.
AND I KNOW THEY'RE WORKING ON IT
THERE IN SAN FRANCISCO, IN THE
BAY AREA. WHAT'S THE GOAL TO
COMPLETE WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO, I GUESS TO REACH 100 OR 50%
OF THEIR THEIR TRAINS AND SO ON.
WHERE ARE THEY AND WHERE WILL WE
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE? WELL,
THERE THERE ARE VARIOUS
INITIATIVES TAKING PLACE THAT
WILL INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRIFICATION ON, PASSENGER
RAIL TRACKS, BUT IT'S HIGHLY
DEPENDENT UPON FUNDING. SO YOU
CAN'T ESTABLISH THE GOAL UNTIL
YOU ESTABLISH THE FUNDING. SO I
HAVE NO NUMBER THAT I CAN I CAN
GIVE YOU AND FOR CALTRAIN, I
MEAN, THAT PROJECT IS CHUGGING
ALONG AND I THINK IS SOON TO BE
COMPLETED, VERY, VERY SOON TO BE
COMPLETED. IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ROAD. YES. YEAH,
THEY'RE STARTING SEPTEMBER 21ST.
VERY GOOD. SO, SENATOR, JUST,
DUE TO THE WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE, YOU KNOW, WE MADE
SURE THAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCLUSIVE OR TECHNOLOGY
AGNOSTIC, BUT ELECTRIFIED RAIL
SHOULD BE ON ITS WAY. YOU KNOW,
THE BAY AREA, I THINK IS
SPEAKING AS A REGION, I THINK IS
OUR GOAL IS TO REALLY REPLACE
ALL THE DIRTY LOCOMOTIVES WITH
CLEAN, ZERO EMISSION, AND
CALTRAIN REALLY IS OUR MODEL
RIGHT NOW. AND, IF CALTRAIN HAD
HAD THIS BILL IN PLACE, THEY
WOULD HAVE HOPEFULLY HAD THEIR,
SERVICE DELIVERED MUCH SOONER
THAN THIS YEAR, BECAUSE
SOMETIMES IT'S KIND OF
LITIGATION REALLY HOLDS IT UP
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY, WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IS UPGRADING THE
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY. IT'S NOT
ABOUT SPANNING THE TRACK OR
DOING ANYTHING MORE. IT'S JUST
UPGRADING EXISTING TRACK
ALREADY. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, SENATOR BLAKESPEAR. YES. THANK
YOU. JUST BRIEFLY. THIS IS A
GREAT BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT AND MOVE IT. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT. THANK YOU.
YES SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. ASSEMBLYMAN DOES THIS
BILL INCLUDES THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL? NO. SO IT DOESN'T EXEMPT
ANY SECRETS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL
OR ANYTHING? NO. IT'S
SPECIFICALLY AND IT'S DEFINED
WELL IN THE STATUTE SURROUNDING
IT. IT'S TO LOCAL AGENCIES. SO
LIKE FOR INSTANCE CALTRAIN OR
VTA OR LOCAL. I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH ORANGE COUNTY, BUT, YOU
KNOW, THE LOCAL TRANSIT
AUTHORITY LINK AND METROLINK LÀ
OR AND ORANGE COUNTY. YEAH, BUT
IT WOULDN'T BE A STATE ENTITY,
WOULD BE A LOCAL ENTITY ONLY.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER REQUESTS TO BE RECOGNIZED
ON THE DAIS, WE ARE STILL ONE
SHORT OF A QUORUM. IT LOOKS LIKE
SO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE WILL.
WE'VE BEEN OFFERED A MOTION.
WE'LL TAKE UP THAT MOTION AND A
VOTE AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TAU, I
THINK YOU'RE UP NEXT. THIS IS
FOR ITEM 20, AB 2698. WELCOME.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO. HARD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2690, A BI
PARTIZAN MEASURE THAT WOULD
DESIGNATE A PORTION OF HIGHWAY
405 WITHIN THE CITY OF
WESTMINSTER AS LITTLE SAIGON
FREEWAY. AND WANT TO BEGIN BY. I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL WITH MY OFFICE. AS
YOU'RE ALL AWARE, AFTER THE FALL
OF SAIGON, MORE THAN 2.5 MILLION
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS BECAME PERMANENT
RESIDENTS AND US CITIZENS, WITH
OVER 800,000 SETTLING IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF THESE
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS MOVED TO
ORANGE COUNTY, FORMING A
BUSTLING CULTURAL COMMUNITY
KNOWN AS LITTLE SAIGON, WHICH IS
NOW THE LECTURES VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY IN THE WORLD OUTSIDE
VIETNAM ITSELF. IT IS OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED BY GOVERNOR
DEUKMEJIAN IN 1988 AS IMPORTANT
VIETNAMESE CULTURAL HUB AND A
POPULAR TOURIST DESTINATION. I
AM ASKING THAT A PORTION OF
HIGHWAY 45 BE DESIGNATED AS
LITTLE SAIGON FREEWAY. I
RECENTLY TOOK AN AMENDMENT THAT
ENSURED THAT THE DESIGNATED
SECTION OF THE HIGHWAY IS FULLY
LOCATED WITHIN THE SAIGON
DISTRICT. THE COST TO
IMPLEMENTING THIS MEASURE WOULD
BE FUNDED ENTIRELY BY PRIVATE
DONATION AND DEEPLY HONORED
TODAY TO PRESENT THIS BILL WITH
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY,
ALONG WITH MR. LAN NGUYEN,
TRUSTEE OF GARDEN GROVE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND MR. CHIRLA,
THE PRESIDENT OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATES IN SAN JOSE.
ALL RIGHT. WELCOME, GENTLEMEN.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO
SPEAK TO US. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS LAN
NGUYEN. I'M A TRUSTEE OF THE
GRAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN 2002, ALMOST 20 YEARS NOW,
I'M CURRENTLY THE LONGEST
SERVING VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE US, BUT
I'M HERE TODAY IN MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
LITTLE SAIGON. AS YOU MAY KNOW,
WESTMINSTER GARDEN GROVE AND THE
SURROUNDING AREAS ARE HOME TO
THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
VIETNAMESE OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM
SINCE THE FALL OF SAIGON NEARLY
50 YEARS AGO, OUR COMMUNITY HAS
GROWN IN ORANGE COUNTY AND MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
CULTURAL FABRIC OF THE REGION
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. LITTLE
SAIGON IS A DESTINATION FOR MANY
VIETNAMESE OR NON-VIETNAMESE UP
AND DOWN THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
HONOR THE CONTRIBUTION, PAY
TRIBUTE TO THE LEADER OF LITTLE
SAIGON THAT HAVE BUILT THE AREA
TO WHERE IT IS TODAY. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN TAM FOR
BRINGING AB 2698 FORWARD SO THAT
WE CAN RECOGNIZE THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS BY NAMING A
PORTION OF THE 45 AS THE LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY WAS SYMBOLIC.
THIS MEANINGFUL LEGISLATION
MEANS SO MUCH TO THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. IF APPROVED,
THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY FROM
AROUND THE STATE CAN FEEL PROUD
OF THIS ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT
CELEBRATE THE VIETNAMESE CULTURE
AND FOSTER COMMUNITY PRIDE. SO
WITH THAT, I HUMBLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY
AND SUPPORT AB 2698 TO HELP
UPLIFT THE VOICES OF THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON,
DEAR CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS
AND ESPECIALLY I, I SEE AGAIN
THAT SENATOR NGUYEN, MY NAME IS
SEYARTO AND I AM PRESIDENT OF
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY, REPRESENTING
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONJUNCTION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
EXPRESSING MY BIG, HEARTFELT
GRATITUDE TO CHAIR CORTESE. AND
IN REGARD CONSIDERED WITH THE
BILL AND ASSEMBLY TEACHER FOR
INTRODUCTION, SUCH VITAL
LEGISLATION, VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
ONE ANOTHER REGARDLESS OF WHERE
WE LIVE OR WHERE WE WORK. WHY WE
ARE ON PROUD AMERICAN, WE DEEPLY
VALUE AND CELEBRATE OUR CULTURAL
HERITAGE. MANY OF US ARE
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES WHO ESCAPED
AFTER THE END OF THE VIETNAM WAR
, AND THE SHARED EXPERIENCE
CREATE A STRONG AND BOND WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY. WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY PROUD THAT SECTION
OF 401 FREEWAY IN OREGON COUNTY
WILL BE NAMED IN HONOR OF LITTLE
SAIGON. THE DELEGATION IS MORE
THAN JUST A SIGN LIKE TO EXIT TO
FREEWAY EXIT. IT REPRESENTS THE
STRUGGLE, THE CHALLENGES, AND
TRIUMPHS THAT THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY HAVE ENDURED SINCE
FIRST ARRIVING IN CALIFORNIA IN
LARGE NUMBER AFTER THE FALL OF
SAIGON. OUR JOURNEY TO
CALIFORNIA VARIED. SOME OF US
COME FROM U.S. MILITARY DURING
THE WORLD OR THE WERE BORN IN A
REFUGEE CAMP, AND SOME ARRIVED
LATER IN PURSUIT OF FREEDOM AND
THE AMERICAN DREAM. DESPITE OUR
DIFFERENT PATHS, WE ALL CAME TO
AMERICAN SEEKING A BETTER LIFE.
THIS FREEWAY DEDICATION
ACKNOWLEDGE AND CELEBRATE THIS
SIGNIFICANT CHAPTER OF AMERICAN
HISTORY. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ORGANIZED ORANGE COUNTY BECAME A
PRIMARY SETTLEMENT AREA FOR MANY
VIETNAMESE AFTER ARRIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. INITIALLY DUE TO
REFUGEE PROCESSING AT CAMP
PENDLETON. FROM THERE, WE SPREAD
OUT MANY VIETNAM, GO TO
WESTMINSTER GARDEN, GROW.
SUDDENLY, OUR AREA, AND ALSO GO
TO SAN JOSE, HOUSTON, VIRGINIA
AND BEYOND. WE CELEBRATE OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENT AS VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN, IRRESPECTIVE OF
GEOGRAPHY. IT IS WHY WE ARE SO
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY DEDICATION
LEGISLATION. WE SEE OURSELVES
NOT AS THE RIVAL, BUT AS FELLOW
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS UNITED IN
OUR EFFORT TO BUILD A BETTER
LIFE FOR OUR FAMILY, FOR
BUSINESS, AND FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
ON BEHALF OF UNITED VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN NORTH
CALIFORNIA. ALSO, MORE
VIETNAMESE IN NORTH CALIFORNIA
IN THERE, I GET A CALL FROM
GENERAL BING. HE CALLED ME AND
SAID HE SUPPORTED AB 2092. SO
UNITED WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION? IT'S THIS IS A NAME,
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT ONLY.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEES. MY NAME IS BRIAN
DILL. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
SCHOOL. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AT A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SAN JOSE. I SUPPORT
AB 2698 AND I HUMBLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR CHAIRS AND OTHER MEMBERS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT.
YES, MY NAME IS CHRISTO PHAM.
I'M FROM SAN JOSE. I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE AB 2698 AND I PLEASE
ASKING AND I TRY TO COUNT ON
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND BOARD. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR FROM CALIFORNIA,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I COME HERE
TO SUPPORT THE AB. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
I'M VICE PRESIDENT OF,
VIETNAMESE MEDIA AT THE, NORTH
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
LIKE TO COME HERE TO BOX 2698.
PERFECT THANK YOU. I AM HERE, I
SUPPORT AB 2698. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS ANNIE. I
LIVE IN SAN JOSE, I SUPPORT. AB
2698 AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE WILL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I AM BILLING
DATA FROM SAN JOSE. I SUPPORT AB
26898. THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
QUYNH VANG FROM ICAN A
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN BASED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION IN
SAN JOSE. I SUPPORT AB 2698 AND
PLEASE APPROVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MARIELLE PHAM. COME
FROM SAN JOSE. SUPPORT THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. I AM A 210. I
LIVE IN SAN JOSE CITY. I SUPPORT
AB 2698. I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE BILL, THE WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM BLONG DANG I AM
FORMED MAYBE JUST I'M SUPPORT AB
. 2698 AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NAME L®NG. I'M
FROM SAN JOSE. I'M SUPPORTING AB
TWO SIX 8998. I ASKED FOR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MIN HUANG.
I AM A YOUNG, MEMBER OF THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY IN SAN
JOSE. I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE AB 2698, AND I
WOULD ASK FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
WILLIAM PHAM. I COME FROM SAN
JOSE. I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
AB 2698 AND THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR. I AM
FROM SAN JOSE ALSO. I SUPPORT
2698 ALSO AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS YOUNG LEE
AND FROM SAN JOSE. I ASK FOR YOU
TO SUPPORT AB 2698. THANK YOU. I
SUPPORT I SUPPORT AB 2698 AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THAT'S GOOD. THANK YOU, HELLO, I
AM LU█N 95 YEARS OLD, VERY OLD.
AND, SALUTE EVERYBODY. I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. I'M MARY PAULETTE,
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
OF EVERGREEN SCHOOL DISTRICT,
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO CUTE. JOHANNA. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I AM JIMMY PHAN,
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT. I'M VERY
PROUD TO BE HERE. AND, I WISH
OUR VOICE TO BE LISTENED. SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB 2698. I ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WELL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
THIS BILL? IF SO, YOU MAY COME
FORWARD, LET ME BE CLEAR. ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AN
OPPOSITION POSITION SHOULD COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE AT THIS
TIME, SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND LET ME
JUST MAKE A OUT OF MY NORMAL
CUSTOM, MAKE A COUPLE OF REMARKS
BEFORE I GO BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE AND START
ACKNOWLEDGING MEMBERS WHO WISH
TO SPEAK, I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE,
JUST ON A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE, THAT, I SUPPOSE THERE
WERE OVER 20 SPEAKERS WHO
TESTIFIED JUST NOW, AND I'VE NOT
EVER HAD THE EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO, WHERE I KNEW EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM, SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS BY DESIGN
OR, JUST A MATTER OF A LOT OF
HISTORY WITH THE COMMUNITY, I
WANT TO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, THE FIRST
GENERATION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY, BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. BEFORE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN HERITAGE.
AND ON BEHALF OF AN AUTHOR OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN HERITAGE,
I'M SURE IT'S QUITE A PROUD
MOMENT FOR EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND IT SHOULD BE, NOT
THAT YOU HAVEN'T EARNED YOUR
STRIPES BY NOW, BUT THIS IS
CERTAINLY, QUITE, SYMBOLIC OF
THE GREAT STRIDES. THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY, I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE TODAY, I DON'T KNOW
HOW THE VOTE WILL GO. I'M
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE MYSELF.
BUT HOWEVER IT GOES, I DO
APPRECIATE, THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE CITED
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO BY THE
WITNESSES. AND WITH THAT, LET ME
TURN TO THE OTHER MEMBERS, AND
THAT WILL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS,
I'M GOING TO GO TO, JUST AS A
MATTER OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
HERE TO SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I AGREE WITH
YOU, IT'S ACTUALLY REALLY
EXCITING TO SEE A LOT OF THE
FOLKS HERE TODAY. I HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM SINCE A FEW YEARS NOW. THEY
WERE HERE. A LOT OF THEM WERE
HERE TESTIFYING ON MY BILL BACK
IN 2018. WE HAD OVER 1000
INDIVIDUALS OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES COME TO
SACRAMENTO ON SEVERAL TRIPS
HERE. AND A LOT OF THEM CAME
FROM SAN JOSE. AND WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE SAN JOSE FOLKS
BECAUSE THEY'RE CLOSE AND
THEY'RE ALWAYS VERY VOCAL AND
VERY, SOME SOMETHING THAT I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN VERY PROUD OF AND
BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM. AND
IF I CAN, MR. CHAIRMAN, CAN I
SAY A FEW WORDS IN VIETNAMESE TO
THEM? YES, YOU MAY. THANK YOU.
Dð JANET THAI I, I LOOK GÂY,
LOOK SB NAM VÀ GANG SB NAM GANG
SOUTH BAY FOR SO TÊ NÓI.
QUIRK-SILVA Kò MANMADHA MANGO
KHÎI VÀ MOTHER JANET VÌ. MONKEY
YANG YAI NATURE NGUYEN. KELLY.
SO THAT, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR THE ASSEMBLYMAN,
IF THAT'S OKAY. IF I CAN ASK,
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY, BEFORE
THIS, THE QUESTIONS I JUST
WANTED JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR OUT
THERE THAT I REPRESENT LITTLE
SAIGON IN ORANGE COUNTY FOR 20
YEARS AS A COUNCILWOMAN, AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR, AS A SENATOR,
AS AN ASSEMBLYMAN. NOW, AS YOUR
SENATOR AGAIN, BUT I ALSO HAVE A
MILLION RESIDENTS IN MY
DISTRICT. I GET TO REPRESENT
HALF ALMOST MAJORITY OF ORANGE
COUNTY CITIES. I WAS CORRECTED
BY SENATOR NEWMAN THAT IT WAS
HALF, ALMOST HALF NOT HALF, OF
THE COUNT, BECAUSE WE REPRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY. SO WE GET TO HAVE
THAT RIVALRY, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
I GET TO LOOK AT THE LENS OF
PROTECTING ALL MY RESIDENTS AND
NOT JUST ONE. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
I'M SO I WANTED TO PREFERENCE
THAT OUT THERE SO THAT YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHERE MY QUESTION IS
GOING TO BE, MR. ASSEMBLYMAN,
DID YOU RECEIVE A LETTER FROM
THE CITY COUNCIL, THE MAYOR OF
HUNTING BEACH BACK LAST YEAR ON
YOUR OTHER BILL? ALL RIGHT.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. YOU,
MENTIONED ABOUT ONE OF MY
RESOLUTION OF NAMING LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY. I, I BELIEVE
THAT A LANGUAGE CAN REALLY,
REALLY SIMILAR TO A BIG 2698.
LAST YEAR, I RECEIVED A LETTER.
YES, I BELIEVE THAT WE RECEIVED
A LETTER OF CONCERNS FROM THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH. AND,
UNFORTUNATELY, MY RESOLUTION
FREEWAY NEVER HEARD IN THE
COMMITTEE. SO THIS YEAR I
DECIDED TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL.
SO I HOPE THAT I WILL HAVE A
HEARING. SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR. ALLOW ME TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A HEARING
TODAY. YEAH BUT I DID RECEIVE
IT. SO THE ANSWER IS YES. YES
CORRECT. DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT
THE CONCERNS THE CITY OF HUNTING
BEACH HAS? THEY RAISED A
CONCERNS THEY'RE NOT REALLY
OPPOSED, BUT THEY RAISED A
CONCERNS THAT A REALLY, REALLY
TINY PORTION OF THE FREEWAY
THAT, WE NAMING LITTLE SAIGON,
BUT ACTUALLY 95% OF THE FREEWAY,
45. THEY LIVE WITHIN THE CITY OF
WESTMINSTER. THAT'S WHAT I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY, BECAUSE THAT
IS THE LANGUAGE OF MY BILL. LET
ME LET ME REFRESH YOUR MEMORY. I
HAVE THE LETTER IN FRONT OF ME.
WE THE UNDERSIGNED AT THE CITY
OF HUNTING BEACH, WERE MADE
AWARE THAT ACR 71 TO WAS PASSED
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND WILL MOST
LIKELY MOVE TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. ACR 71
WILL DESIGNATE THE PORTION OF
THE INTERSTATE HIGHWAY 4 OR 5,
IN THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AT
MAGNOLIA STREET AS THE LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMAN TAU ON
THIS BILL, AND WE SEE THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR THAT
HE WOULD WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE WOULD TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
PROTECT HUNTING BEACH WHILE WE
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY, WE ARE ASKING
THAT THE SOUTHERN PORTION FROM
THE CENTER LINE TO THE SOUTH OF
INTERSTATE HIGHWAY 4 OR 5 BE
NAMED SURF CITY USA FREEWAY. THE
SOUTHERN PART PORTION IS WITHIN
THE CITY OF HUNTING BEACH. THE
NORTHERN PART, FROM THE CENTER
LINE TO THE NORTH, IS WITHIN THE
CITIES OF GARDEN GROVE,
WESTMINSTER, FOUNTAIN VALLEY,
WHICH ALL WITHIN LITTLE SAIGON
AND THUS SHOULD BE NAMED LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY. IN SUMMARY, THE
CITY OF HUNTING BEACH REQUESTS
THIS PORTION OF THE SOUTHERN
SIDE OF INTERSTATE 45 FROM THE
CENTER LINE BE NAMED SURF CITY
USA FREEWAY, AND THE NORTHERN
SIDE OF THE CENTER LINE BE NAMED
LITTLE SAIGON FREEWAY. BOTH
LITTLE SAIGON AND SURF CITY USA
ARE CULTURAL LANDMARKS OF ORANGE
COUNTY, AND THEY ARE BOTH
IMPORTANT TO BE RECOGNIZED. SO
WITH YOUR NEW BILL, HAVE YOU
REACHED OUT TO THE CITY OF
HUNTING BEACH AND TALK TO THEM
AT ALL? I BELIEVE THAT THAT,
LETTER THAT YOU READ, OUR
OFFICE, WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED,
THAT WE RECEIVED SOME CONCERNS.
BUT IF YOU TALK ABOUT THE NORTH
AND THE SOUTH FREEWAY, WE HAVE
TO RECEIVE A LETTER. BUT
ACTUALLY, LAST YEAR, I RAN A
RESOLUTION TO NAME THE
INTERSECTION OF FREEWAY
FORTIFYING THE BEACH BOULEVARD
TO BE SURF CITY. AND THE
RESOLUTION ONLY PASSED FEW
MONTHS AGO. SO I THINK LAST
YEAR, LETTER CCU AND MYSELF AND
SO OKAY, SO YOU HAVEN'T RECEIVED
THIS LETTER? I HAVEN'T RECEIVED
A LETTER. BUT HOWEVER, I YOU BUT
I TOOK THE AMENDMENT, FROM SO
FOR I THINK A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO OUR OFFICE WILL SUBMIT A NEW
AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK
COMPLETELY THE PORTION OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH, CHAU. YES.
YEAH. AND I SEE THAT, I SEE THAT
MY QUESTION IS, HAVE YOU REACHED
OUT TO THE CITY OF HUNTING BEACH
AND LET THEM KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
A NEW BILL? LAST YEAR, I TRIED
TO WORK WITH HUNTINGTON BEACH.
UNFORTUNATELY, I'M TALKING ABOUT
THIS NEW BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY. DID YOU OR YOUR OFFICE
REACH OUT TO THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND WORK WITH
THEM AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
THERE'S A BILL THAT YOU GOT AND
AMENDED AND THAT YOU'RE MOVING
FORWARD WITH ONE PORTION OF THE
FREEWAY. DID YOU WORK WITH THE.
I ALWAYS WORK WITH EVERYONE IN
THE CITY. SO YOU HAVEN'T YOU
DIDN'T REACH OUT TO HUDSON BEACH
AT ALL? I DID REACH OUT TO
HUNTINGTON BEACH LAST YEAR
BECAUSE I'M TALKING ABOUT
LANGUAGE. REALLY REALLY SIMILAR,
SENATOR. THE LANGUAGE REALLY,
REALLY SIMILAR. MISS
ASSEMBLYMAN, MY QUESTION IS VERY
SIMPLE. YOUR CURRENT BILL BEFORE
US TODAY, DID ANYBODY IN YOUR
OFFICE OR YOU HAVE REACHED OUT
PERSONALLY TO THE CITY TO LET
THEM KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS
MOVING FORWARD? IT'S A YES OR
NO. THAT'S A YES. OKAY THAT'S A
YES. CAN I ASK WHO DID YOU REACH
OUT TO? I THINK MY CHIEF OF
STAFF, MY I BELIEVE THAT MY
DISTRICT STAFF, WE DID REACH OUT
TO HUNTINGTON BEACH, TO THE
MAYOR, TO THE CITY COUNCIL, TO
THE MAYOR. MAYOR, FORMER MAYOR
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH. YES.
CORRECT YES. YOU REACH OUT TO
THE FORMER MAYOR, TONY
STRICKLAND, ON THIS NEW BILL.
CORRECT. AND YOU DID NOT REACH
OUT TO THE CURRENT MAYOR ON THE
BILL BECAUSE A LETTER SIGNED BY
MAYOR TONY STRICKLAND. OH, I
THOUGHT YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T SEE
THE LETTER. I DIDN'T SEE THE
LETTER. HOW DID YOU I REALLY
SURPRISED BY THAT BECAUSE I SAW
THE DIFFERENT VERSION OF THE
LETTER. I DIDN'T SEE THAT LETTER
. THERE'S ONLY ONE VERSION. THIS
IS THE ONLY LETTER I RECEIVED A
DIFFERENT VERSION OF THE LETTER.
SO. SO YOU YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LETTER, BUT YOU. I HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THAT VERSION OF THE
LETTER. SENATOR. YES. OKAY, SO.
ON BEHALF OF HUNTON BEACH AND
THEIR COMMENTS, LOOK, AS THE
LETTER HAS STATED, THEY'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS, BUT WHAT IS
DISHEARTENING IS THAT YOUR STAFF
AND YOU CONTINUE TO GO OUT THERE
AND DISPARAGE THE CITY OF
HUNTING BEACH AND THEIR STAFF
AND SAYING AND CALLING THEM
RACIST BECAUSE ALL THEY'RE
ASKING FOR IS ANOTHER SIGN RIGHT
NEXT TO LITTLE SAIGON. WHAT I'M
SAYING TO YOU HERE IS WE HERE AS
LEGISLATOR. I'VE BEEN HERE EIGHT
YEARS. WE DON'T DISPARAGE EACH
OTHER, AND WE DON'T TARGET AND
PIT ONE COMMUNITY AGAINST
ANOTHER. AND I HOPE THAT YOU BE
NEW UP HERE, THAT MOVING FORWARD
, THAT THAT IS SOMETHING TO KNOW
AND UNDERSTAND IS THAT WE MIGHT
APPEAR CAN DISAGREE ON POLICIES,
BUT TO GO OUT THERE AND PIT ONE
COMMUNITY AGAINST ANOTHER IS NOT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BECAUSE
UP HERE, WE AS LEGISLATORS ARE
TRYING TO WORK WITH EVERY
COMMUNITY AND WHAT YOU HAVE DONE
IN MOVING FORWARD AND NOT EVEN
TALKING TO THE CURRENT MAYOR, TO
THE CITY MANAGER THAT IS CURRENT
CITY MANAGER, AND DECIDED JUST
TO HAVE ONE PHONE CALL. IF YOU
DID. I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T, I, I USUALLY
COMMUNICATE WITH THE CURRENT
MAYOR AND NOT THE PAST MAYOR ON
CURRENT EVENTS, AND SO I THINK,
IS THAT SOMETHING FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND? IS THAT MOVING
FORWARD AS YOU'RE HERE, I HOPE
TO SEE THAT THE COLLABORATION OF
MEMBERS AND HELPING COMMUNITIES
TO WORK TOGETHER. I KNOW YOU
ONLY REPRESENT A SLIVER OF
HUNTING BEACH, AND I REPRESENT
100% OF HUNTING BEACH. I ALSO
REPRESENT 100% OF LITTLE SAIGON
FOR 20 YEARS. AND SO DISPARAGING
AGAINST EACH OTHER DOESN'T HELP
IN THE COMMUNITY. WE HEAR MYSELF
AND A THOUSAND PEOPLE IN 20,000
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SIGN A
PETITION TO GET THE MODEL
CURRICULUM BILL TO PASS IN THIS
SENATE. AND THE ASSEMBLY SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR. UNANIMOUS TOOK
US THREE YEARS TO DO THAT, BUT
WE DID IT WITH THE COLLABORATION
OF UNITY, POINT OF ORDER, I
UNDERSTAND. SO, SENATOR, LET ME
THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR. I SO MY
THING IS THAT I JUST NEED YOU TO
STICK TO THIS BILL. OF COURSE I
WILL. THANK YOU. AND SO THE
OTHER PART IS, I WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU, WHETHER LAST YEAR,
WHEN THERE'S DRAFT LEGISLATION
BEING DRAFTED, IT SEEMS LIKE
SOMEONE IN YOUR OFFICE LEAKED
THOSE DRAFT LEGISLATION OUT
THERE IN THE COMMUNITY TO THEN
SHOW SOMEHOW THAT I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER? BEFORE YOU EVEN
RESPOND, I'M GOING TO PAUSE
PROCEDURALLY FOR A MOMENT. HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE ANSWER TO
THIS QUESTION, AND ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
HERE SO THAT ULTIMATELY WE CAN
VOTE ON THIS BILL AND OTHER
BILLS BEFORE WE LOSE A MEMBER,
BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER COMMITTEES
GOING ON TODAY. SO, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ HERE. CORTEZ HERE. NILO
HERE. NILO HERE. ALLEN ARCHULETA
HERE. ARCHULETA HERE. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. HERE.
DALY. DALY. HERE. DODD. DODD.
HERE. GONZALEZ LAIRD. LIMÓN
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE. NGUYEN
HERE. NGUYEN. HERE. SATO. UMBERG
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. AND LET YOU RESPOND TO
THAT QUESTION. AND I WOULD JUST
ASK THE SENATOR, TO PREPARE TO
YIELD THE FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN
GET OTHER QUESTIONS OFF, OFF THE
DAIS HERE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND KEEP MOVING ON. YEAH. I HAVE
ONE MORE QUESTION AFTER, MR.
CHAIR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
ALERTING ME TO THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OKAY, SO, I MEAN, I'M
I'M NOT APPRECIATING YOUR
COMMENT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
ACCURATE. MY OFFICE AND EVEN
MYSELF, I NEVER CALL ANYONE
RACIST. BUT WE DID OUR OFFICE.
WE RECEIVED A FEW. I CAN, I CAN.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT INAPPROPRIATE
LANGUAGE THE LETTER SUBMITTED TO
MY OFFICE. I HAVE TO SAY THAT
INAPPROPRIATE LANGUAGE. BUT I,
MYSELF, MYSELF AND EVERYONE IN
MY OFFICE, WE NEVER CALL ANYONE
RACIST. BUT THE LANGUAGE IS
REALLY, REALLY INAPPROPRIATE.
AND IT REALLY. NO GOOD TO THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND ACTUALLY, I, I RAN ANOTHER
RESOLUTION TO NAME THE PORTION
OF INTERSECTION OF 45 FREEWAY
AND THE BEACH BOULEVARD TO BE
LIKE SURF CITY IN THE STATE. I
DID, AND THEY ALREADY PASSED,
AND WE ALL SUPPORTED THAT. IT
ALREADY PASSED ON THE ASSEMBLY
AND ON THE SENATE. AND, I DON'T
KNOW WHY YOU ASKING ME WITH THAT
KIND OF QUESTION. AND I'M NOT
APPRECIATED THAT WASN'T THE
QUESTION I ASKED. THAT WAS A
COMMENT. MY QUESTION WAS, WAS
THERE ANY LEAKING OF DRAFT
LEGISLATION IN THE COMMUNITY TO
THEN SOMEHOW INDICATE OR, SAY,
STATE THAT I OPPOSE LITTLE
SAIGON FREEWAY, MY OFFICE WOULD
NEVER RECEIVE ANY INFORMATION
LIKE THAT, AND NONE OF US LEAK
AND INFORMATION BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T RECEIVE IT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTIONS I HAVE. WILL YOU
SUPPORT THE SURF CITY USA SIGN
ON THE FREEWAY? I ALREADY PASSED
THE RESOLUTION. ALREADY PASSED.
THAT'S THE EXIT SIGN. WOULD YOU
SUPPORT A PORTION OF THE FREE.
BUT THE BILL TODAY THAT WE NOT
IN HUNTINGTON BEACH I. I KNOW
THE BILL TODAY IS NAMELY THE
SECOND FREEWAY CHAIR POINT OF
ORDER. THIS IS TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE. CONVERSATION IN
MY IN MY VIEW, I'M ONLY ONE
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE, BUT I
THINK IF YOU GUYS HAVE SOME
ISSUES THAT YOU NEED TO WORK
OUT, IF I DO WITH MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WE DO THAT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS. DOING THAT IN A COMMITTEE
HEARING LIKE THIS, I JUST THINK
IT'S TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE. BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR DODD.
BUT SHE'S CURRENTLY ASKING
WHETHER, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
WHETHER OR NOT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE WILLING TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL IN THE
FUTURE, ASK THAT QUESTION IN
HALF AN HOUR AGO. THAT'S THAT
MAY BE TRUE, BUT WE'RE AGAIN,
SENATOR NGUYEN, WE ARE TRYING TO
MOVE THE AGENDA HERE. SO SUPPORT
AN AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE SURF
CITY USA. YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
BILL? YEAH. NO. THIS BILL. NO.
OKAY THANK YOU, WITH THAT THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, NEXT, WE HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. WELL, THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO. AND, I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU
PERSONALLY, FOR YOU COMING TO
AMERICA, NOT SPEAKING A WORD OF
ENGLISH, GOING TO COLLEGE,
BECOMING THE FIRST MAYOR IN THE
HISTORY OF WESTMINSTER, AND
SUPPORTING. OBVIOUSLY, YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND AS YOU HEARD,
WE DO IT EQUALLY FAIRLY ACROSS
THE BOARD TO EVERYONE. AND I'M
PROUD OF WHAT YOU'VE DONE TODAY,
I AM SUPPORTING THE BILL. I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE. THE VIETNAMESE AMERICANS,
AND I KNOW MANY OF YOU HAVE
FAMILY WHO SERVED ALONGSIDE OUR
TROOPS AND VIETNAM, I SERVED
DURING THAT ERA. YOU HAVE FAMILY
WHO SERVED DURING THAT ERA. AND
AS FOR THOSE VETERANS THAT ARE
THERE AND THOSE WHO'VE SERVED,
WELCOME HOME. WELCOME TO
AMERICA. AND I'M SO PROUD THAT
YOU SHED BLOOD WITH US. AND WE
SHED BLOOD WITH YOU FOR FREEDOM.
AND I THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE
THAT THIS PORTION OF THE 405
FREEWAY IS NAMED, LITTLE SAIGON.
AND I WILL DEFINITELY MOVE THE
BILL AT APPROPRIATE TIME. AND I
SUPPORT IT TO MOVE THE BILL. OH.
YOU DID? OH, I WAS GOING TO WAIT
TILL AFTER. OKAY, WELL, I WILL
YIELD TO MY COLLEAGUE TO DO
THAT, BUT I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. UNLIKE THE CITY
COUNCIL, WE DON'T HAVE AUDIENCE
PARTICIPATION HERE. SO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE, KEEPING THE
APPLAUSE DOWN, WE HAVE A MOTION.
ALREADY BY SENATOR NGUYEN, LET
ME COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I
REALLY WANT TO THANK. I WANT TO
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
MY OFFICE WILL APPRECIATE THAT
AND ASK THE. AS A VIETNAMESE
REFUGEE MYSELF, I CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY IN 1992 AT THE AGE OF
19. I I ALWAYS WANT TO DO
SOMETHING, TO CONTRIBUTE TO
AMERICA. SO I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF MY DISTRICT. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY COMMUNITY. SO I
RESPECT I, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE, BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT.
YEAH. OKAY. THANK YOU. ON THE
MOTION BY SENATOR NGUYEN, I'LL
HAVE THE ASSISTANT STATE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. THIS IS FOR ITEM NUMBER
20, AB 2698. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS, COURTESY A COURTESY I
NILO NILO I ALLEN. ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER I BECKER I
BREAKSPEAR BREAKSPEAR I DALLY
DALLY I DODD DODD I GONZALEZ
LU█T LIMÓN NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NGUYEN I SATO UMBERG
NINE ZERO ON. ALL RIGHT. THAT
ITEM HAS A VOTE OF 9 TO 0, WHICH
IS ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE, BUT WE'LL KEEP IT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS, THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE WHO TRAVELED TO BE
HERE UNTIL GENERAL BEN, I SAID
HELLO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. THANK YOU.
KNOW, THE HEARING IS CLOSED. I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU. THOUGH WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE NEXT AUTHOR,
JUAN CARRILLO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUAN CARRILLO, ON AB 3179.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL AB
3179. BUT BEFORE I BEGIN, I
WOULD LIKE TO CONFIRM THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
AGREED INTO THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE,
AB 3179 IS A NECESSARY MEASURE
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR A NARROW
EXEMPTION SPECIFICALLY FOR
BUCKET TRUCKS AND SALE ON WHEELS
TO THE CARB ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET
REGULATION BUCKET TRUCKS PLAYED
A VITAL ROLE IN PERFORMING
AERIAL MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS
ON TELECOMMUNICATION LINES,
ENSURING CONNECTIVITY FOR
EMERGENCY SERVICES. SIMILARLY,
CELL ON WHEELS ARE DEPLOYED TO
RESTORE CELLULAR COVERAGE
SWIFTLY IN NECESSARY LOCATIONS
DURING EMERGENCIES OR OUTAGES,
ENSURING THAT ESSENTIAL
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS REMAIN
OPERATIONAL FOR EMERGENCY CALLS
AND SERVICES. WITHOUT THESE
SPECIALIZED VEHICLES,
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
WOULD FACE SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN
RESTORING SERVICES DURING
EMERGENCIES, POTENTIALLY
ENDANGERING LIVES AND
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY.
THERE ARE NO MANUFACTURERS THAT
PROVIDE RELIABLE BUCKET TRUCKS
OR CELL ON WHEELS VEHICLES THAT
MEET THE CURRENT ACF
REGULATIONS. THESE VEHICLES FACE
CHALLENGES IN ADOPTING ZERO
EMISSION ELECTRIC VEHICLES DUE
TO THEIR HEAVY DUTY NATURE
REQUIRING HIGH POWER AND LONG
RANGE CAPABILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY, RAPID DEPLOYMENT
NEEDS DURING EMERGENCIES OFTEN
AREAS WITH LIMITED OR NO
COMMERCIAL POWER FURTHER
COMPLICATED FEASIBILITY OF
ELECTRIC OPTIONS. THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD HAS
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANT ROLE
EMERGENCY VEHICLES PLAY IN THE
TIMES OF CRISIS, AND ACCEPTING
THEM FROM THEIR ADVANCED CLEAN
FLEET REGULATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY, EXISTING
EXEMPTIONS AND OFF RAMPS ARE NOT
VIABLE OPTIONS FOR PRIVATELY
OWNED TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS AS THEY ONLY APPLY TO
PUBLICLY OWNED VEHICLES. WITH
THE UNPREDICTABILITY OF NATURAL
DISASTERS, WE MUST REMAIN
PREPARED AND READY TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
PROVIDED WITH RELIABLE
CONNECTIONS TO ESSENTIAL
SERVICES IN CASE OF SEVERE
WEATHER, WILDFIRES OR FLOODS.
JOINING ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IS AMANDA VALDERRAMA WITH CAL
BROADBAND AND TERI MICHELI WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN. THANK YOU,
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS AMANDA GUADERRAMA WITH
CAL BROADBAND PROUD SPONSORS OF
AB 3179. FIRST, I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL. AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED, THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR A VERY
NARROW EXEMPTION TO THE ADVANCED
CLEAN FLEET REGULATIONS FOR
BUCKET TRUCKS AND CELL ON
WHEELS. TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS ARE ENTRUSTED WITH
MAINTAINING THE NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE. CRUCIAL FOR
FACILITATING 911 AND EMERGENCY
ALERT COMMUNICATIONS. THIS
INCLUDES THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS THE
NECESSARY SOFTWARE AND PROTOCOLS
TO DIRECT EMERGENCY CALLS TO THE
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ANSWERING SORRY. TO THE
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT OR EMERGENCY
DISPATCH CENTER. THEY MUST ALSO
COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION AND
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO 911 SERVICES. THIS INCLUDES
ENSURING THE ABILITY FOR USERS
TO REACH EMERGENCY SERVICES BY
DIALING 911, ENSURING THAT
EMERGENCY DISPATCHERS
AUTOMATICALLY RECEIVE THE
CALLER'S LOCATION INFORMATION.
NOTIFYING 911 CALL CENTERS OF
OUTAGES, AND CERTIFYING THE
RELIABILITY MEASURES ARE TAKEN
AS STATED. BUCKET TRUCKS AND
CELL ON WHEELS ARE SPECIALIZED
VEHICLES THAT TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS UTILIZE WHEN
PERFORMING MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS TO THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LINES OR
UTILIZE TO TEMPORARILY RESTORE
CELL SERVICE SWIFTLY DURING
EMERGENCIES OR OUTAGES. THE
TRANSITION TO FULLY ELECTRIC
SOLUTIONS REMAINS IMPRACTICAL
FOR THESE TWO TYPES OF VEHICLES,
MAKING THESE EXEMPTIONS CRITICAL
FOR MAINTAINING THE RELIABILITY
AND AVAILABILITY OF EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEREFORE IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
PASS THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS CAN
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND RESTORE CRITICAL
SERVICES PROMPTLY. I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
TERRY MCHALE WITH AARON REED AND
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE ABOUT 6
MILLION TRUCKS IN THE VEHICLE
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THESE BUCKET TRUCKS
AND COWS, THESE SEE THE CELL ON
WHEELS MAKE UP A DE MINIMIS
PORTION OF THAT POPULATION. THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL, CAL
FIRE, PORAC ALL SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE DURING TIMES
OF EMERGENCY, THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMMUNICATION IS
WORKING AND THAT PEOPLE CAN BE
CAN BE MOVED ABOUT SAFELY. THIS
BILL IS SENSIBLE. IT'S SMART
GOVERNMENT AND MR. CHAIRMAN,
IT'S ALSO A NOD. IT'S A NOD TO
THE COURAGE OF THOSE PEOPLE FOR
THE BROADBAND INDUSTRY WHO
DURING TIMES OF DISASTER, HAVE
THE COURAGE AND THE TEMERITY AND
THE UNDERSTANDING AND THE WISDOM
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
COMMUNICATION WORKS WHEN WE NEED
IT THE MOST. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY PATROL IS
PROUD TO BE A CO-SPONSOR, AND WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE, MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION?
PLEASE COME ON UP, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON FOR CTIA.
WE ARE THE TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE WIRELESS TELEPHONE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, YOLANDA
BENSON, ON BEHALF OF US TELECOM,
THE BROADBAND ASSOCIATION ALSO
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES. JULIE MALINOWSKI, PAUL, ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WALID HAJJAJ, ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT. MARC NEUBERGER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. CHAIR MEMBERS NATE
SOLOVE ON BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE
AND FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS IN
SUPPORT. APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
WORK. THANK YOU. PAM LOOMIS, ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES THAT MAKE UP THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS HERE? WE DO
NOT. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. AT THIS TIME, SEEING NO
ONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WELCOME. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
READY BY SENATOR BREAKSPEARE. SO
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. I'LL
SIMPLY CLOSE BY RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ON THE
MOTION BY SENATOR BREAKSPEARE
WAS THE ASSISTANT TO CALL THE
ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE, AB 3179. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS.
CORTESE A, CORTESE I, NILO I,
MILO I, ALAN ARCHULETA I,
ARCHULETA I, BECKER I BECKER I
BREAKSPEAR BREAKSPEAR I DALLEY
DODD GONZALEZ. LAIRD LIMÓN
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NGUYEN
I SATO. UMBERG 601 KHÓ. ALL
RIGHT. THE VOTE IS 6 TO 0 AND
WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
FOR. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. SO, MEMBER AGAR CURRY,
WELCOME. THIS IS FOR ITEM 14 AB
2286. AND YOU MAY PRESENT
WHENEVER READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS SIMPLE FULL TESTING
AND FULL DEPLOYMENT OF AN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE. OVER 10,000
POUNDS CAN BE PERMITTED BY THE
DMV TO OPERATE ON PUBLIC ROADS
IN CALIFORNIA. WHILE WE AWAIT
THE ANALYSIS OF SAFETY DATA AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, THAT VEHICLE MUST BE
ACCOMPANIED BY A QUALIFIED HUMAN
SAFETY OPERATOR. THERE IS
NOTHING ABOUT A HUMAN SAFETY
OPERATOR THAT PREVENTS THE
AUTONOMOUS TRUCKING INDUSTRY
FROM TESTING AND DEPLOYING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ANYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE ONLY CONCEIVABLE
MOTIVATION FOR RUSHING FORWARD
WITHOUT A MONITOR IN THE CAB IS
TO INCREASE PROFITS. AT THE RISK
OF PUBLIC SAFETY, AND THE
LIVELIHOODS OF OUR TRAINED
EXPERT TRUCKING WORKFORCE. THE
ROLLOUT OF LIGHT DUTY AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES IN SAN FRANCISCO IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE INVOLVED
IN THE FINAL DECISION MAKING ON
PERSONLESS 80,000 POUND TRUCKS,
HUNDREDS OF INCIDENTS HAVE WITH
DRIVERLESS AUTONOMOUS CARS HAVE
PROMPTED CITY PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO PLEAD WITH THE CPUC TO REIN
IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF DRIVERLESS,
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND REVIEW OF THE
DATA DO NOT INCLUDE THIS
DEPLOYMENT HAS BEEN SAFE IN
THESE INCIDENTS. DRIVERLESS
VEHICLES STOPPED SUDDENLY
IMPEDING TRAFFIC AND CAUSING
ACCIDENTS IN OTHERS, THEY HAVE
BLOCKED EMERGENCY VEHICLES,
INCLUDING PREVENTING POLICE FROM
RESPONDING TO A MASS SHOOTING.
THE VEHICLES HAVE DRIVEN THROUGH
EMERGENCY SCENES AND INTO DOWNED
WIRES, OR EVEN ONE DROVE FROM
THE POLICE CARS DURING A VEHICLE
STOP. WE HAVE ALSO SEEN A
HORRIFIC ACCIDENT WHERE A
PEDESTRIAN WAS DRAGGED BY AN
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE AND TRAPPED
UNDER IT. THE COMPANY
RESPONSIBLE DID NOT DISCLOSE
FULL FOOTAGE. EXCUSE ME. FULL
FOOTAGE TO THE DMV INITIALLY.
MEANWHILE, THE COMPANY IS
DEPLOYING THE TECHNOLOGY, ARE
PULLING OUT ALL STOPS, LOBBYING
FOR EXPANSION OVER THE
PASSIONATE OBJECTION OF LOCAL
OFFICIALS. SO LET ME MAKE THIS
CLEAR THAT I BELIEVE THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS GREAT POTENTIAL,
WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL
AFFIRMATIVELY RECOGNIZES WE
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD WITH TESTING
AND DEPLOYMENT OF THESE
VEHICLES. BUT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THE SAN FRANCISCO EXPERIENCE
WON'T BE REPEATED IN TESTING
DRIVERLESS TRUCKS. UNLIKE SAN
FRANCISCO TAXIS, THESE VEHICLES
WEIGH AN EXTRA 76,000 POUNDS
DRIVE AT SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
SPEEDS AND PRESENT AN
EXPONENTIALLY GREATER THREAT TO
THE PUBLIC. WE NEED THE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING IN AB
2286 TO GET A REAL SENSE OF
BROADER IMPACTS OF AV TRUCKING
TECHNOLOGY. SO ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS INCLUDE THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT IN A MORE
TRANSPARENT PROCESS. AS THE
FINAL DECISION IS MADE TO REMOVE
HUMANS FROM TRUCKING IN OUR
STATE, WE ALL OF US HERE ANSWER
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. IT
AFFIRMATIVELY LAYS THE
GROUNDWORK FOR COMPANIES TO TEST
AND DEPLOY AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS,
AND IT CONTAINS A STATUTORY
TRIGGER FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION OF FINAL APPROVAL
OF DRIVERLESS OPERATION BASED ON
REAL DATA ANALYZED BY THE SAFETY
EXPERTS IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THEY WILL THEN APPEAR IN A
HEARING TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO ELECTED LEGISLATORS. AT THAT
TIME. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ARE MATT BRAUDE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL, AND STEVE GOULD, CEO
AND FOUNDER OF 160 DRIVING
ACADEMY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MATT BRAD, HERE AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS.
HOPEFULLY MY LAST TIME THIS YEAR
ON AV ISSUES. AND, YOU KNOW, IF
IT FEELS A LITTLE BIT LIKE DEJA
VU WITH THIS, THIS BILL, WE ARE
BACK AGAIN, THIS TIME AND I, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THE IMPETUS AND
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL HASN'T
CHANGED, NOTWITHSTANDING THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO, THAT THERE ARE
VERY SPECIFIC SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT VEHICLES OF THIS
SIZE. 10,000 POUNDS, UP TO
80,000 POUNDS. I WILL TELL YOU
THAT WHEN I TALK TO TEAMSTER UPS
DRIVER, PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY
DO THE FEEDER, THE LONG HAUL,
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT WHEN
THEY SLAM ON THE BRAKES ON A
TRUCK, IT TAKES 525FT FOR IT TO
STOP. AND THAT'S BECAUSE THESE
TRUCKS ARE HEAVY AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE FRANKLY DANGEROUS. AND,
AND, AND SO I REALLY THINK THAT
WITH THIS BILL, AS OUR AUTHOR
SAID, WE'RE ALLOWING THE
TECHNOLOGY TO GO FORWARD. WE'RE
CREATING A PATHWAY THAT
RECOGNIZES, HEY, WE HAVE A HUMAN
ON BOARD AS A AS A SECOND SET
OF, YOU KNOW, SAFETY TO, TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ACCIDENTS DON'T
HAPPEN, NOT UNLIKE YOU TAKE A
LARGE VEHICLE LIKE AN AIRPLANE
HAS A PILOT LARGELY, FLIES ON
AUTOPILOT THESE DAYS. BUT OF
COURSE, WE HAVE A PILOT THERE
FOR BECAUSE OF THOSE COMPELLING
SAFETY REASONS. FINALLY, I'LL
JUST SAY IN TERMS OF THIS, THE
VERSION OF THIS BILL AND, AND
THE BILL LAST YEAR AT THIS POINT
, THEY ARE THE SAME. WE HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. OBVIOUSLY, IT'S
OUR IN OUR INTEREST TO GET A
BILL SIGNED. AND YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO ALL MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO GET
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
COMPROMISE THE SPIRIT OF THE
BILL, BUT STILL ALLOWS THE SAFE
DEPLOYMENT OF THESE VEHICLES. SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
STEVE GOULD, AND I OWN THE 160
DRIVING ACADEMY TRUCK DRIVING
SCHOOLS WITH 154 SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. THE 160 DRIVING
ACADEMY IS THE LARGEST
COMMERCIAL TRAINING INSTITUTION
IN THE NATION. IN 2024, WE PLAN
TO TRAIN OVER 30,000 NEW
PROFESSIONAL TRUCK DRIVERS
ACROSS OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM. IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE TEN ONE, 60
DRIVING ACADEMIES WILL CREATE
OVER 25 NEW TRUCK, 2500 NEW
TRUCK DRIVING JOBS ACROSS THE
STATE THIS YEAR IN CALIFORNIA,
MY COMPANY IS LICENSED AND
GOVERNED BY THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE AND POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION, OR BETTER KNOWN AS
THE BPP. THE 160 DRIVING ACADEMY
IS SINGULARLY FOCUSED ON DRIVER
SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ON OUR ROADWAYS.
IN 2022, THE NATIONAL SAFETY
COUNCIL REPORTED ALMOST 6000
HIGHWAY FATALITIES DUE TO HEAVY
TRUCK INCIDENTS. 437 OF THESE
FATALITIES WERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS MY PARENTS LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO, I HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN THE STATISTIC BY. BY
WAY OF BACKGROUND, I'M THE
FORMER CHIEF SUPPLY CHAIN
OFFICER FOR ALL OF PEPSICO,
AMONG OTHER THINGS, I HAD
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE LARGEST
PRIVATE FLEET IN THE NATION. I
STARTED THE 160 DRIVING ACADEMY
12 YEARS AGO. I SAW FIRSTHAND
THE ISSUES WITH TRAINING AND
SAFETY IN THE STATE OF THE
AMERICAN TRUCK DRIVER. MY FIRST
INTRODUCTION TO AUTONOMOUS
TRUCKING WAS ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
AGO, WHEN AN INVESTOR INTRODUCED
ME TO A COMPANY CALLED OTTO,
WHICH WAS CREATED, WHICH HAD
CREATED AN AUTONOMOUS TRUCK. AT
THAT TIME, NO ONE HAD EVER HEARD
THAT TERM, BUT EVERYONE KNEW
WHAT IT MEANT. A TRUCK THAT HAD
NO DRIVER. I WENT OUT TO SAN
FRANCISCO, AND INDEED, THE OTTO
LEADERSHIP TEAM DEMONSTRATED A
TRUCK IN A CLOSED PARKING LOT
WITH NO DRIVER BEHIND THE WHEEL
DOING FIGURE EIGHTS. YOU'VE
NEVER SEEN A TRUCK WITH NO
DRIVER? LET ME TELL YOU, SEEING
AN 80,000 POUND VEHICLE WITH NO
DRIVER DOING FIGURE EIGHTS IN A
PARKING LOT WILL RAISE YOUR
EYEBROWS. AT THE TIME, I HAD
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS, BUT WAS TOLD
BY THE COMPANY THAT THEY WOULD
BE COMMERCIALIZED IN FIVE YEARS.
THEY'D BE RETROFITTING
RETROFITTING THE 3 MILLION
TRUCKS IN THE NATION WITH LIDAR
CAMERA SYSTEMS. AND THE COMPANY
HAD A NUMBER THAT COMPANY AND
THEY WOULD BE SORRY IN THE
NATION WITH LIDAR CAMERA
SYSTEMS, THAT COMPANY AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER COMPANIES WHO
HAVE SPENT. I WOULD GUESS,
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
AUTONOMOUS TRUCKING AS A
SOLUTION TO THE AMERICAN
TRUCKING INDUSTRY. MANY, MANY OF
THOSE NO LONGER EXIST. I THINK
THERE ARE THREE KEY AREAS THAT
MANY WHO INVEST IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY OVERLOOK. WHEN MAKING
PROCLAMATIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS AND THEIR
IMPACT ON THE US TRUCKING
INDUSTRY. BY FAR THE FIRST IS
SAFETY. IT WOULD SEEM LIKE AN
EASY FIX TO REDUCE HIGHWAY
ACCIDENTS THROUGH IMPROVED
TRAINING, BUT TO THINK THAT A
TRUCK WITH A PROPERLY TRAINED
DRIVER IS GOING TO HAVE LESS
ACCIDENTS THAN A TRUCK WITHOUT A
DRIVER SIMPLY MAKES NO SENSE.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE ALGORITHM
CAN'T RESPOND FAST ENOUGH, OR
THE CELL NETWORK CAN'T RESPOND?
I LIVE IN CHICAGO, AND A FEW
YEARS BACK THERE WAS AN ANALYSIS
ON IF A ROBOT CAN MAKE DECISIONS
FASTER THAN MICHAEL JORDAN WHEN
HE DRIVES A LANE. THEY TESTED
NUMEROUS ALGORITHMS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND HAS FOUND THAT
A COMPUTER'S JUDGMENT CANNOT
REACT FASTER THAN A HUMAN. IN A
BASKETBALL GAME. I WOULD SAY THE
SAME THING IS TRUE WHILE DRIVING
AN 80,000 POUND TRUCK. THERE ARE
SIMPLY TOO MANY VARIABLES TO
IDENTIFY AND TOO SHORT OF A TIME
TO MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION. AND
I THINK WE'VE ALL HEARD ABOUT
THE INCIDENTS THAT AUTONOMOUS
CARS AND TRUCK TESTING HAVE
CAUSED, WHICH IS TRULY
UNFORTUNATE. TRUCK DRIVING IS
NOT A REPEATABLE ROBOTIC TASK.
EVERY SECOND CAN BE DIFFERENT
FOR THE DRIVER, WHICH IS WHY
SAFETY TRAINING IS CRITICAL
HERE, AS WELL AS THE ABILITY TO
REACT IN A SPLIT SECOND. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS JOBS. 30 YEARS
AGO, TRUCKING WAS A RESPECTABLE
MIDDLE CLASS PROFESSION. TODAY,
COMPANIES LIKE UPS AND WALMART
PUBLICLY ADVERTISE THEIR TRUCK
DRIVING JOBS AT OVER $100,000
PER YEAR, PLUS ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. AND THAT NUMBER
CONTINUES TO GROW. TO THINK THAT
WE WANT TO DISPLACE THE 3
MILLION PLUS AMERICAN TRUCK
DRIVERS IN THIS COUNTRY WHO
SUPPORT THIS INDUSTRY WITH
ROBOTS, WOULD BE A DISSERVICE TO
SO MANY HARD WORKING
INDIVIDUALS. FINALLY, THERE'S
COST. I WAS STARTING TO SEE WE
ARE STARTING TO SEE $100 MILLION
NUCLEAR JUDGMENTS WHEN THERE'S A
TRUCKING ACCIDENT, AND MAYBE
RIGHTLY SO. IF THE DRIVER HAS
NOT BEEN PROPERLY TRAINED OR
SOMEONE STAYING ON THE ROAD TOO
LONG IN INCLEMENT INCLEMENT
WEATHER, BUT WHO'S GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN AN AUTONOMOUS
TRUCK TAKES OUT A FAMILY OF
FOUR? THE ROBOT SET ASIDE THE
PERSONAL TRAGEDY HOW MANY, HOW
MUCH INSURANCE COVERAGE WILL BE
ENOUGH? DO WE REALLY WANT TO
WAIT TO FIND OUT, AS THESE COSTS
WILL IMPACT ALL TRUCKING
COMPANIES INSURANCE RATES?
CLEARLY, THE FOCUS ON SAFETY DUE
TO CRASH PREVENTION TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAS COME IN RECENT YEARS IS
NO DOUBT A HUGE BENEFIT HERE AND
NOW, INTEGRATED INTO MANY OF THE
OEM STANDARD FEATURES AS WELL AS
OUR CARS. OTHER BENEFITS LIKE
FUEL EFFICIENCY AND BRAKE
ASSISTANCE. I'LL HAVE TO WRAP UP
SOON. HELP HELP PRODUCTIVITY
INDUSTRY. BUT EVEN WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES INTEGRATING THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY, HIGHWAY
FATALITY RATES CONTINUE TO GROW.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE TECHNOLOGY BY
ITSELF IS A SOLUTION HERE. THE
HUMAN AND THE MODEL SIMPLY
CANNOT BE REPLACED. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. OKAY. THANK
YOU. PLEASE COME ON UP. IF YOU
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MATT.
HEADACHE WITH THE TRANSPORT
WORKERS UNION IN SUPPORT. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, IVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
A PROUD CO-SPONSOR. MITCH
STEIGER, WITH CFT ALSO IN
SUPPORT. JAMES LOMBARDO, ON
BEHALF OF ABATE MOTORCYCLISTS
RIGHTS AND SAFETY ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT. RYAN SNOW,
BROTHERHOOD OF LOCOMOTIVE
ENGINEERS AND TRAINMEN SUPPORT.
MR. CHAIR MEMBERS LOUIE ACOSTA
WITH SMART TRANSPORTATION. STATE
LEGISLATIVE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MEGAN
ADAMS FOR SMART LOCAL 1741.
SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SYLVIA SOLIS
SHORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SCOTT
BRANT, SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION, LOCAL 1201 OUT OF
STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JAMIE
PAQUETTE, SMART SUPPORT.
JONATHAN ESPOSITO, LOCAL 1732,
SMART TD, AMTRAK AND CALTRANS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA.
I DO SUPPORT. MR. CHAIR MATT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION,
I'M IN A BIT OF A TWEENER SPOT.
IF YOU WOULD MIND STARTING ME
SECONDS. THANK YOU. SIR, WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS TO TRY TO HAVE
THE BILL REFLECT THE PROCESS
THAT I THINK YOU WERE FAMILIAR
WITH IN YOUR PAST ROLE THAT WE
WORKED WITH ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS, THAT ALLOWS
THAT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS, EXCUSE ME TO OCCUR
BEFORE THE DEPLOYMENT OF THESE
VEHICLES. SO WE HOPE WE CAN FIND
SOME AMENDMENTS IN A PATH
FORWARD THAT ALLOW US TO
RECOGNIZE THAT PROCESS IN THIS
BILL, BECAUSE IT DOES APPLY TO
COMMERCIAL HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES,
WHICH INCLUDES OUR TRANSIT
VEHICLES, AND WE ARE FULLY ON
BOARD WITH ALL OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
IN THE BILL. I'M HAPPY TO
SUBSCRIBE TO THOSE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION, OPPOSITION WITNESSES
MAY COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
AND PLEASE BE SEATED.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AGAIN.
MY NAME IS RENEE GIBSON. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. I'M
TESTIFYING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB 2286, ALONGSIDE DOZENS OF
GROUPS THAT REPRESENTS THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
MILLIONS OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AVIA SHARES THE SAFETY CONCERNS
OF THE AUTHOR. SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIANS LESS
SAFE BECAUSE IT WOULD HALT THE
DEPLOYMENT OF AV TRUCKS BY
IMPOSING A PERMANENT BAN ON
DRIVERLESS AV TRUCKS IN
CALIFORNIA, WITH NO ARTICULATED
PATH FOR THE STATE TO APPROVE
AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS, AND WITHOUT
ANY DEMONSTRATION OF WHY A HUMAN
OPERATOR WILL IMPROVE SAFETY, WE
HAVE ATTEMPTED TO MEET WITH THE
AUTHOR TO DISCUSS AN APPROPRIATE
PATH FORWARD FOR THIS BILL, AND
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY RESPONSE.
WHEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETOED THE SAME
BILL LAST YEAR, HE EXPLAINED
THAT THE BILL WAS, QUOTE,
UNNECESSARY FOR THE OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATION OF HEAVY DUTY
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY.
IN CALIFORNIA, AV TRUCKS HAVE
BEEN PROHIBITED HERE FOR 13
YEARS. THE DMV HAS BEEN WORKING
ON RULES TO GET THIS TECHNOLOGY
SLOWLY ROLLED OUT FOR THE BETTER
PART OF A DECADE, AND AFTER
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS IN
INVESTMENT AND THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES COUNTING ON IT,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SAID THEY ARE
JUST MONTHS AWAY FROM PUTTING
OUT DRAFT RULES. BUT THIS BILL
WOULD SHUT DOWN, SHUT IT DOWN
FOR A MINIMUM OF ANOTHER SIX
YEARS WITH NO GUARANTEE OF EVER
LETTING IT HAPPEN. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERT REGULATORS BE ALLOWED TO
DO THEIR JOB. THIS BILL WOULD
TAKE THE DRACONIAN STEP OF
PREMATURELY SHUTTING DOWN AN
INDUSTRY BEFORE IT IS EVEN
ALLOWED IN CALIFORNIA. WE
THEREFORE STRONGLY URGE A VOTE
OF NO AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS PETER
MUNOZ WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP. AUTONOMOUS
TRUCKS WILL MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER
, BOOST SUPPLY CHAIN EFFICIENCY
AND CREATE NEW HIGH QUALITY JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS. AB 2286 WOULD BLOCK
CALIFORNIANS FROM ACCESSING THE
BENEFITS OF AUTONOMOUS TRUCKING
TECHNOLOGY AND FURTHER SETBACK
THE STATE ON THIS CRITICAL
INNOVATION. THE AV INDUSTRY IS
CURRENTLY LEVERAGING THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE TO CREATE NEW
ROLES FOR DIFFERENT EDUCATION
AND SKILL LEVELS. MANY OF THE
JOBS CREATED WILL NOT REQUIRE A
COLLEGE DEGREE, SUCH AS SERVICE
TECHNICIANS, REMOTE ASSISTANCE
OPERATORS, MAPPING DATA
COLLECTORS, AND DELIVERY
PACKERS. WORKERS WITH EXPERIENCE
IN THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY
SPECIFICALLY OFFER VALUABLE
SKILLS TO AV TRUCKING. EMPLOYERS
MAKE NO MISTAKE, AMERICA'S TRUCK
DRIVERS AND AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS
WILL COEXIST AND THRIVE IN THE
FUTURE. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DATA
SHOWS THAT OUR COUNTRY MUST MOVE
50% MORE FREIGHT BY 2050.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS AT CURRENT
FREIGHT LEVELS, RESULTING IN
REDUCED SUPPLIES OF GOODS FOR
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES,
AS WELL AS THE STRAIN OF HIGHER
PRICES, ESPECIALLY IN LOWER
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE US TRUCKING
INDUSTRY IS CURRENTLY SHORT OF
AN ESTIMATED 78,000 TRUCK
DRIVERS DUE TO A LONG TERM
DECLINE IN NEW DRIVERS ENTERING
THE PROFESSION AND AN ANNUAL
TURNOVER RATE EXCEEDING 90. THIS
TRUCK DRIVER SHORTAGE IS
ESTIMATED TO REACH 160,000. IN
2031. CALIFORNIA MUST FIND NEW
WAYS TO MOVE MORE FREIGHT WITH
FEWER TRUCK DRIVERS TO DO IT.
AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS ARE ONE PART
OF THAT SOLUTION. WE BELIEVE
THAT AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS WILL HELP
INCREASE THE QUALITY OF LIFE AS
WELL. FOR WORKERS IN THE
LOGISTICS INDUSTRY AND DEVELOP A
STRONGER WORKFORCE. THIS
TECHNOLOGY PRESENTS AN ARRAY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AS WELL,
INCLUDING GREATER FUEL
EFFICIENCY, MORE EFFICIENT USE
OF PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE,
REDUCED CONGESTION AND REDUCED
AGRICULTURAL SPOILAGE, AND
RELATED PRESERVATION OF SOIL AND
WATER RESOURCES. MOREOVER,
AUTONOMOUS LONG HAUL TRUCKING
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BROADLY
BENEFIT THE ECONOMY BY IMPROVING
THE EFFICIENCY OF COUNTLESS
INDUSTRIES THAT RELY ON MOVING
GOODS, SUCH AS AGRICULTURE,
RETAIL, AND MANUFACTURING.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY FUNDED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION.
AUTOMATING LONG HAUL TRUCK
DRIVING WILL SPUR $111 BILLION
IN AGGREGATE INVESTMENT SPENDING
ACROSS THE US ECONOMY AND WILL
INCREASE TOTAL US EMPLOYMENT BY
26 TO 35,000 JOBS PER YEAR ON
AVERAGE IN CALIFORNIA,
ESPECIALLY. ONE RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT AUTONOMOUS TRUCKING
TECHNOLOGY CAN ADD 6.5 TO $8
BILLION IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY TO
THE STATE. YOU'RE ABOUT EQUAL
WITH THE SUPPORT NOW FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
2286. THANK YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU, OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
MAY COME FORWARD. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, DEAN TALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, TIMOTHY BURR ON BEHALF
OF AURORA INNOVATION KODIAK
GADEK, WABI AND TESLA ALL
OPPOSED. THANK YOU, MANDY ISAACS
LEE HERE FOR CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GRACE COPELAND HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AT THIS
TIME, SENATOR BLAKESTER. YES.
THANK YOU, SO I VOTED FOR THIS
IN COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR
LAST YEAR AND IN THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO, HE SAID THAT THE DMV IS
WORKING ON IT. SO I WANTED TO
JUST ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DMV,
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, WHAT
IS THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
WORKING ON IT? BECAUSE NOW IT'S
BEEN A WHILE AND I WONDER WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT. THE VETO MESSAGE SAID THAT
THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ME, AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO DO
THAT, THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING
PIECES RIGHT NOW, AS YOU KNOW,
IN THIS BUILDING, AND MINE HAS
NOT BEEN I DON'T THINK A
PRIORITY AT THIS POINT. BUT
THEY'RE LOOKING FORWARD US TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT, THE DMV
WAS, THEY THEY'VE BEEN IN DOING
THIS FOR TEN YEARS, AND WE STILL
DON'T HAVE THE DATA THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE, AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED, AND I WOULD PROPOSE
THAT, THEY MAY NOT STILL HAVE
THAT. AND WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
IT AND ASKING FOR IT, SO I IT'D
BE THE BEST PART IS IF THEY WE
HAD AN ANALYSIS AND WE TOOK IT
TO THE GOVERNOR AND WE WOULD
HAVE THAT. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THEIR ANALYSIS. AND I'M
FRUSTRATED THAT THIS HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR SUCH A LONG TIME.
AND HOW LONG ARE WE GOING TO
WAIT UNTIL SOMEONE ELSE GETS
HURT? SO I, I RESPECTFULLY,
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. LABOR HAS
EVEN BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE. MY SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH HIS OFFICE AS WELL.
AND SO WE'RE HOPING TO COME TO
SOME RESOLUTION. BUT I KNOW IT
SEEMS LIKE, OH, IT'S BACK AGAIN.
YOU'RE RIGHT. IT'S GOING TO BE
BACK AGAIN UNTIL WE MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE ON THE
ROADS THAT WE HAVE, THE
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. AS I'VE SAID ALL ALONG,
I'M NOT AGAINST THE TECHNOLOGY
AT ALL. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S DONE RIGHT, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW AS WELL AS I DO ONE BAD
THING THAT HAPPENS THAT IT'S
GOING TO SEND THE AUTONOMOUS
TRUCKING TEN YEARS BACK. I DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS. SENATOR NEWMAN, SENATOR
NHîNG, ARE YOU IN? GO AHEAD.
I'LL. I'LL COME BACK NEXT. VICE
CHAIR. APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. SO, SO THE OPPOSITION
HAS MADE THE ASSERTION THAT,
APPLYING THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL WOULD, WOULD SEVERELY
HANDICAP THE DEVELOPMENT OF AB,
TRUCKING IN CALIFORNIA, AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, YOU'RE SIMPLY
ASKING FOR AN OPERATOR TO BE
PRESENT UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE
HAVE DATA. ABSOLUTELY. OKAY. SO,
YOU KNOW, TO THE OPPOSITION, CAN
CAN YOU ELABORATE, PLEASE? WE
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
YOUR POINT. SO, SO TO THE POINT
WHERE WE'VE BEEN WAITING ON
THESE REGS FROM THE, FROM THE,
THE, THE FROM THE DMV AND CPUC
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS, AND WE
WOULD JUST ASK THAT, THAT
PROCESS BE ALLOWED TO PLAY OUT.
WE'RE HOPING TO SEE DRAFT REGS
THAT THE INDUSTRY COULD
POTENTIALLY RESPOND TO. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT PROCESS
COULD TAKE A COUPLE OF YEARS,
FROM THE POINT OF DRAFT REGS
BEING RELEASED IN AN ACTUAL
FINALIZATION OF A RULE, AND THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE IMPOSE A
TIMELINE OF ANOTHER SIX YEARS ON
TOP OF THAT. SO TO THAT END, I
THINK WE WOULD JUST ASK THAT
THE, THE ADMINISTRATION BE
ALLOWED TO DO ITS JOB, AND THAT
TIMELINE IS SIX YEARS UNTIL IT
WOULD BE ALLOWED FOR AV TRUCKS
TO OPERATE WITHOUT A DRIVER. IS
THAT CORRECT? IT WOULD BE UNTIL
THERE IS A, THEY CALL IT A
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THE STATE
OF AV TECHNOLOGY FOR HEAVY DUTY
AVS, BUT IT'S NOT EXPRESSLY
REQUIRED IN THE BILL TO HOLD
THAT HEARING. AND SO
ESSENTIALLY, THE BILL WOULD SET
UP A PROCESS WHERE, YOU COULD
EFFECTIVELY NOT EVER AUTHORIZE
DRIVERLESS. BUT IN THE INTERIM,
DOESN'T YOUR BILL STILL ALLOW
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT AND TESTING
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY WHILE SIMPLY
ENSURING THAT THERE IS A HUMAN
PRESENCE, IS THAT I UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY. RIGHT. OKAY. SO THESE
TWO THINGS DON'T SEEM TO ME TO
BE MUTUALLY TECHNOLOGY. I HAVE
NEVER SAID NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
ON. NOT ONE TIME HAVE I SAID
THAT. I SAID I WOULD LIKE A
HUMAN SAFETY OPERATOR IN THERE,
AS WE DO THE TESTING AND
COLLECTING THE DATA, I BELIEVE.
MR. IF YOU DON'T MIND, MR. BROAD
HAD A QUESTION OR A RESPONSE AS
WELL THROUGH THE CHAIR, IF
THAT'S OKAY, YEAH, JUST JUST
VERY, VERY BRIEFLY, YOU KNOW,
THE TIMELINE UNDER THE BILL IS
THAT IF THE BILL IS PASSED,
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, THE
COMPANIES WOULD BEGIN TO BE ABLE
TO DEPLOY WITH A HUMAN SAFETY
OPERATOR ON BOARD, AND THEN THEY
WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK AFTER
FIVE YEARS. THERE'S A CONVENING
BETWEEN LABOR AGENCY, BETWEEN,
CALTRANS, BETWEEN THE DMV, CPUC,
HIGHWAY PATROL, TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS AND, AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION OF THE EFFICACY OF
THE TECHNOLOGY. I THINK OUR
POINT IS, WHY RUSH TO PUT THE
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE AND
POTENTIALLY CAUSE THE RISK, THE
POTENTIAL HARM VERSUS LET'S SAY,
OKAY, LET'S HAVE A DRIVER ON
BOARD, YOU CAN STILL TEST IT,
YOU CAN STILL DEPLOY IT. AND
THEN WE CAN WE CAN MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON THE HUMAN
SAFETY OPERATOR REQUIREMENT. I
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION. CLEARLY, IF
YOU'RE STILL WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THERE'S A
OPENNESS TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THAT TRANSITION PERIOD AT THE
END OF FIVE YEARS, IS THAT
CORRECT? I JUST WANT TO GET
THAT'S CORRECT. WHEN YOU PUT THE
VETO MESSAGE IN THERE, IT SAID
TO ME, I'M OPEN TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NEAL. VICE CHAIR NEAL. YES,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU HAVE
STATED THAT YOU'RE NOT OPPOSED
TO THE TECHNOLOGY. IT'S A SAFETY
FEATURE. I'VE MET WITH YOU ABOUT
LAST YEAR'S BILL. I SUPPORTED
LAST YEAR'S BILL ON THAT BASIS.
I'M. SO YOU'RE DOING IT AGAIN?
BEG YOUR PARDON? I'M JUST
TEASING YOU ON ON THAT BASIS,
I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AGAIN, BUT I'M A BIT TROUBLED BY
THE YOUR SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS.
IF I UNDERSTOOD WHAT HE SAID, HE
BASICALLY SPOKE COMPLETELY
AGAINST THE TECHNOLOGY. I DIDN'T
HEAR HIM TALK ABOUT THE TESTING
PERIOD. AND EVENTUALLY THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN SUCCEED AND BE
SUCCESSFUL. I, I KIND OF HEARD
HIM TESTIFY COMPLETELY AGAINST
IT. THAT I MISSED SOMETHING
THERE. I DON'T KNOW, WHAT SHOULD
WE ASK HIM? YEAH. NO, I, TOTALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL, WHAT? I KNOW
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL ANALOGY.
ARE THE TECHNOLOGY NÓ. I THINK
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENT AS I SAID, AT THE
VERY END OF MY STATEMENT WITH,
ANTI-CRASH TECHNOLOGY AND FUEL
EFFICIENCY, THOSE ARE ALL GREAT
THINGS FOR THE INDUSTRY BEYOND
SAFETY. AND SO I TOTALLY SUPPORT
THE TECHNOLOGY. I THINK 100% YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE DRIVER IN THE
CAB, AS PART OF THIS MODEL.
ABSOLUTELY. FOR HOW LONG? FOR
HOW LONG UNTIL I DON'T KNOW. I
DON'T SEE THERE'S A THERE'S NOT
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION, BUT I
DON'T REALLY HAVE A TIMELINE
RIGHT NOW. I HAVEN'T I HAVE YET
TO SEE HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE. A SOLUTION, THAT'S MY
CONCERN. AND IF THAT IS, THE, I
DON'T GET THAT. THAT'S THE YOUR
SPIRIT OF THE BILL. BUT, IT'S
INTERESTING AS WE MOVE THIS BILL
ALONG, IS THAT DIFFERENT
COMPANIES WILL TELL YOU, WELL,
IT'LL BE TEN YEARS BEFORE WE
REALLY HAVE THE. OR IT COULD BE
TWO YEARS. SO NOT EVEN THE
INDUSTRY KNOWS QUITE WHEN IT'S
GOING TO BE READY FOR PRIME
TIME. SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
MOVING TARGET ON IT. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOME GUARDRAILS
AROUND IT TO MAKE SURE THE
PUBLIC IS SAFE. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND
PROVEN IN THIS BILL. MR. CHAIR,
MAY I ADD SOMETHING TO THE LAST
COMMENT? IF THAT'S OKAY? I THINK
THE WITH DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR, I THINK IT'S THAT
COMPLEXITY THAT REALLY COMPELS
THE NEED FOR HAVING A RULEMAKING
PROCESS THAT THE DMV WAS IN THE
PROCESS OF, OF LOOKING TO HAVE
THAT WOULD BRING TOGETHER
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS,
DIFFERENT VOICES, INDUSTRY,
LABOR, CONSUMER GROUPS, ETC.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THERE IS
THAT COMPLEXITY AND SO SHORT
CIRCUITING THAT PROCESS AND
MOVING QUICKLY TO LEGISLATE IN
THIS ARENA, I THINK, DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO BRING THOSE VOICES
TOGETHER TO FULLY CONSIDER THE
DIFFERENT COMPLEXITIES. SO I
THINK THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF THE
INDUSTRY FOLKS HAVE A CONCERN
WITH. AND A LOT OF THE DIFFERENT
CONSUMER GROUPS AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS, AS WELL. THE
CHAIR, VICE CHAIR, NEIL, ARE YOU
CEDING THE FLOOR AT THIS POINT?
I MOVE THE BILL, BUT WE STILL
HAVE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK.
I'M GOING TO GO TO SENATOR DODD.
YEAH, I'M GOING TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY. I SUPPORTED IT
THE LAST TIME, BUT I THINK A
LITTLE DOSE OF REALITY HERE IS,
IS IMPORTANT, THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE. NORMALLY, I WOULD
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL TODAY. I
KNOW THIS AUTHOR. I KNOW THAT
SHE'S GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
THIS PROBLEM. BUT I DO HAVE A
PROBLEM WHERE YOU'RE CONFLATING
THE AV ISSUES IN SAN FRANCISCO,
THAT HAVE SO, SO MUCH PROBLEMS
WITH AUTONOMOUS TRUCKS
OPERATING, YOU KNOW, ON ON OUR
HIGHWAYS, THE OTHER THING IS, IS
RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO SUNSET. SO
YOU'RE GOING TO GET BACK A
COMMITTEE. AND THE ONLY WAY
SOMETHING CAN HAPPEN IN THIS
BUILDING, TO RECTIFY THE
SITUATION IS TO GET VOTES IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO OVERTURN A BILL
LIKE THIS. THAT'S WHY I DON'T
REALLY LIKE THIS BILL. IF IT WAS
A IF IT WAS A CLEAR SUNSET ON,
ON ON THIS BILL IN A REASONABLE
PERIOD OF TIME, I THINK IT WOULD
BE MUCH BETTER. BUT I DO BELIEVE
THE AUTHOR HAS GOT A CONNECTION
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY, AND I'LL
SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT WHEN IT GETS
TO THE FLOOR. IF IT'S NOT DONE,
YOU KNOW, TO GO THE OTHER WAY.
POINT WELL TAKEN. THANK YOU.
YES. OF COURSE. AS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW, I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY AS WELL. I DID LAST
TIME AS WELL. I GUESS ANOTHER
DOSE OF REALITY. AND I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH SENATOR DODD'S,
YOU KNOW, CONCERNS. AND I DO
THINK THE EXIT STRATEGY FROM THE
FIVE YEARS PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE
CLEARER. BUT ALSO, I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT'S KIND OF AN
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. REQUEST AT
SOME POINT, THE FORMALITY OF
THAT, BECAUSE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH AN EXECUTIVE BRANCH AGENCY
AND, YOU KNOW, HOPEFULLY THAT
COMES TO FRUITION. I DON'T THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
REALLY MAKE THE CALL ON HERE. I
WILL SAY ALSO, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, MY OPINION, AS ONE
SENATOR, IF YOU'RE WAITING FOR
AGENCY RULEMAKING IN THIS STATE,
TO ENABLE YOU TO DO ANYTHING,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE WAITING A
LONG, LONG TIME, I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH SEVERAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION IN SEVERAL AREAS OF
CONCERN, NOT JUST
TRANSPORTATION, WHERE THE REASON
FOR THE LEGISLATION WAS BECAUSE
WE'D BEEN WAITING FOR 6 OR 7
YEARS, BE IT AROUND WORKPLACE
SAFETY OR ANY NUMBER OF OTHER
ISSUES. FOR THOSE AGENCIES TO
GET THAT WORK DONE. AND THEN
OFTENTIMES WHEN IT DOES GET
DONE, WE HAVE TO COME BACK WITH
LEGISLATION TO AUGMENT IT OR
CLEAN IT UP, BECAUSE FRANKLY,
IT'S SO BAD, SO, YOU KNOW, I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THESE COMMITTEES AND THE
EXPERTISE WITH THE STAFF ON
THESE COMMITTEES OFTENTIMES CAN
BE A LITTLE, A LITTLE MORE
NIMBLE, THAN THE EXECUTIVE
AGENCIES. AND, STEP IN
ESSENTIALLY AND SAY, LOOK, AS
THE AUTHOR HAS SAID HERE, WE
WANT THIS TO COME FORWARD. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TAKE THE POSITION
OF, OF TRYING TO GET IN THE WAY
OF IT. BUT SINCE NOBODY ELSE IS
WRITING ANY RULES AROUND IT,
WE'RE GOING TO COME IN AND DO
THAT AND ENABLE THINGS TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND THAT'S THE SPIRIT
IN WHICH I HAVE ALWAYS TAKEN
THIS BILL ALONG WITH. I WILL
STILL SAY I DO NOT WANT TO BE
DRIVING MY LIGHT VEHICLE OVER
HIGHWAY 152 FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OVER TO HIGHWAY FIVE.
WITH TODAY WITH AN AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE LOADED 80,000 POUNDS
COMING THE OTHER WAY. IT IS, IT
IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TODAY, EVEN
WITH DRIVERS WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE TEAMSTERS, IT IS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE AS A AS A
LIGHT VEHICLE DRIVER TO MAKE
YOUR PASSENGERS FEEL SAFE ON
SOME OF THESE HIGHWAYS. WHEN WE
SAY HIGHWAYS, YOU KNOW, WE ALL
KNOW WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
FOUR LANE, SIX LANE HIGHWAYS
ACROSS THE STATE WHERE THERE'S
AMPLE ROOM, TO NAVIGATE. AND
THAT'S ALL GOING TO NEED TO BE
DEVELOPED AT SOME POINT. AND I
THINK THERE'S A STRONG BELIEF
THAT THAT THAT'S COMING IT'S
COMING, BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INTERIM, AN INTERIM POLICY IN
PLACE FOR HOW WE GET TO THAT
POINT. AND I THINK THIS BILL IS
AS GOOD AS WE'VE SEEN. AND
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN CLOSE THE DEAL
ON IT THIS TIME AROUND. THAT'S
MY SENTIMENT. WITH THAT, I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR A MOTION ON THE
BILL IF THERE WASN'T ONE
ALREADY. SENATOR ARCHULETA IS
MOVING THE BILL AND WE'LL TAKE A
ROLL CALL. VOTE I SHOULD MAKE
ONE TO CLOSE. I'M SO SORRY. NO,
I'D JUST LIKE TO MAKE ONE
COMMENT. YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T WANT
TO COME BACK WITH YOU TO THIS
WITH YOU, TO THIS, WITH THIS
BILL. BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS, IS WE GAVE THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH THIS AUTHORITY BACK IN
2014. AND I THINK WE AS CO-EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO REINSERT
OURSELVES, TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. AND SO WITH THAT, I ASK
YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 14 AB
2286. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR CORTEZ,
AS A COURTESY I NILO NILO I
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE.
SPEER I DALLEY. DODD DODD I
GONZALEZ. LAIRD. LIMÓN NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. CIERTO. UMBERG.
601. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE AT SIX
ZERO, AND WE'LL KEEP THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE EXCELLENT
DISCUSSION TODAY. OUR NEXT
AUTHOR AND FOLLOW ORDER IS ITEM
19 AB 2697, WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN WEBER WHO'S GOING
TO. WELCOME. YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. AND JUST TO POINT OUT
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE ANALYSIS IS BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2697, A BILL RELATED
TO THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
EXPERIENCE AS AN EV DRIVER, I
HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED BY THE ALL
TOO COMMON EXPERIENCE OF TRYING
AND FAILING TO FIND A
FUNCTIONING PUBLIC CHARGER.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC, 41% OF OUR
PUBLIC EV CHARGERS WERE
INSTALLED WITH STATE GRANT AND
TAXPAYER MONEY. THIS AMOUNTS TO
ROUGHLY 40,000 CHARGERS ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS WILL BILL
REQUIRES THAT STATE FUNDED
CHARGERS BE SUBJECT TO ROAMING
AGREEMENTS SO THAT DRIVERS CAN
EASILY ACCESS A WORKING EV
CHARGER USING THEIR PREFERRED
APP. THE REQUIREMENTS IN AB 2697
ARE INTENDED TO BENEFIT
CONSUMERS. SINCE TAXPAYERS HAVE
FUNDED THIS INFRASTRUCTURE,
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT NEARLY $1.7
BILLION ON EV CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. THESE CHARGERS
ARE AT RISK OF BECOMING STRANDED
ASSETS AND I HAVE NO WITNESSES
TODAY. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE,
THERE'S NO WITNESSES. IS THE
AUTHOR SAID, IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO COME FORWARD AND
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL?
PLEASE DO SO NOW. MICHELLE
CONNELLY'S UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. MEGAN MURRAY WITH
ELECTRIFY AMERICA. SO WE DIDN'T
GET OUR LETTER IN QUITE IN TIME
WITH THE QUICK CHANGE FROM
ENERGY TO THIS COMMITTEE, BUT WE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
KAI COOPER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION, ALSO NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL TO THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THAT CONCLUDES
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE BE SEATED. YOU'LL HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES TO SPEAK. I'LL
LET YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. COREY BULLIS, ON BEHALF
OF FLOW EV CHARGING WITH AN
IMPOSE UNLESS AMENDED, POSITION
ON THE BILL. WE'VE BEEN HAVING
REALLY PRODUCTIVE, COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR,
AND WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
TO A SUPPORT POSITION
EVENTUALLY. BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE SOME UNRESOLVED
CONCERNS. IN SHORT, ROAMING
AGREEMENTS ARE A TYPE OF
CONTRACT. THEY'RE A TYPE OF
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP OF WHICH
THE DETAILS ARE NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN TWO COMPANIES THAT ARE
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
CHARGING EXPERIENCE. WE OFTEN
CUSTOMIZE THESE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN EACH OTHER TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR RESPECTIVE CUSTOMERS
AS THEY ROAM BETWEEN OUR
NETWORKS. AB 2697 ENCOURAGES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
ADOPT ROAMING REQUIREMENTS, BUT
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
GUARDRAILS TO RESPECT THESE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS, INCLUDING HOW WE
OPERATIONALIZE OUR CONTRACTS AND
THE MODEL THAT WE USE TO ROAM
WITH ONE ANOTHER. THE RESULTING
EFFECT COULD BE THAT THE
COMMISSION GETS TO PICK WINNERS
AND LOSERS, INCLUDING THE
BUSINESS MODELS THAT WE USE TO
ROAM BETWEEN NETWORKS OR BETWEEN
COMPANIES. I WOULD SAY THIS
COULD ULTIMATELY HAMSTRING
INNOVATION IN WAYS THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY LEAD US TO IMPROVING
THE CHARGING EXPERIENCE VIA THE
MOBILE APPS AND VIA ROAMING,
WHICH IS A GOAL WE SHARE WITH
THE AUTHOR. OF COURSE, AND THIS
COULD THUS ULTIMATELY PASS ON
COSTS TO DRIVERS THAT THEY DO
NOT BEAR TODAY. SO FOR THESE
REASONS, WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
YOU MAY DO SO AT THE MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
SCROGGIN, ON BEHALF OF
CHARGEPOINT, WE HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS COMING OUT OF SENATE
ENERGY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY? SEEING NONE, WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO I WANT TO, ASK ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION AROUND ROAMING.
AND WE'VE HEARD THIS MANY TIMES
BEFORE, ESPECIALLY LAST YEAR,
AND SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IMPROVING INFORMATION
AROUND ACCESS TO RELIABLE
CHARGING. SO I IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN. YOU KNOW HOW I MEAN,
WHAT'S THE PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION AND HOW IS IT
DIRECTLY RELATED OR IN THE WAY
OF ALLOWING FOR I THINK WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO IS TO
SIMPLY TO CREATE A BETTER BASIS
FOR DRIVERS TO KNOW WHERE THE
RELIABLE CHARGERS ARE LOCATED.
SURE. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
AND I JUST WANT TO STATE
CLEARLY, FOR THE RECORD, WE
SUPPORT MORE REQUIREMENTS TO DO
ROAMING WITH OTHER NETWORKS, AND
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF STATE POLICY
MAKING THAT REQUIRES INDUSTRY TO
DO MORE ROAMING AGREEMENTS.
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS OF WHAT
YOU ASKED, THERE'S ULTIMATELY
TWO PRIMARY METHODS ON HOW
COMPANIES ROAM WITH ONE ANOTHER.
ONE'S CALLED A BILATERAL
AGREEMENT. YOU AND I HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH EACH OTHER
DIRECTLY TO EXECUTE OUR ROAMING
AGREEMENT. THE OTHER MODEL IS
CALLED A HUB MODEL. IT'S A THIRD
PARTY ENTITY. THERE'S BEEN A
COUPLE COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED JUST TO PROVIDE THIS
KIND OF HUB THAT THEN WE ENTER
INTO AGREEMENTS WITH THE HUB. SO
RATHER THAN HAVING A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH OTHER,
YOUR RELATIONSHIP IS WITH THE
HUB. AND THE HUB IS WHAT
FACILITATES ROAMING AND BECAUSE
ROAMING IS SO NEW AND IT'S VERY
TECHNICAL, THERE'S LOTS OF
CONSIDERATIONS THAT GO INTO WHY
DOES A COMPANY CHOOSE TO DO A
BILATERAL AGREEMENT, VERSUS WHY
WOULD A COMPANY CHOOSE TO HAVE A
HUB ARRANGEMENT? THERE'S PROS
AND CONS TO BOTH, AND WE'RE
ULTIMATELY LOOKING FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR COMPANIES LIKE
US TO CONTINUE CHOOSING THAT
UNDERLYING MODEL. AND TO BE
CLEAR, THE DRIVER DOES NOT SEE
OR FEEL THAT IMPACT WHEN YOU'RE
USING A MOBILE APP TO FIND A
CHARGING STATION, YOU CAN'T TELL
BEHIND THE SCENES TYPICALLY,
WHAT IS THE METHODOLOGY USED?
THIS IS ALL KIND OF BEHIND THE
SCENES BUSINESS AGREEMENTS, BUT
ARGUABLY THOSE AGREEMENTS MAKE
IT EITHER EASIER OR HARDER FOR A
USER TO SEE WHERE AN AVAILABLE
CHARGER IS LOCATED. AND SO
AGAIN, THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING
TO DO. AND I WOULD ASSUME THAT
FOR THE MOST PART, YOU'D COMPETE
ON PRICE AND THAT, YOU KNOW, I
GUESS YOU'RE TRYING TO WHAT,
PREVENT CIRCUMVENTION BY YOUR
COMPETITORS. LIKE WHAT? WHAT IS
IT ABOUT A BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
HERE THAT THAT IS SOMEHOW AN
IMPEDIMENT TO WHAT I THINK WE
ALL AGREE WOULD BE HUGELY USEFUL
IN CALIFORNIA. SURE. HERE'S ONE
OF THE MORE PROMINENT EXAMPLES.
SO FLO'S HAD ROAMING AGREEMENTS
IN PLACE SINCE 2018. WE WERE
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE FIRST
COMPANIES IN NORTH AMERICA TO
EXECUTE A BILATERAL AGREEMENT.
WE DID IT WITH OUR FRIENDS AT
CHARGEPOINT, AND ONE OF THE
FEATURES OF OUR ROAMING
ARRANGEMENT IS IT IS OFFERED FOR
FREE TO DRIVERS BETWEEN OUR TWO
NETWORKS, SO WE DO NOT CHARGE
DRIVERS AT ALL WHEN THEY'RE
ROAMING USING THE CHARGEPOINT
APP ON A FLO STATION OR VICE
VERSA. TECHNICALLY, IN A HUB
MODEL. SO I'M CLEAR THEY'RE NOT
CHARGING FOR FREE. THEY'RE
SIMPLY NOT CHARGING A PREMIUM.
RIGHT? BECAUSE WE'RE NOT. IF I'M
A CHARGEPOINT CUSTOMER, I'M
PAYING CHARGEPOINT. I ASSUME
THERE'S SOME THAT MONEY'S PASSED
ON TO YOU. YOU'RE YOU ARE STILL
BEING CHARGED FOR USING THE
CHARGING SESSION, BUT JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE USING THE
CHARGEPOINT APP, LET'S SAY TO
THEN ACTIVATE A FLO STATION,
THERE'S NO EXTRA FEE FOR THAT
FEATURE OR THAT SERVICE, HUB
MODELS TYPICALLY DO CHARGE A
FEE. AND THAT GETS PASSED ON TO
THE DRIVER. TYPICALLY AND THAT
IS TO US ONE DOWNSIDE OF A HUB
MODEL. AND WE JUST DON'T SEE
THAT AS HELPING. ULTIMATELY, THE
DRIVER EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE, THOUGH.
AND SO TO THE AUTHOR, IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND RESPONDING. SO,
YOU KNOW, DID I CORRECTLY
SUMMARIZE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO? AND IF SO, HOW SHOULD WE
THINK ABOUT THIS OBJECTION. I
THINK YOU KNOW VERY WELL WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO, WHICH IS TO
EASE THE EXPERIENCE FOR EV
DRIVERS. WE'VE ALL HEARD ALL THE
STORIES WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE OPPOSITION.
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS. A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS DROPPED OUT.
WE'RE WAITING TO GET THE
FEEDBACK FROM THE CEC,
SPECIFICALLY ON ROAMING, BECAUSE
THE AMENDMENTS WERE JUST PUT IN
IN THE ENERGY COMMITTEE, AND
WITH THE, CHAIR, WITH THE
CHAIR'S PERMISSION, WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT
THEY WOULD BE HAPPY WITH. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO RAISE A
QUESTION? YES SENATOR BOXER.
YES. THIS BILL HAS BEEN REALLY
SIMPLIFIED, WHICH I APPRECIATE.
AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL AND
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, SEEING NO
ONE ELSE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED, WE'LL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR HAS MADE THE
MOTION. I'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT
TO STATE THAT MOTION. AND CALL
THE ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 2697. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED.
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
CORTESE, A RATTAZZI I NILO ALAN
ARCHULETA A ARCHULETA I BECKER
BLAKESPEAR BLAKESPEAR I DALLY
DODD DODD I GONZALEZ. LAIRD
LIMÓN NEWMAN. NEWMAN I NGUYEN.
SERRATO UMBERG. 501 ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE AT FIVE ZERO ON CALL.
THANK YOU. GOT A LOT OF MEMBERS
THAT WILL BE COMING BACK HERE
SOON. THANK YOU. YES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER, I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTING
THE LAST TWO BILLS. THE WILSON
BILL, FILE ITEM 26, AND YOUR OWN
BILL, FILE ITEM 27. AND WITH
THAT, I WOULD ASK IF WE CAN GET
ANY HELP FROM, SERGEANTS OR
OTHERS TO GET OUR MEMBERS BACK
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO BE LIFTING
THE CALL BEFORE YOU KNOW IT.
WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO COME
BACK TO YOU AND WHATEVER ORDER
YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE THEM IN IS
FINE WITH US. JUST LET ME KNOW.
ALL RIGHT? I'LL START WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WILSON'S BILL.
AB 3138. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, DO YOU WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON'S OFFICE ON THE
AMENDMENTS NOW IN PRINT, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 3138 ON
HER BEHALF, WHICH WILL ALLOW,
THE TO MODIFY THE EXISTING
ALTERNATIVE DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM TO ALLOW DRIVERS
THE OPTION TO INCLUDE VEHICLE
LOCATION TECHNOLOGY, MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN AS GPS. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS, THIS BILL WILL ALSO
SUBJECT THE DIGITAL PLATES TO
APPROVAL BY BOTH THE DMV AND
CHP, AND WILL REQUIRE THE DMV TO
CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS OF BANNER
MESSAGES DISPLAYED ON LICENSE
PLATES. THIS BUILDS UPON
SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROGRAM
LAUNCHED OVER A DECADE AGO IN
2013. AS STATED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, A 2019 REPORT BY THE
DMV ASSESSING THE ALTERNATIVE
DEVICE PILOT PROGRAM, WHICH
NOTABLY ALLOWED GPS AND BANNER
MESSAGES THEY FOUND, QUOTE, NO
SIGNIFICANT LAW ENFORCEMENT DMV,
OR CUSTOMER CONCERNS. END QUOTE.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW, ALL
DRIVERS WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE METAL PLATE THAT OUR
THAT WE ARE ACCUSTOMED TO
SEEING. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT, BUT IT GIVES
DRIVERS A CHOICE WHETHER THEY
WOULD LIKE AN ALTERNATIVE DEVICE
THAT HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE
DMV AND CHP, AN OPTION THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR YEARS. UNDER THIS
PILOT PROGRAM, THE DIGITAL
PLATES CAN ALSO SERVE TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN VARIOUS WAYS,
SUCH AS DISPLAY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
MESSAGES WHEN A VEHICLE IS
STOLEN, AND AMBER ALERTS. THE
BILL ALSO PUTS IN PLACE PRIVACY
STANDARDS FOR THE GPS PLATES
THAT FAR EXCEED PROTECTIONS IN
CURRENT LAW. FOR OTHER
COMPATIBLE GPS EQUIPPED DEVICES.
AB 3138 REQUIRES THE FOLLOWING
PROTECTIONS FOR ALL GPS ENABLED
PLATES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST, THE GPS SHALL BE CAPABLE
OF BEING PERMANENTLY DISABLED BY
MEANS OF A NONREVERSIBLE METHOD
THAT CEASES ALL FUNCTIONALITY
AND TRACKING INFORMATION.
CAPABILITIES. THE GPS SHALL BE
CAPABLE OF BEING MANUALLY
DISABLED AND ENABLED BY A DRIVER
OF THE VEHICLE, WHILE THAT
DRIVER IS INSIDE THE VEHICLE.
THE METHOD OF MANUALLY DISABLING
AND ENABLING THE GPS SHALL BE
PROMINENTLY LOCATED AND EASY TO
DISABLE, AND ENABLE, WITHOUT
REQUIRING ACCESS TO A REMOTE
ONLINE APPLICATION. THE METHOD
OF MANUALLY DISABLING AND
ENABLING THE GPS SHALL NOT
REQUIRE A PASSWORD OR ANY OTHER
LOGIN INFORMATION. AND FINALLY,
ONCE THE VEHICLE LOCATION
TECHNOLOGY IS MANUALLY DISABLED
FROM INSIDE THE CAR, THE ONLY
METHOD OF RE-ENABLING THE
TECHNOLOGY SHALL BE MANUALLY
FROM INSIDE THE CAR. THE
REGISTERED OWNER OF THE LICENSE
PLATE, THE MANUFACTURER, THE
DMV, OR ANY OTHER ENTITY SHALL
NOT HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
REENGAGE THE GPS THROUGH ANY
REMOTE MEANS. THESE PROTECTIONS
FAR EXCEED PROTECTIONS IN
STATUTE FOR OTHER GPS ENABLED
DEVICES, SUCH AS THE CARS
THEMSELVES. APP TO USE INSIDE
THE CARS, OUR CELL PHONES AND
COUNTLESS OTHER LEGAL PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS AT A MUCH
CHEAPER PRICE. WHILE GPS, LIKE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES, HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABUSED BY BAD
ACTORS, THE APPROPRIATE POLICY
RESPONSE IS TO PUT GUARDRAILS
AND PROTECTIONS IN PLACE, NOT TO
SIMPLY BAN THE TECHNOLOGY IN ONE
SMALL PRODUCT WHILE ALLOWING IT
TO EXIST WITHOUT RECOURSE. AND
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER COMPARABLE
PRODUCT WITH ME TO PRESENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS NEVILLE
BOSTON, THE CO-FOUNDER OF
REVIVER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
NEVILLE BOSTON. I'M THE FOUNDER
AND CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER FOR
REVIVER. AS THE AUTHOR STATED,
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND
REVIVER REMAINS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH STAFF AND MEMBERS
TO GET THE BILL TO A COMFORTABLE
PLACE FOR EVERYONE. AB 3138
BUILDS UPON THE WORK THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN VOTED ON AND
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE. AB
984. IN 2022 AND SB 806 IN 2013,
WHICH THE ORIGINAL PILOT WAS
BUILT AROUND, WE'VE BEEN
EFFECTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
DMV, CHP AND THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LAST, I
WOULD SAY, TEN YEARS, THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE DIGITAL PLATE MUST
COMPLY WITH PROVISIONS TO ENSURE
PRIVACY OF THE CONSUMER IS NOT
COMPROMISED WHILE CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN THE BENEFITS PROVIDED
TO BUSINESSES. TO BE CLEAR,
THERE ARE TWO PLATES OFFERED BY
REVIVER A BATTERY OPERATED PLATE
AND A WIRED PLATE. ONE OFFERS
GPS, WHICH IS THE WIRED PLATE.
THE BATTERY OPERATED PLATE DOES
NOT. 95% OF THE PLATES ON THE
ROAD ARE THE BATTERY OPERATED
PLATES, WHICH DON'T HAVE GPS.
AND THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE WIRED PLATE ARE FLEET
CONSUMERS, ALL REVIVER SERVICES
ARE OPT IN. THE BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT. THE BILL WILL HELP
TO MAINTAIN CONSUMER SAFETY AND
PRIVACY RIGHTS BY STRENGTHENING
THE PARAMETERS AROUND
GEOLOCATION TECHNOLOGY. IT WILL
DO THIS BY REQUIRING THE PRODUCT
IS CAPABLE OF BEING PERMANENTLY
DISABLED FROM WITHIN THE CAR AND
BEING MANUALLY DISABLED BY THE
DRIVER INSIDE THE VEHICLE. THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL CLEARLY
STATES IF THE ALTERNATIVE DEVICE
FAILS TO MEET REQUIREMENTS.
VEHICLE LOCATION TECHNOLOGY WILL
NOT BE INCLUDED IN THE DEVICE.
AB AB 984 MOVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE IN 2022. THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN AS A
RESULT OF A CONVERSATION IN
OPPOSITION TO INCLUDING A KILL
SWITCH IN THE MECHANISM, WHICH
WE WERE ABLE TO DO, THE
GEOLOCATION TECHNOLOGY IS
BENEFICIAL FOR FLEETS, AND WE
HAD TESTIMONY TO THAT FACT
PREVIOUSLY, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND THE OTHER WITNESS, ARE YOU
GOING TO SPEAK OR ARE YOU JUST
HERE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS?
THANK YOU, OTHERS WHO WOULD WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
MAY COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME.
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM, I THINK WE HAVE
SOMEONE COMING FORWARD IN
SUPPORT. IS THAT RIGHT? THAT'S
RIGHT. THIS IS THE ME TOO
PERIOD. NAME, AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WANT TO DO THAT? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO ONE. DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YOU MAY BE SEATED AT
THE TABLE. WELCOME. HELLO. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
CATALINA SANCHEZ, LEGISLATIVE
ACTIVIST WITH THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION, HERE,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING AB 3138,
WHICH WOULD TURN A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION PRODUCT INTO A
SURVEILLANCE TRACKER THAT
RECORDS EVERYWHERE THE VEHICLE
GOES. THIS IS BAD NEWS FOR
CALIFORNIANS EVERYWHERE, BUT IT
WOULD BE ESPECIALLY DEADLY FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY, IMMIGRANTS,
PEOPLE SEEKING ABORTIONS, RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, NUMEROUS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, LGBTQI REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE, YOUTH AND PRIVACY
ORGANIZATIONS HAD SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH AB NINE EIGHT 4 IN
2022. THAT BILL ALSO PROPOSED
ALLOWING GPS TRACKING DEVICES IN
PASSENGER LICENSE PLATES. AB
3138 WOULD REMOVE THE LANGUAGE
IN AB 984 THAT WE NEGOTIATED TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS, THOUGH
ALL THE CONCERNS THESE GROUPS
RAISED ABOUT THE HARMFUL IMPACTS
OF GPS TRACKERS AND TECH ENABLED
ABUSE THEN REMAIN TODAY.
CREATING THESE GPS TRACKING
DEVICES WOULD JEOPARDIZE
CONFIDENTIALITY AND INCREASE THE
RISK OF STALKING, WHICH CAN BE
DEADLY. THAT IS WHY NUMEROUS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ORGANIZATIONS
JOINED US IN IN OPPOSING AB 984
UNTIL IT WAS AMENDED TO PROHIBIT
THE INCLUSION OF GPS. PEOPLE WHO
ABUSE HAVE NO INCENTIVE TO LET
THEIR PARTNER KNOW THEIR CAR HAS
BECOME A TRACKING DEVICE, EVEN
IF PEOPLE WHO SUFFER ABUSE ARE
AWARE OF THE GPS TRACKING, THEY
MAY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO SUBMIT
TO THAT TRACKING BECAUSE THEY
MAY NOT KNOW HOW TO DISABLE IT
AND DOING SO COULD PUT THEM AT
THE ESCALATION OF MORE THAN
VIOLENCE. OTHER COMMUNITIES ARE
PUT AT RISK BY AB 3138. IT COULD
JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY OF SOMEONE
TRAVELING TO CALIFORNIA FROM OUT
OF STATE. IT MAY NOT BE AWARE
THAT THEIR VEHICLE OR RIDESHARE
IS RECORDING THEIR DRIVE AS THEY
MAKE THEIR WAY TO A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CLINIC. DATA THAT
COULD THEN BE USED AS EVIDENCE
AGAINST THEM. ICE COULD ALSO USE
THE GPS SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
TO TRACK AND LOCATE IMMIGRANTS,
AS IT HAS DONE WITH OTHER
LOCATION TRACKING DEVICES.
UNSUPPORTIVE PARENTS OF QUEER
YOUTH YOUTH COULD USE GPS
ENABLED PLATES TO MONITOR
WHETHER TEENS ARE GOING TO LOCAL
LGBTQ CENTERS. THE APRIL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR DRIVERS TO TURN OFF
TRACKING. HOWEVER, THIS FALLS
SHORT OF WHAT IS NEEDED TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS WHILE MAKING
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE WAYS TO
TURN OFF TRACKING ARE BOTH
PROMINENT AND EASY TO TURN OFF.
DOES EMPOWER DRIVERS. THESE
CHANGES ARE NOT ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERN ABOUT
SITUATIONS IN WHICH PEOPLE FEEL
PRESSURED BY PARTNERS OR THEIR
FAMILY TO SUBMIT TO THAT
TRACKING. LASTLY, THERE ARE
SECURITY CONCERNS AFTER AB 984
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW, RESEARCHERS
UNCOVERED THAT REVIVER HAD AN
ALARMING SECURITY VULNERABILITY
IN ITS SYSTEMS THAT MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR INFILTRATORS TO
TRACK VEHICLES BY GPS IN REAL
TIME AND EVEN CHANGE WHAT THE
PLATES DISPLAYED. MORE GENERALLY
, ANY COMPANY THAT SELLS DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATES WITH GPS TRACKING
WOULD HAVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS
PRECISE LOCATION DATA RIGHT NOW,
EVEN IF THESE COMPANIES DO NOT
SELL THEIR DATA COMMERCIALLY,
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS MAY NEVERTHELESS BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT DATA. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO JOIN IN IN OPPOSITION? YOU
MAY COME FORWARD AND EXPRESS Ã
ME TO MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ANTHONY SAMSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION. APOLOGIES. I
INTENDED TO COME UP FOR SUPPORT.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GEORGE TH¤U, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
. THANK YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS POINT, SENATOR NEWMAN,
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF. SO TO, THE
COMPANIES. SO AT THE MOMENT, WHO
CAN SEE THE GPS INFORMATION THAT
THAT IS MADE POSSIBLE BY THE
LICENSE PLATE, JUST THE USER.
JUST THE USER. YEAH. AND HOW DO
YOU RESPOND TO CONCERNS ABOUT
VULNERABILITIES AND YOUR ABILITY
TO, SET THOSE? SO I THINK SHE
WAS REFERENCING, SOMETHING IT
WAS A, I THINK A WHITE HAT
HACKER THAT HAD LOOKED INTO IT.
THERE WAS NO INFORMATION THAT
WAS SHARED. AND WHATEVER
VULNERABILITIES WERE TAKEN CARE
OF BY THE COMPANY THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE CHAIR. CAN I RESPOND
TO THAT? YES. YEAH THERE WAS
ALSO VULNERABILITIES FOUND WITH
EVERY OTHER CAR MANUFACTURER,
WHILE THAT RESEARCHER WAS DOING
THEIR RESEARCH AND BASICALLY
ASKED EVERY ONE OF THOSE
COMPANIES TO RESPOND WITHIN 24
HOURS AND FIX THE VULNERABILITY.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD,
ESSENTIALLY EXPOSE IT. WHICH
REVIVER WAS ABLE TO FIX THE
VULNERABILITY. SO WHEN THEY
TRIED TO RE PENETRATE IT, THEY
WERE UNABLE TO DO SO. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT, YOU KNOW, THESE
WERE, KNOWN VULNERABILITIES,
THEY NEVER EXPOSED A USER TO NØ
ANY KIND OF RISK. NO. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THERE'S THROUGH THE
CHAIR. THERE'S ALSO SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN 1984 THAT PROHIBITS
ANY ANY DATA SHARING OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS
AND THE COMPANY. I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANKS YEAH. THANK YOU. I
JUST WANT TO JUST BE CLEAR FOR
THE RECORD, ALTHOUGH WE
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY AND THE
CONCERN ABOUT PRIVACY, THIS
COMMITTEE, JUST BASED ON
JURISDICTION, REALLY DIDN'T,
FULLY ANALYZE THAT ISSUE. I WILL
SAY THERE WERE SOME ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE ISSUE, BUT
KNOWING THAT THE BILL IS MOVING
ON IN SOME SENSE TO COMMITTEES
THAT WILL TAKE A GREATER
INTEREST IN, PRIVACY, ESPECIALLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO I'M SURE
YOU'LL HAVE MORE OF A DISCUSSION
THERE ON THAT ISSUE. I WOULD SAY
THERE ARE CONCERNS, BUT YOU
KNOW, AND AS IT AS ONE SENATOR
HOUSLEY, THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE, I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT, THERE'S A WHOLE LOT THAT
NEEDS TO BE RECONCILED OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW. YOU KNOW, GIVEN THAT
WE HAVE A TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES AND OTHERS THAT ARE
NOW, YOU KNOW, USING USING THE
VERY OR TRYING TO USE THE VERY
IPHONES THAT WERE WERE PACKING
AROUND WITH US, TO PAY TOLLS
AUTOMATICALLY TO, TO BASICALLY
TO TRACK US THROUGH THE FREEWAY
SYSTEM. I AM NOT SUGGESTING THAT
THERE'S NO CONCERNS WITH THAT OR
THAT TWO WRONGS WOULD MAKE A
RIGHT, BUT SOMEHOW THAT'S ALL
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RECONCILED
IN THE FUTURE. I DON'T THINK
IT'S JUST THIS PARTICULAR GPS
TRACKING THAT WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT. WE SHOULD
PROBABLY BE CONCERNED ABOUT,
DATA PRIVACY ACROSS THE BOARD.
THESE DAYS, SO WE JUST DIDN'T
REALLY DEAL WITH THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS HERE BY DESIGN, AND
WITH THAT, WE'LL TURN TO, THE
AUTHORS DESIGNEE TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER. YOU MAY
CLOSE. WELL, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'D LIKE TO THANK ONCE
AGAIN, THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK THOSE WHO HAVE
COME OUT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. AND, YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR AND SHE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO ENSURE
THAT, THIS TECHNOLOGY DOES NOT,
BREACH ANYONE'S PRIVACY OR THEIR
RIGHTS, ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
VICTIMS. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB 38 3138 AND DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? SO MOVED MOVE BY SENATOR
DODD. I'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT TO
TAKE THE ROLE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 26, AB 3138. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATORS
CORTEZ, CORTEZ I, NILO NILO I
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I
BECKER, BLAKE. SPEER, BLAKE.
SPEER I DALLEY. DODD I DODD I
GONZALEZ. LAIRD. LIMÓN NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. WEN I SATO.
SATO I UMBERG. 801 ALL RIGHT.
THAT IS AT AN 8 TO 0 VOTE, WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL, THOUGH, FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND AGAIN, WE
THANK WE APPRECIATE THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY ON BOTH SIDES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. AND, AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER, YOUR OWN
BILL. YES. ITEM 27, THIS WOULD
BE AB 3139 FOR THOSE FOLLOWING
ALONG AT HOME. YES. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, GOOD EVENING, MEMBERS. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 3139, A BILL
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL VEHICLE
DATA PROTECTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. THE
CAPABILITIES OF MODERN VEHICLES
HAVE ADVANCED SO QUICKLY THAT
CARS ARE NOW SOMETIMES REFERRED
TO AS SMARTPHONES ON WHEELS. YET
THEIR INCREASED CONNECTIVITY
RAISES CONCERN ABOUT CONSUMER
PRIVACY BEING COMPROMISED.
RESEARCHERS HAVE ANALYZED 25 CAR
BRANDS AND IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
PROBLEMATIC PRACTICES, INCLUDING
EXCESSIVE COLLECTION OF PERSONAL
DATA AND LIMITED CONTROL
PROVIDED TO DRIVERS OVER THEIR
PERSONAL DATA. THIS POSES A
THREAT TO SAFETY, AND IN THE
CASE OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR, IT CAN MEAN A LIFE OR
DEATH SITUATION. JUST THIS
JANUARY, THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION
CHAIRWOMAN WROTE TO AUTO
MANUFACTURERS AS WELL AS
WIRELESS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
SEEK THEIR HELP IN PROTECTING
DOMESTIC ABUSE SURVIVORS FROM
THE MISUSE OF CONNECTED CAR
TOOLS BY ABUSERS. FOR THESE
REASONS, AB 3139 WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING IF FEASIBLE, AN AUTO
MANUFACTURER WOULD NEED TO
INSTALL AN OPTION ALLOWING A
CONSUMER TO IMMEDIATELY DISABLE
ALL REMOTE TRACKING TECHNOLOGY
WITHIN THE VEHICLE. ONCE
DISABLED, THE SURVIVOR WILL HAVE
SEVEN DAYS TO SUBMIT THE PROPER
DOCUMENTATION FOR THE CONNECTION
TO REMAIN SEVERED. IF THAT IS
NOT FEASIBLE, THEN THE VICTIM
WOULD NEED TO SUBMIT A SEPARATE
SEPARATION REQUEST TO THE
VEHICLE MANUFACTURER, INCLUDING
THE PROPER DOCUMENTATION, AND
THE VEHICLE MANUFACTURER WOULD
THEN BE REQUIRED TO SEPARATE THE
PERPETRATORS ACCESS FROM THE
REMOTE VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY. IN
ONE BUSINESS DAY HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS ROBERT HARRELL, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. WELCOME. YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATOR. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ROBERT
HARRELL WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
WE'VE WORKED ON PRIVACY ISSUES
WITH VEHICLES FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS, MOST RECENTLY WITH A BILL
BY SENATOR WIECKOWSKI, WHICH
THEN BECAME A BILL BY SENATOR
DODD THAT GOT SIGNED INTO LAW ON
IN-CABIN CAMERAS, ON THIS ISSUE,
YOU HAVE A TRULY HORRIFYING
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE IS BEING
TRACKED, AND THE, IN A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION AND, THE
FEDERAL LAW THAT THIS IS BUILT
UPON, THE SAFE CONNECTIONS ACT
BEGAN AS SOMETHING THAT WAS
FOCUSED ON, YOUR MOBILE PLAN AND
SEVERING TIES WHEN THE FCC WAS
TASKED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, TO LOOK AT THIS AND
FULLY, FULLY IMPLEMENT IT, THEY
BEGAN TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTO MANUFACTURERS FOR THE
REASONS THAT THE AUTHOR POINTED
OUT IN HER OPEN. I'LL CUT RIGHT
TO THE CHASE, BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A LONG AFTERNOON AND
YOU WAITED MOST OF IT TO GET
YOUR QUORUM, SENATOR. SO, THERE
ARE THREE BILLS IN THIS AREA,
THERE'S THIS BILL. THERE'S A
BILL BY SENATOR MIN AND THAT'S
VERY SIMILAR, HAS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES. AND THEN
THERE'S A THIRD BILL BY SENATOR
ASHBY THAT IS BROADER AND THAT
INCLUDES A WIDE RANGE OF
DIFFERENT SMART DEVICES. WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS. WE'VE HAD SOME
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
NOT ONLY THOSE OTHER AUTHORS
OFFICES AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED, I FEEL FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN GET THERE
ON ALL THREE BILLS IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY, ULTIMATELY, THE
OBJECTIVE IS VERY CLEAR FOR ALL
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS WORKING ON
THIS. AND THAT IS TO HELP,
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS,
PLAN SAFELY AND NOT BE TRACKED.
AND IN SOME CASES, LITERALLY,
WE'VE SEEN CASES WHERE WOMEN
HAVE BEEN KILLED AND SEVERELY
HARMED. SO WITH THAT, I'LL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS THE DEBATE
CONTINUES. ALL RIGHT. THERE
MIGHT BE SOME THANK YOU, SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
COME UP AND EXPRESS SUPPORT? IS
THERE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS? IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION? MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS KURT
AUGUSTI, AND I'M WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION. I AM NOT HERE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS AND THEY ARE
PRIMARILY ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER SOLUTION IS CHOSEN FOR
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE, THAT IT IS
ONE TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE.
AND WE DON'T OFFER FALSE
SOLUTION OR PROMISE TO
SURVIVORS. SECONDLY, MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE
PROTECTION FOR THE AUTOMAKERS ON
ANY LIABILITY ISSUES WHEN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS DENIED AND CUT
OFF. THIRDLY, AS MENTIONED,
THERE ARE THREE BILLS ON THE
SAME TOPIC AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET SOME RESOLUTION IN THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT IN APPROACH. AND THEN
FINALLY, THE OPEN ISSUE ABOUT
THE CUT OFF DATE, WE DO NOT OR
CUT OFF TIME. EXCUSE ME. THAT IS
NOT AN ISSUE FOR US. WE BELIEVE
THAT IS BEST SUITED FOR THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR
GROUPS TO WORK THAT OUT. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME DEBATE
ABOUT THAT, BUT WE'RE WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH WHATEVER THEY
WORK OUT ON THAT ISSUE. SO OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY METOOS
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR DODD DODD, MR. CHAIR,
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION READY TO GO. WE DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED, I APPRECIATE AS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
REFERENCE TO TRYING TO RECONCILE
WITH OTHER BILLS THAT ARE OUT
THERE, INCLUDING, I THINK, ONE
IN OUR HOUSE. AND I KNOW IT
HAPPENS TO THE BEST OF US TO
HAVE OVERLAPPING BILLS, BUT WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE WHATEVER YOU CAN
DO TO WORK THOSE THINGS OUT, AS
YOU INDICATED THAT YOU WOULD,
AND WITH THAT, WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD WITH SENATOR DODD'S
MOTION, AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE FIRST.
DOCTOR WEBBER, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SO IN MY CLOSING, I DO WANT
TO ADDRESS SOMETHING THAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS SAID WE HAVE
ALREADY COMMITTED TO TAKING
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS WHEN COMPLYING
WITH PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. WE
HAVE PROVIDED THEM WITH THE
LANGUAGE AND WE ARE WAITING FOR
THEM TO GET BACK TO US TO ENSURE
THAT WHATEVER WE CROSS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH AND, YOU KNOW, JUST
WANT TO ALSO ECHO WHAT MY
SUPPORT WITNESS SAID, THAT WE
ARE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OTHER TWO SENATORS WHO HAVE
BILLS THAT ARE SIMILAR TO THIS
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT HAS
ONE LANGUAGE AND IT'S NOT
CONFUSING, NOR CONFLICTING, AND
WITH THAT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR CARS BEING ABLE TO BE
TRACKED OR THEIR PERPETRATORS
BEING ABLE TO HARASS THEM
THROUGH THEIR CARS. AND SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON AB 3139. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN,
THE MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
DODD AND LOST THE ASSISTANT TO
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 27, AB 3139. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR CORTESE. CORTESE I NILO
NILO I ALAN ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA, I BECKER. BECKER I
BREAKSPEAR. BREAKSPEAR I DALLEY.
DODD I DODD I GONZALEZ. LAIRD.
LAIRD I LIMÓN LIMÓN I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. SERRATO.
SERRATO I UMBERG. TEN ZERO ONE
CALL. THAT'S A TEN ZERO. SO THE
BILL ISN'T OUT YET, BUT YOU HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES FOR IT. WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. APPRECIATE IT, WE ARE
GOING TO COME BACK TO CONSENT.
I'M NOT SURE. WE HAD A MOTION. I
HAVE SEVERAL MOTIONS ON BILLS BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. WE'LL GET TO
THOSE, BUT WE NEED. WE ARE. THE
CONSENT HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR NGUYEN. AND I'LL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO STATE CLEARLY.
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
HERE. AND CONSENT, PLEASE. SURE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 2401,
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB 1978,
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 2082,
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11 2130 FILE
ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 2186 17 AB
2645 FILE ITEM NUMBER 18 AB
2879. FILE ITEM NUMBER 21 AB
2817. FILE ITEM NUMBER 23 AB
2900. FILE. ITEM NUMBER 25 AB
3102. FILE. ITEM NUMBER 28 AB
3278. FILE ITEM NUMBER 29 SCR
159. ALL RIGHT. AND SO WITH THAT
MOTION FROM SENATOR NGUYEN, WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS CORTESE, CORTESE, I,
NEIL NEIL I ALAN ARCHULETA I
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
BLAKE SPEAR BLAKE SPEAR I DALLY
DODD DODD I GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ
I LAIRD I LAIRD I LIMÓN LIMÓN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN I NGUYEN. HI WINE
I SATO SERRATO I UMBERG I UMBERG
I 14 ZERO. SENATOR ALLEN JUST
WAITING. WE'RE WAITING ON
SENATOR ALLEN. SO IT'S 14 TO 0.
WELL, WE STILL HAVE ONE ABSENT
MEMBER, SO LET'S LEAVE THAT ON
CALL. BUT IT'S AT 14 ZERO, AND
LET'S NOW LIFT THE CALL ON THE
REMAINING BILLS. OH, I'M SORRY.
WE HAVE TWO. SO 13, 13, ZERO. MY
APOLOGIES. OH, SENATOR. YES,
SENATOR. SO WE HAVE TWO ABSENT
MEMBERS CURRENTLY. BUT AGAIN
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE BILLS ON
CALL. GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW UP HERE. ALL RIGHT. THE
MOTION ON FILE ITEM ONE WAS FROM
SENATOR ARCHULETA, ASSISTANT.
THIS IS FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
637. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AS SENATORS
CORTEZ I, CORTEZ I NILO I NILO I
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
BECKER, BLAKE. BECKER I, BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR I
DALI. DODD. DODD I GONZALEZ.
LAIRD LAIRD I LIMÓN LIMÓN I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NGUYEN
I CIERTO CIERTO I UMBERG I
UMBERG I. 12 TO 12 TO ZERO ON
CALL. 12 ZERO ON CALL. FILE ITEM
TWO WAS MOVED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB 1777. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED, AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
COURTESY A COURTESY I NILO NILO
I ALLEN ARCHULETA A ARCHULETA I
BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR.
BLAKE SPEAR I DALI DODD DODD I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LAIRD.
LAIRD I LIMÓN. LIMÓN I NEWMAN.
HI. NEWMAN I NGUYEN. SATO. HI
SATO I UMBERG I UMBERG I WHEN I
WHEN I, 13 ZERO ONE CALL 13 ZERO
BILLS ON CALL. MOVING THE FILE
ITEM FIVE I BELIEVE WAS ON OR
WAS OFF. I THINK IT MIGHT BE OFF
. FOUR WAS REMOVED. WE'RE MOVING
TO ITEM FIVE. FOUR FOUR WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. FOR THOSE
THAT WEREN'T HERE, FILE ITEM
FIVE IS AB 2127. WE HAD A MOTION
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA OFFERED IN
THAT MOTION IS STILL GOOD. SO
WE'LL ASK, THE ASSISTANT TO CALL
THE ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AB 2127. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS CORTESE A CORTESE I
NILO NO NILO NO ALLEN. ARCHULETA
A, ARCHULETA I BECKER. BECKER I
BREAKSPEAR BREAKSPEAR I DALI.
DODD A DODD I GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I LAIRD. LAIRD I LIMÓN
LIMON I NEWMAN NEWMAN I NGUYEN.
NO. ONE NO. SATO SERRATO. NO.
UMBERG I UMBERG I. 10 TO 3 ON
CALL. 10 TO 3 ON CALL. WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM SIX. THE OTHER
FURMAN BILL, AND THIS IS ALSO A
ARCHULETA MOTION. AND WE'LL ASK
THE ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. AB 2583. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED, AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SENATORS CORTESE A,
CORTESE I, NILO NÓ NIELSEN NO.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA A, ARCHULETA I,
BECKER. BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR,
BLAKE SPEAR I DALLEY DODD DODD I
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I LAYERED,
LAYERED I LIMÓN LIMÓN I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I NGUYEN CIERTO SATO I
UMBERG UMBERG. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE WE HAVE SEVERAL
LIVE MICS UP HERE. THERE'S A LOT
OF NOISE GOING ON ON THE DAIS.
SO JUST JUST A CAVEAT. THAT'S
ALL. IT'S NOT BOTHERING ME. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM 11 TO 1 ON CALL FOR YOU ARE
CHIRLA 11. I'M SORRY. THE LAST
FILE ITEM SIX IS 11 TO 1 ON
CALL. AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NINE. AT THIS TIME
THAT IS AB 3179. FOR ITEM NUMBER
NINE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS ALLEN DALLY, DODD DODD
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
LAIRD. BAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN
AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. 13 ZERO ONE
CALL. 13 ZERO ON. CALL IT WAS.
IT WAS A FOLLOW ME ABOUT THEM
ANYWHERE FILE ITEM TEN IS
SCHIAVO BILL AB 36 2086. AND
SENATOR ARCHULETA OFFERED THE
MOTION ON THAT BILL, WE'LL CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN,
AB 2086. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTEZ
Ã ORTEZ. AYE. NHIÀU AYE. NILO.
AYE. ALLEN ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BLAKESPEAR AYE. DALI
DODD. DODD. AYE. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. WHEN? AYE.
SATO. SERRATO. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
THAT'S. AYE UMBERG. AYE SHORT,
THAT WAS YOUR REAL SIZE. DID YOU
GET US? AND EVERYTHING'S GOING
TO BE SENATOR BECKER NOT VOTING.
BECKER YEAH. BECKER. AYE. 13
ZERO ONE CALL 13 ZERO ON CALL.
MOVING TO ITEM 13, WHICH IS AB
2678. AGAIN. SENATOR ARCHULETA
OFFERED THE MOTION ON THIS BILL.
SO WE WILL CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTEZ,
A COURTESY. AYE. NEELO. I'M
SORRY, WHAT IS THAT? TWO SIX.
SEVEN SIX. WALLACE. ITEM 12
1314. ITEM 13. OH I'M SORRY,
THIS IS NOT VOTING. SENATORS
ALLEN. ARCHULETA. Ã. ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER A BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
DALI DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
LAIRD A. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
LIMON. AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE. SATO. SATO
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG. AYE 12
ZERO ON A 12. ZERO ON CALL. GOT
YOU. PHÐ. ITEM 14 IS THE
AGUIAR-CURRY BILL. AB 2286. AND
WE'LL LIFT THE CALL ON THAT. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING. AYE.
SENATORS ALLEN BECKER, DALI
GONZALEZ, I GONZALEZ. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. NGUYEN SATO. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. YOUR HONOR,
TEN ZERO TEN ZERO ON CALL. FINAL
ITEM 15. THAT IS AB 2503. AND IT
WAS MOVED BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER
AT THE TIME. AND THAT MOTION IS
STILL GOOD. SO WE'LL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED,
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTEZ
Ã ORTEZ. AYE. NEELO. NO. NEELO
NO. ALLEN ARCHULETA, A.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. BREAKSPEAR.
AYE. DALI. DODD DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. MEANT
NO. SATO. SERRATO. NO UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. NINE 9 TO 3 ON
CALL. 9 TO 3 ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE
NOW TO ITEM 16. THIS IS A HER
BILL AND IT IS AB 2525. I DON'T
THINK WE AND I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THIS
BILL. IS THAT CORRECT MOTION.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR ARCHULETA HAS
MOVED THIS BILL WILL ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL. VOTE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 16. AB 2525. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
CORTESE, A. CORTESE. AYE. NEELO.
NO. NEELO. NO. ALLEN ARCHULETA A
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER A BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE DALI. DODD. AYE. DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. LIMÓN.
AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. ONE. NO. SATO. SERRATO. NO
UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE 10 TO 3 ON
CALL. 10 TO 3 ON CALL. FOLLOWED
HIM. 19 IS IRWIN BILL 2607 AND
26 2697. WE'LL LIFT THE CALL.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
NILO NO. NILO NO. ALLEN BECKER A
BECKER. AYE. DALI GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ. AYE LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
WHEN. NO. SATO SATO. NO. UMBERG
A UMBERG. AYE 10 TO 3 ON CALL.
10 TO 3 ON CALL. ITEM 20 IS THE
TAU BILL, AB. 2698. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING.
AYE SENATORS ALLEN GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN LIMON. AYE. SATO.
SATO. AYE UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE 14 ZERO ON CALL. WE'RE AT 14
ZERO ON CALL. ITEM 22 IS THE LOW
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL 2892.
ASSISTANT. OH, YES. SENATOR
ARCHULETA OFFERED THE MOTION ON
THAT BILL. HE INDICATES THAT'S A
GOOD MOTION. SO WE'LL ASK FOR
THE ROLL CALL, PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS, AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CORTESE
A CORTESE. AYE NILO. I'M SORRY,
WHAT BILL IS THAT AGAIN? AB 2892
22. NEELO. AYE. ALLEN ARCHULETA
A ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. DALI DODD. DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN LIMON.
AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE. WHEN I. SATO. SATO AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG. AYE 13 ZERO
ON CALL. 13 ZERO ON CALL. WE'LL
MOVE NOW TO THE HANEY BILL. FILE
ITEM 24. THAT IS AB 3061.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, ARE YOU STILL
MAKING THE MOTION? I AM MAKING
THE MOTION. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE. ITEM
NUMBER 24, AB 3061. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS. SENATORS
CORTESE Ã CORTESE. AYE. NEELO
NO. NEELO NO. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. BLAKESPEAR.
AYE. DALI. DODD AYE. DODD. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
SATO. SATO. NO UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE 10 TO 2. ONE CALLS.
10 TO 2 ON CALL. ITEM 26. AB
3138 IS THE WILSON BILL. THANK
YOU. CHAIR, LIFT THE CALL. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 26 AB 3138. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS ALLEN. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. DALI. OH, I'M
SORRY. GONZALEZ. AYE. DALI.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN.
AYE UMBERG. OH OKAY. 12 ZERO ON
CALL. 12 ZERO ON CALL. AND THEN
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, ITEM 27 AB
3139 WEBER. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING.
AYE. SENATORS ALLEN DALLI
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ AYE. NGUYEN
UMBERG AYE. UMBERG AYE. DUNN 12
ZERO ONE HÌ 12 ZERO ON CALL. LET
ME JUST ASK, IF WE HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON WHETHER THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WILL BE
RETURNING? NO. IF SERGEANTS HAVE
THAT INFORMATION. THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR. YEAH. THANK YOU. WHAT'S
UP WITH THAT?
I SEE YOU. WE HAVE BEEN JOINED
BY ONE OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR DULL, I'M GOING TO ASK
THE ASSISTANT TO LIFT THE CALL
AND GO THROUGH THE BILLS,
INCLUDING THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY, THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS ALLEN. DOLLY.
DOLLY, I PILE ITEM NUMBER ONE,
AB 637. SENATORS ALLEN. DALLY.
WHICH ONE DO YOU WANT? 630. OH,
YEAH. I'M SORRY. DALLY, I
GONZALEZ. OH, WE SHOULD CALL HIM
UP. ARE THERE STILL ON CALL?
SORRY. OKAY OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
DO DO YOU, DO YOU WANT TO SAY
WE'RE DOING THIS TWICE? WE'RE
DOING THIS NOW. AND THEN LATER
WHEN ALLEN COMES BACK, IS HE
STILL PRESENTING? YEAH. JUST GO
AHEAD AND GO THROUGH. OKAY. ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1777. SENATORS
ALLEN. DOLLY. DOLLY, I BUY ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, AB 2127. SENATORS
ALLEN, DALLY, I DOLLY I FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX. OH WAIT. I'M
SORRY. THAT'S A NO. I'M SORRY I
GOT THE WRONG FILE. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SENATOR DALLY, I TO NØ.
YES. AND FOR I WOULD FOR IS NOT.
OH, OKAY. THAT'S WHERE I GOT
MYSELF. OKAY. SORRY. THE VOTING.
ALL RIGHT, FOR ITEM NUMBER SIX,
AB 2583, SENATORS ALLEN DALLY, A
DOLLY, I NGUYEN FOR ITEM NUMBER
NINE, SENATORS ALLEN, DOLLY,
DOLLY, I FOR ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
2086. SENATORS ALLEN DOLLY.
DOLLY I CALL ITEM NUMBER 13, AB
2678. SENATORS NEELO ALLEN.
DALLY. NÓ DALLY NÓ FOR ITEM
NUMBER 14, AB 2286. SENATORS
ALLEN, BECKER, DALLY A DALLY I
NGUYEN, SEYARTO FILE ITEM NUMBER
15 AB 2503. SENATORS ALLEN DALLY
, NOT VOTING LIMÓN. FOR ITEM
NUMBER 16 AB 2525. HANG ON A
SECOND. SORRY, I'M SO SORRY. 14.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 14. I WANT TO
LAY OFF THAT BILL. OKAY, THEN
I'LL GO. NO, IT'S FINE FOR ITEM
NUMBER 14, AB 2280. HOLD ON, DID
YOU SAY YOU WANTED TO GO? NO, HE
WANTED TO GO OFF LAY. I WANTED
TO LAY OFF. YOU CAN'T BECAUSE HE
ALREADY VOTED ON THEM. SO YOU
WANT TO. OKAY. YOU WANT TO GO?
AYE. TO. NO. YES. YEAH OKAY. SO
WHY DON'T YOU CALL HIM AGAIN ON
THAT BILL SO HE CAN SAY IT ON
THE RECORD SO HE CAN SAY IT ON
THE RECORD ON ITEM 14. OKAY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 2286.
SENATORS ALLEN BECKER DALLY I TO
NÓ DALLY I TO NØ NGUYEN SUGIARTO
. FILE ITEM 15. OKAY, YOU VOTED
NO VOTE. OKAY ABSTAIN. YES. OKAY
FILE ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2525.
SENATORS ALLEN DALLY. OKAY FILE
ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 2697.
SENATORS ALLEN. DOLLY. DOLLY. NÓ
ITEM NUMBER 20, AB 2698.
SENATORS ALLEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
22, AB 2892. SENATORS ALLEN,
DOLLY. DOLLY, I, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 24 AB 3061. SENATORS
ALLEN DALLY. NOT VOTING OKAY
WHEN FILE ITEM NUMBER 26.
SENATORS ALLEN. DOLLY. DOLLY I
UMBERG FILE ITEM NUMBER 27.
SENATORS ALLEN, DALLY. NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU. WHEN OKAY,
COOL. WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND RECESS FOR APPROXIMATELY
FIVE, APPROXIMATELY
APPROXIMATELY TWO MINUTES, LESS
THAN FIVE MINUTES. IF YOU'RE, IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS STREAMED,
BUT WE WILL TURN OFF THE
MICROPHONES FOR A COUPLE OF
MINUTES. THANK YOU. LIKE THE
AND WE'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT.
WE'RE BACK. I SHOULD DO THIS
OFFICIALLY. OKAY, RECESS IS
OVER. WE'RE BACK. LIVE AND,
THANK YOU FOR CALLING THE
COMMITTEE. BACK TO ORDER, AND
WE'LL GET SENATOR ALLEN'S VOTES
ON THE RECORD. NOW, I'LL LET THE
ASSISTANT DO THAT. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATORS ALLEN
I ALLEN, I 15 ZERO OUT, 15 ZERO
BILLS OUT FOR ITEM NUMBER 1AB6
37 SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
GONZALEZ 14 ZERO 14 ZERO. OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 1777.
SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I 15
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. FOR ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 2127. SENATORS
ALLEN I ALLEN I 11. THE FOURTH
BILL IS OUT FOR ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB 2583 SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
, NGUYEN 13 ONE. THE BILLS OUT
FOR ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 3179.
SENATORS ALLEN I. ALLEN I 15
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT FOR ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2086. SENATORS
ALLEN I ALLEN I 15 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT FOR ITEM NUMBER 13
AB 2678. SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN
I OKAY. 1313 ONE THE BILLS OUT
FOR ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 2286
SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I BECKER
NGUYEN SEYARTO 11 ONE. THE BILL
IS OUT AB 2503 FILE ITEM NUMBER
15. SENATORS ALLEN I. ALLEN I
DALLY LIMÓN. TEN THREE THE BILL
IS NOW FILE ITEM NUMBER 16 AB
2525. SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
DALLY. 11-3 THE BILL. SO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 19 AB 2697 SENATORS
ALLEN I. ALLEN I 11-3. THE BILL
IS OUT FOR ITEM NUMBER 20 AB
2698. SENATORS ALLEN, THIS IS
THIS ORANGE COUNTY HIGHWAY
THING. IT'S 11. IT'S 14 TO 0
NOW. OKAY I. 15 ZERO THAT GOES
OUT. DIDN'T WANT YOU TO FEEL
ALONE ON THAT ONE. ALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER 19 SHOULD BE
CORRECTED 11 TO 4 EVERY TIME I
DRIVE. AND I'M GOING TO THINK
ABOUT THIS MOMENT, THERE'S STILL
A LITTLE NEGOTIATING GOING ON.
FILE ITEM 19. CORRECTING THE
CALL IS 11 TO 4. THE BILLS OUT
IN THAT VOTE OKAY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 20 AB 2698. SENATORS
ALLEN, THIS IS THE LITTLE YEAH I
OKAY. GOTCHA 15 TO 0 BILLS FOR
ITEM NUMBER 22 AB 2892 SENATORS
ALLEN I ALLEN I 14 ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. MY APOLOGIES. 15
ZERO CORRECTION 15 ZERO THE BILL
IS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 24 AB
3061. SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I
DALLY NGUYEN. 11 TO 2 11 TO 2.
BILLS OUT FOR ITEM NUMBER 26 AB
3138. SENATORS ALLEN ALLEN I
UMBERG. 14 ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT
FOR ITEM NUMBER 27 AB 3139.
SENATORS ALLEN I ALLEN I DALLY
NGUYEN. 13 ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ALL RIGHT. AND THANK YOU
EVERYONE. VERY MUCH. I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO CONVENE THE
COMMITTEE. WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
RIGHT 2910 HEARINGS IN AUGUST.
IN AUGUST. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL WE
WILL BE BACK IN AUGUST. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO COMMITTEE STAFF
AND TO EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY. WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.